GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WERE GONNA LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING TONIGHT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS-
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS DON'T PRACTICES. TO
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN THE
CAPITAL SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY FOR
TODAY'S HEARING CENTER MELENDEZ
IS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY-
THURMOND IS ARE YOU HERE. I AM
HERE ALL RIGHT DO YOU HAVE
STAFF WITH YOU I HAVE MANDA
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WELCOME- DOES PROVIDING
TESTIMONY TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND FOR
OF COURSE IF YOU'RE A REMOTE
PARTICIPATE YOU HOPEFULLY KNOW
THE DRILL BY NOW PLEASE MEET
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS- USED
TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN
THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU'D
LIKE TO BE. TO SPEAK AND THEN
AFTER THAT ARE I. T. PERSONAL
PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU
ARE DONE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS SEE ANYBODY IN THERE
RIGHT NOW. BUT TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING ALLOW
THEY WILL BE THERE AND THEN
WILL ALSO BE USING OUR
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ALSO IS TO
TESTIFY TODAY. A INDIVIDUALS
WHO DO WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT ARE TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN
FOUR NINE SEVEN NINE EIGHT
SEVEN. HAVE YOU NEED MORE
DETAILS PLEASE CONTACT THE
COMMITTEE- AND OR THE SENATE
WEBSITE PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AGAIN PLEASE MUTE YOUR
DEVICE YOU'RE SPEAKING ON. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE HEARING. FROM THE REMOTE AB
MEETING AND HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED- PLEASE BE
PATIENT WE ARE MAKING EVERY
ADJUSTMENT WE CAN'T BUT
SOMETIMES THINGS TAKE SOME
TIME- TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE
JUST THE GOVERNMENT DISCUSSING
THE MEET REVISED PROPOSALS FROM
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCY- THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. AND THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AGAIN TODAY WE ARE NOT GONNA BE
TAKING ANY. VOTES ON THINGS BUT
WE'LL BE HEARING ALL THESE
THINGS AND LEAVING THESE ITEMS
OPEN. FOR TODAY'S HEARINGS WILL
BE HEARING ALL THE ITEMS WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF MANTA IN PART
A AND PART B. BEFORE TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL THE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA WILL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AT THE END FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON ANY
AGENDA ITEM- NOW WE'RE TO BEGIN
WITH- PART EIGHTY. OF OUR
AGENDA AND WE ARE GOING TO-
WELCOME. THE ADMINISTRATION OF
FOR THEIR PRESENTATION. ON THE
FIRST ISSUE WHICH IS NOW. A
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. PERCY. RIGHT ACR DAR
DAR DR MARK KELLY HERE WITH US.
YES OUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS ARE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME TIME
WITH YOU AND TALK ABOUT A
COUPLE OF THE KEY ARE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES PROPOSALS
AND- MAY REVISE- WE ARE GONNA
START. I BELIEVE WE'RE AT THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION- AND I WILL KICK US
OFF AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE STEPHANIE WELCH ARE.
WHO WILL CARRY FORWARD THAT
ITEM AND THEN I BELIEVE- THE
AGENDA HAS US MOVING INTO
CHILDREN'S BEAVER HALL PROPOSAL
AS WELL SO FIVE IF IT'S OKAY-
CENTER EGGMAN I WILL START ON
WITH THE OFFICE AND YOU CAN
RESTORATION SOMETIME THAT'S
JUST FINE THANK YOU SIR. GREAT
BOB SO AS ARE AS I THINK ALL OF
US HAVE BEEN TRACKING- WHEN
GOVERNOR NEWSOM CAME INTO
OFFICE THE PLAN- EVEN BEFORE I
TOOK THE POSITION AS HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SECRETARY. WAS
TO CONSIDER. MOVING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
OUT OF CDCR INTO HELPING HUMAN
SERVICES AS A DEPARTMENT. OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION- THE CONCEPT THERE
WAS TO REALLY BUILD UP. A PLAN
TO FOCUS ON YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
YOU'VE HEALTH FOCUS ON THE
SERVICES WITHIN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY BROADLY
ALL OF OUR DEPARTMENTS THAT IT
COULD AID NOT JUST IN
PROGRAMMING IN DJJ FACILITIES.
BUT ALSO IN THE WORKS TO
FACILITATE COMMUNITY PROGRAMS
UPON REENTRY AND EVEN BEFORE-
INVOLVEMENT IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM WITH DIVERSION BOB BILL
TIME I'VE BEEN PRACTICES THAT
HAVE BANNED OF ALL BEING IN
CALIFORNIA FOR QUITE SOME YEARS
ACROSS THE NATION IN FACT. THE
FOCUS ON WHAT I'VE ALWAYS LIKED
TO CALL A CARE FIRST SIR THIS
IS FIRST MODEL. FARM TO THE
PANDEMIC- THE PLAN TO CREATE A
DEPARTMENT- WAS- SHOULD SHELVE
TO SIMPLY IN LIEU OF AND AN
APPROACH WHERE- WAS INITIALLY
THE- YOUNG PEOPLE ACT. FIVE DJJ
FACILITIES NOW PROPOSED TO BE
MOVED BACK TO THEIR HOME
COUNTIES- HANDED BUILDING-
PROGRAMS WITHIN BOTH PROBATION
FACILITIES BUT ALSO. CONTINUING
TO FOCUS ON BUILDING UP THOSE
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
SO TODAY WE PROPOSE IN THE MAY
REVISE AN EXPANSION OF WHAT WAS
THE JANUARY PROPOSAL- WHERE IN
THAT OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION AT HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
WOULD BE BUILT OUT. WITH OF
COURSE A DIRECTOR AND W. UNDER
THAT DIRECT. BUT NOW MOVES FROM-
SEVEN VISIT UP TO THIRTY
POSSESS. AS WELL AS SOME-
RESOURCE TO HELP US. THE IN THE
COMMUNITY I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT IT'S A REAL PRIVILEGE TO
BE ABLE TO PRESENT THIS PROJECT
I THINK. THERE IS SUCH A VALUE
I'VE SEEN IT FIRST HAND IN MY
WORK IN LOS ANGELES BEFORE
COMING TO THE STATE THE ABILITY
TO WORK ACROSS BOTH COUNTY AND
LOCAL PARTNERS ON- PUBLIC
SAFETY SIDE- HUMAN SERVICES AND
HEALTH SIDE. MANY MANY
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS AND
ADVOCATES TO REALLY BUILD UP A
SERIES OF PROGRAMS THAT GIVE
YOUNG PEOPLE A CHANCE TO BE
ENGAGED IN MEANINGFUL PURSUITS-
DURING THOSE. FORMATIVE YEARS-
WELL IN ADVANCE WE HOPE OF
INVOLVEMENT IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM BUT FOR THOSE WHO DO
HAVE ENCOUNTERS WITH OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY SYSTEMS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROVIDE A FULL ARRAY OF
SERVICES THAT FOCUS ON
DEVELOPMENT HEALTH AND OTHER.
CORE SERVICES TO REALLY CHANGE
THE TRAJECTORY OF YOUNG
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND I THINK WE
SAW SUCCESS IN POCKETS OF
CALIFORNIA I CAN SPEAK TO SOME
OF THOSE SUCCESSES IN LOS
ANGELES WORKING ACROSS MULTIPLE
ARM. SECTORS TO REALLY CREATE
THESE PROGRAMS AND AS SOMEBODY
WHO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF TAKING
CARE OF YOUNG PEOPLE BOTH IN
JUVENILE HALLS AND CAMPS. CAMPS
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES TO SEE
THE IMPACT THOSE PROGRAMS CAN
MAKE- WHEN THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE TRANSITION TO THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE REALLY- FOCUSED ON
THESE TWO CORE PILLARS OF THE
OFFICE. ONE REALLY WORKING WITH
FROM PAR ARE BOARD JOINED. THAT
THIS. ANDTHOSE THIS LOCKED OF
MY SO. ARE UP APPROACH AND-
ATTY TO THE ENRICHMENT SAFETY
OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE OF BUT EVEN
MORE. FOCUS ON BUILDING UP THE
ARRAY OF COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE-
LINKING THEM TO THE MANY MANY
DIFFERENT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES- SERVICES WHETHER IT'S
ON THE HELP SIDE IN MEDICAID
TAKING ADANTAGE OF SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WILL BE GROWING.
MORE AND MORE THROUGH THIS MAY
REVISE IN CATALAN AND OTHER
FEATURES- SOME OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
THAT WE HOPE TO BUILD ON AS
WELL BUT THEN. ON OUR SOCIAL
SERVICES SIDE AND OUR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SIDE
SOME OTHER CORE SERVICES AND-
SUPPORTS THAT WE KNOW CAN
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
NOT JUST THE YOUNG PEOPLE OF
FAMILIES IN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY COME FROM AND THAT
THEY WILL RETURN TO- WE HOPE. A
LITTLE BETTER OFF AND ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN SORT OF GROWING
UP- IN CALIFORNIA LIKE WE WANT
FOR ALL YOUNG PEOPLE SO IT'S
OUR I THINK A REAL OPPORTUNITY.
TO CONTINUE TO LISTEN TO THE
ADVOCATES CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
SOME OF THOSE PRINCIPLES OF
EQUITY- DAD WE HAVE BEEN
BATTLING THROUGH COVERAGE AND
REALLY TAKE IT HEAD ON THROUGH
THIS OFFICE. AND IN A
COLLABORATIVE WAY WITH OUR
COMPANY PARTNERS AND TO THOSE
MANY MANY COMMUNITY ADVOCATES
THAT WE TRUST. THE BOTH- KEEP
US ON OUR TOES HEALTH US PUSH
TO BETTER OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IN.
FROM THE SHIP THEM THE FAMILIES
IN TWO. THAT WE- HAVE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SO WITHOUT ALL STILL
TURN IT OVER TO STEPHANIE-
PLEASE ADD ON ANY OF THE
DETAILS LIKE OVERLOOKED- BEFORE
WE END THIS PART OF THE
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
MISQUOTE. AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR- SO I AM GOING TO JUST GO
OVER SOME OF THE NUTS AND BOLTS
REALLY QUICKLY- TO TALK ABOUT
THE SPECIFICS OF THE- UPDATE TO
OUR PROPOSAL- SO WE ARE
REQUESTING NOW A TOTAL OF
THIRTY THREE PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR AND
SEVEN POINT TWO MILLION I'M
GOING. TO ESTABLISH AN TO THAT
MANAGE THE OFFICE THAT'S AN
INCREASE OF FOURTEEN- BUT AS IT
STANDS ORIGINALLY WE HAD
REQUESTED NINETEEN I'M GONNA
JUST QUICKLY HIGHLIGHT WHERE WE
HAVE MADE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN ORDER TO. BE
RESPONSIVE TO THAT REQUEST AB
FROM OUR AD THE KIDS AND THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING ON THE
GROUND IN THESE PROGRAMS. FOR
WHAT WE HAVE DONE. IS IT REALLY
EXPANDED OUR POLICY UNIT- BROWN
THREE POSITIONS TO EIGHT
POSITIONS ADDING TO RESEARCH
POSITIONS AS WELL AS ATTY- AND
THE HEALTH AND JUSTICE POLICY
EXPERT POSITIONS AND WE'RE VERY
EXCITED THAT THAT OFFICE WILL
NOW HAVE THE CAPACITY TO IN
HOUSE REALLY DO SOME RESEARCH
PROJECTS- THAT WILL DRIVE OUR
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
WILL PRODUCE- ANNUALLY IN A
REPORT THAT WE WILL PROVIDE TO
THE LEGISLATURE. WE ALSO
EXPANDED OUR COUNTY
COORDINATION UNIT FROM THREE
FULL TIME STAFF TO EIGHT FULL
TIME STAFF AND THIS PARTICULAR
UNIT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
REVIEWING THE LOCAL JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT PLANS THAT-
OUTLINED WHICH SERVICES AND
WHICH TARGET POPULATIONS WILL
BE SERVED- WITH THE MONEY
THAT'S COMING FROM THE STATE TO
SUPPORT THE REALIGNED YOU- THIS
WILL ALSO BE THE UNIT THAT
REALLY PROVIDES KIND OF- AND-
SO I'M KIND OF LIKE ARE YOU
EYES AND EARS IN TERMS OF WHAT
FUTURE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS
NEEDED. I AND I WILL COME TO
RESOURCES THAT WILL BE FOR THAT
IN JUST A MOMENT AND THEN WHAT
WAS WHAT IS NEEDED- AND-
RESPONSIVE TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE COMMENTS FROM. OUR OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS IN ADVOCATES IN
THE COMMUNITIES IS TO CREATE A
SEPARATE ARMS PERSONS UNIT THAT
UNIT WILL NOW HAVE SEVEN STAFF
INCLUDING THE CHIEF THAT WILL
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR WORKING WITH
OUR NEARLY AT THE ADDED DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AS WELL AS OUR IN
HOUSE COUNSEL. THAT IMPLEMENT
BEST PRACTICES AND INCREDIBLE
REVIEW PROCESS AND IMPLEMENT
STRATEGIES TO ENSURE. THAT WE
ARE HE CONFIDENTIAL WILL BE
RISK. TO AT. REQUEST THAT COME
INTO THE OFFICE TO. A CIGARETTE.
AND WE WITH THE ADDITION STAFF
THAT ARE DEDICATED SOLELY TO
THAT IN A MORE TIMELY FASHION-
ADDITIONALLY- WE HAVE WILL BE
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR POSITION
FROM A CAREER EXECUTIVE
ASSIGNMENT TO AN EXACT POSITION
AND WE BELIEVE THIS GIVES US
FULL FLEXIBILITY TO RECRUIT. A
TALENTED LEADER AND SOMEONE WHO
CAN BE AN EXPERT IN THE FIELD
AS WELL AS- REALLY BE
RESPONSIVE TO OUR LOCAL
IMPLEMENTERS AS WELL AS- AS THE
LEGISLATURE- AND- WE HAVE ADDED
ALSO THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR. NXT
EIGHT POSITION IT REALLY CAN
BRING ADDED EXPERTISE BUT ALSO
KIND OF SOME MANAGEMENT MUSCLE
TO THE OFFICE NOW THAT IS
LARGER AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
REALLY IMPLEMENTING QUALITY
PERFORMANCE MEASURES- SO THAT-
I THINK. I WILL HI AND WE CAN
TAKE ANY PARTICULAR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYTHING
FROM OUR DEPARTMENT FINANCE ON
THIS. THERE WAS A PART OF
FINANCE NOTHING AT THIS TIME.
HOW ABOUT THE L. A. L. MORROW
WITH THE L. A. L. WE HAVE NOT
RAISED CONCERNS IN THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I'VE I NOTE THAT
THEM WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EXTRA TENSION IN THIS BECAUSE
WE KNOW- IF ANYTHING WE REALLY
NEED TO MAKE SURE I MEAN I
THINK IT IS A GREAT IDEA TO
HAVE OUR KIDS SERVING. IN THE-
IN THE COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY
CAME FROM AND LIKE I SAID
THEY'LL BE GOING BACK TO IN
HOOKING UP WITH THE RESOURCES
TO ENSURE SUCCESS. SOONER THAN
LATER- CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE ARMS BUT
EVEN POSITION NOW THAT IT
DOESN'T HAVE- SOME OF THE SAME-
ED. RESPONSIBILITIES AS SOME OF
THE OTHER ONES WITHIN OUR OUR
SYSTEM. LIKE IT CAN THIS THIS
OMBUDSMAN CANNOT ACCESS
RECORDS- DON'T WE- WEARING YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT HAVING A LITTLE
BIT MORE TEETH IN THE OMBUDSMAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
STAYS. SAFE AND WE'RE NOT WE'RE
NOT MISSING ANYTHING DURING
THIS PROCESS. SO- IN OUR
ASSESSMENTS- AND IT. WE HAVE
PROBABLYABOUT TEN THOUSAND USE
THAT FALL WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF THE ARMS PERSON
THAT HAS BEEN OUTLINED IN SB
EIGHT TO THREE- AND SO THOSE
ARGUES THE LAW WHO ARE ON
PROBATION AND THEY'RE IN AND
OUT OF HOME PLACEMENTS- I THINK
THAT WE HAVE SEVEN STAFF AND AN
IN HOUSE COUNSEL AS WELL AS
YOUR SHIP FROM OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. ED WE WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TAKE- TAKE IN THOSE
AT THOSE CONCERNS FROM THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND STASHED THEM
OUT REFER THEM TO OTHER
DEPARTMENTS OR OTHER ENTITIES
WHICH MAY BE A SIGNIFICANT PART
OF THERESPONSIBILITY- AS WELL
AS TO USE THAT INFORMATION
SOMETHING NIGHT ACTUALLY LEFT
ITS MENTION BEFORE I APOLOGIZE
IS THAT WE ARE REQUESTING TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING. IN CONSULTING FUNDS
WHICH THIS REPRESENTS- A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN WHAT WE
ASK FOR IN JANUARY AND THAT'S
REALLY BECAUSE WE WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO BE HIGHLY NIMBLE AND
RESPONSIVE TO THE UNIQUE NEEDS
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND SO PRISTINE TRENDS OF
RECEIVING- CONSISTENT THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE RESOLVED WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROCURE
EXPERTISE TO BE. PROVIDED TO
OUR LOCAL IMPLEMENTERS TO
QUICKLY RIGHT BUT IN AND GO THE
OTHER DIRECTION IN TERMS OF
BEING MORE INNOVATIVE I THINK
WE ALSO SEE THIS IS AS KIND OF
AN AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COUNTY'S
RIGHT OUT THE GATE AND WE. NEED
TO THINK ABOUT DEVELOPING. AS
THE KIND OF PROGRAM THAT
FRANKLY ARE REALLY AN EXISTING
AND OR THE- ONE PLACE NOT IN A
AND HOW AT LEAST. THE COUNTY'S
ADAPT TO MODEL THAT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THEIR SIZE AND
THEIR REGION AND THE NEEDS OF
THEIR- PARTICULAR UNITS SO- SO
I THINK OF HAVING THOSE TWO
RESOURCES AT OUR DISPOSAL- YOU
KNOW GIVES US WHAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO IMPLEMENT WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DIRECTED TO DO UNDERNEATH
THE JURISDICTION THAT WE'VE
BEEN PROVIDED WITH. SB EIGHT
TWO THREE. OKAY WELL I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE-
OF AN HONEST PERSON AND MAKING
SURE THAT THAT PERSON HAS THE
SAME. AUTHORITY AND- AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
ABOUT THESE ARE- INTO SOME OF
THEM ARE YOU THEMSELVES BUT
THERE HAS TO BE SOME LEVEL OF-
BOTH RESPONSIBILITY- AND PEOPLE
WHO THEN HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TAKE ACTION. IF NEEDED. AT THE
CURRENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CARE EGGMAN I TO I JUST Y.
EXPRESS THAT- WITH THE
OMBUDSMAN SHOULD ALSO. AGREE
THAT- SHOULD BE- MODELED AFTER
SOME THE OF- WILLIAM BIRDS MEN
AND WHERE THEY HAVE THE- YOU
KNOW THE AUTHORITY. TO BE ABLE
GET ACCESS TO RECORDS
INVESTIGATING SO FAR SO THEY
CAN ACTUALLY. TRULY FULFILL
THEIR DUTIES CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- THAT THERE'S OTHER
STAFF THAT CAN ALSO HELP YOU
SUPPORT BUT- BUT SOME OF THEM
SELVES BY DEFINITION SHOULD
HAVE. SHOULD BE SOMEONE WHO
CAN. BE NUMBERS BUT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
ADVOCATE. I GUESS THE OTHER
QUESTION YOU MEANT YOU DID
MENTION ABOUT- YOU KNOW FUNDING
FOR CONSULTANTS AND CERTAINLY
CONSULTANTS HAVE THEIR PLACE- I
GUESS THAT'S MY QUESTION THERE
IS THAT- THE WHAT DEGREE. ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT BUILDING
CAPACITY WITHIN THE STATE STATE
GOVERNMENT REVERSES-
CONTRACTING OUT TO OUTSIDERS TO
DO WORK FOR THE STATE SO
CERTAINLY IF THERE'S A
PARTICULAR EXPERTISE THAT WE
ONLY NEED TEMPORARILY- WE CAN
USE CONSULTANTS BUT I ALSO- AND
I APPRECIATE THAT. YOU'RE
PROPOSING ALSO HIRING PEOPLE
HERE WITHIN THE STATE TO BUT- I
CAN YOU CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO
THE ROLE OF THESE CONSULTANTS
AND- AND- YOU KNOW TO WHAT
DEGREE. ARE TRYING TO BUILD
CAPACITY WITHIN THE STATE
VERSUS- USING VERSUS
CONTRACTING OUT. OUR TASKS. I
MIGHT TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A
STAB AT IT BUT THEN I ALSO
THINK I AM THE SECRETARY MIGHT
HAVE SOME THOUGHTS AND YOU KNOW
I THINK INITIALLY THIS IS- THIS
IS AN AWESOME UNDERTAKING AND A
TREMENDOUS. OPPORTUNITY AND I
THINK. THE FLEXIBILITY WITH
THOSE KINDS OF FUNDS ALLOWS US
TO WORK WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNER
TO IDENTIFY WHAT EXACTLY O
THEY NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL. AND
I THINK BECAUSE THIS IS TONIO
AND WE WANT TO DO A GOOD JOB.
WE WANTED TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
FLEXIBILITY SO- CERTAINLY IT'S
REALLY MORE SO ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO BE RESPONSIVE. TO SUPPORT
LOCAL SUCCESS- ATTY IN IN IN MY
MIND OF MY VISION OF HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THESE
RESOURCES AND REALLY AVING IT
BE A PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR LOCAL
IMPLEMENTERS AND ALL OF OURS
ARE STAKEHOLDERS AND ADVOCATES.
SAY YOU KNOW HOW DO WE BEST USE
THESE FUNDS TO MAKE THE
SIGNIFICANT SYSTEM CHANGE- AND
SO. I'M HOPEFUL THAT THAT WILL
BE- POWER WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH. WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THOSE PLANS.
YEAH I WOULD ADD. SENATOR PAN
THAT. THE CERTAINLY THE BIG
APPROACH WITH- CONSULTANTS ARE
GOING TO STOP MAKING THAT LOCAL
CONNECTION- WE ALL SEE THIS AS
LOCAL WORK. ARE YOU WILL BE
GUIDED BY PRINCIPLES AND IDEAS
THAT IT- EMANATE FROM ACROSS
THE STATE ARE REALLY WILL HAVE
TO BE IMPLEMENTED LIKE SO MANY
THINGS LOCALLY AND- AS I'VE
BEEN LISTENING TO VARIOUS
COMPANIES AT DIFFERENT STAGES
OF DEVELOPMENT OF THESE
PROGRAMS. HAVING THAT EXPERTISE
THAT MATCHES WHERE THEY ARE AND
BEING ABLE TO. LEVERAGE SOME
LOCAL KNOWLEDGE TO BUILD THESE
PROGRAMS IS GOING TO BE KIANA
HAVING RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
TAP INTO THAT KNOWLEDGE. EVEN
IF ONLY FOR A TEMPORARY PERIOD
OF TIME IS GOING TO HELP US
AND- AS YOU NOTED IT DOES NOT
REDUCE THE NEED FOR US AT THE
STATE LEVEL. TO CREATE THIS
EXPERTISE THIS LASTING
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE WORLD
HOLDING THIS WORKING CALIFORNIA
BUILDING ON BEST PRACTICES
ACROSS THE NATION. TAKING MAD
RESEARCH THAT WE KNOW OTHER
PLACES INCLUDING. PARTS OF OUR
OWN LOCALITIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CREATING SO WE
SEE IT IS BOTH. WE DON'T SEE
THAT THE CONTRACTING OUT
FUNCTION OF THE CONTRACTING
FUNCTION HERE IS REALLY TO
REPLACE THAT EXPERTISE AT THE
STATE LEVEL WERE REALLY
ENTHUSIASTIC AND EXCITED. TO
DEVELOP THAT KNOWLEDGE THAT.
AND FRANKLY THAT LEADERSHIP WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WORK IS NOT
ONLY GONNA CATECHOL CALIFORNIA
FORWARD BUT WILL WILL REALLY IN
THROUGHS ARE NATIONAL WORK. AND
HAVING THAT EXPERTISE WITHIN
OUR OWN. OFFICE AT HHS WILL BE
KEY AND SOMETHING THAT EVOLVES
OVER TIME SO IT'S REALLY FOCUS
TO STEPHANIE SAID ON THAT LOCAL
PIECE THAT LOCAL CAPACITY
BUILDING. FIRST AND THEN IT
ALSO SIMULTANEOUSLY BUILDING UP
OUR OWN EXPERTISE WITHIN THE ON.
THE NEW OFFICE OKAY THANK YOU.
AND WILL MOVE ON TO. THE NEXT
ARE YOUR NEXT BIG ONE DOCTOR
GALA CHILDREN HEALTH YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE.
RATES AND- IT IS YOU KNOW WITH-
I SEE ARE AND THIS OUR PROGRAM.
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE TO
PRESENT TOGETHER BECAUSE THEY
ARE IN FACT LINKED AND THAT
THIS LARGE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE FOCUSED ON YOUNG
PEOPLE- ZERO TO TWENTY FIVE I
THINK REALLY REPRESENTS- DOWN
PAYMENT ON. THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA AND- AS IT'S BEEN
SAID THAT- HOW WE SPEND OUR
RESOURCE OUR TIME IN OUR IN. IS
A TRUE REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES
FOR THE GOVERNOR AND MANY
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS- THESE
INVESTMENTS BOTH THE TIME AND
FUNDING IN YOUNG CALIFORNIANS
ARE CORE PILLARS JUST
SUPPORTING A STATE. THAT
THRIVES NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC HEALTH PUBLIC HEALTH
EDUCATORS SO MANY OTHER CHILD
FOCUSED PROFESSIONALS ACROSS
THE STATE ACROSS THE NATION
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC'S IMPACT ON YOUNG
PEOPLE. THOSE OF US YOUNG
CHILDREN I HAVE FOUR FIVE
WITNESSED FIRST THE CHALLENGES
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE FACED OVER
THE LAST FIFTEEN MONTHS FROM A
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL POINT OF
VIEW. AND ALTHOUGH THE TOLL HAS
BEEN TREMENDOUS WE CANNOT
BEHAVE AS THOUGH THIS IS ALL
NEW. OUR STARTED BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. IF THE PANDA AS A-
AND DEEPENED THIS SMALL DURING.
AND MANY OF US HAVE BEEN TRACK
THIS FOR A LONG. BUT THE SLOW
STEADY. IN B. HEALTH CARE. BY
YOUNG BE. BEN BUILDING FOR MANY
YEARS WE'VE SEEN. DOES BY
CHILLED WHO ARE SCREAMING OUT
FOR HELP. THROUGH BOTH THEIR
WITH NO TO TURN. TEACHERS AND
OTHER SUPPORTS SIMILAR. LONG
WAITS FOR SERVICES IF THEY
EXIST AT ALL. CONVERGENCE YOU
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE FILLING UP
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT IT'S FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES IN CRISIS BECAUSE
CHILDREN ARE STRESSED ANXIOUS
DEPRESSED AND IN SOME CASES
EXPERIENCING PSYCHOSIS.
COMMUNITY TOOLS TO ADDRESS THE
EARLY MANIFESTATIONS OF THESE
I'M- PLEASE IMPORTANT AND NOW
EXPECT CHANNEL. DOES DO NOT
EXIST IN THE STUFF QUANTITY AND
I OFTEN SAY PEDIATRICS IS THE
ULTIMATE FORM AN ADULT
PREVENTATIVE MEDICINE AND IT'S
NO WHERE MORE TRUE THAN WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. WITH A LINK
TO A OUR MOST WILL BEING AND
JUST A BILL- REALLY WHEN TO
SUCCESS ADULTS. AND COROLLARY
AS OUR SURGEON GENERALAS
HELPED SEE THAT INCREASE TALKS
STRESS AND EGGS TO. CHILDHOOD
WE SEE THAT UP FOR HOW OKAY IN
LATE TEENS EARLY A AND
THROUGHOUT ADULTS WE SHOULD NOT
MUCH MORE EVIDENCE TO INCREASE
ARE RESOLVED NOW. THE LINK
BETWEEN HOME INCARCERATION AND
UNDERTREATED CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND EMOTIONAL
HEALTH IS WELL KNOWN IF WE WANT
TO CHANGE THE ARC OF THE LIVES
OF THE NEXT GENERATION FEW
INVESTMENTS CAN BE MORE
IMPACTFUL THAN SUPPORTING YOUNG
PEOPLE THROUGH THE UPS AND
DOWNS OF GROWING UP AND BEING
ON OUR TOES READY TO SUPPORT
THEM WHEN OF MANIFESTING
BEHAVIORS EMERGE. WE KNOW THAT
IT AS WE WAIT AS WE WITNESSED
THOSE BEHAVIORS AND HAVE FEW
RESPONSES THAT THE CHALLENGES
AHEAD BECOME HARDER AND HARDER
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE I JUST TAKE A
MOMENT TO TELL YOU A STORY TRUE
STORY- THAT I EXPERIENCED
MYSELF AND- RIGHT OUTSIDE MY
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HOME QUIET
COMMUNITY TREE LINED AND A
NEIGHBOR CALLED ABOUT- YOUNG
MAN TURNED OUT TO BE FIFTY FOUR
WILL CALL MISTER MAN'S. WHO WAS
IN THE ALLEY- IN IS- YOU KNOW
FILL BLANKET HANDS DOWN TO HIS
KNEE IS TALKING TO HIM SO.
CLEARLY ALTERED ARM AND- YOU
KNOW BEING CHALLENGED FIVE I
HAD IT TO SIT WITH THEM IN THE
AFTER COLEEN SOME I KNEW AND
THE LAWSUIT AREA TO COME. HELP
AND I AM A CHANCE TO HEAR IS
ONE THAT REMINDS ME THAT AND
REMINDS ME TODAY LIKE SO MANY
OTHER STORIES THAT I KNOW AND
WE ALL KNOW OF HOW WE MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY MISTER MEMBERS BORN
IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES BUT NOT OF
SHIP AND- PRETTY AND TOUGH.
PART OF SOUTH LA- BEACH. JANGAN
IN- EARLY ON- JUSTICE INVOLVED
BY THE AGE OF OR THIRTY NINETY
REMEMBER WHICH WAS ON HIS WAY
TO THE- YOUTH OF THE WHERE HE
SPENT THE REST OF TEAM. ARE
THEY BROKE BACK HERE HE CLEARLY
DOES AS- OF JEFFREY IN
CHALLENGE THE LAW WITH. A BILL
OF BOSS MONEY AND- MENTAL
HEALTH DIED HE'S- WITHOUT. MADS
WITHOUT OF TO UP. HE CAME BACK
TO A FAMILY THAT. WASN'T REAL
PREPARE FOR HIM. AND- FOREIGN
HALF DECADE LATER A NUMBER OF
US DANCING COUNTY. ON IF YOU
WERE BACK TO PRISON SYSTEM. IN
AND OUT OF. IS IT WAS THERE AND
ALLEY ARE MY CORNER AND HE SAID
TO ME THIS MIGHT BE BUT THAT I
FIVE. GET HELP. MAN I WAS PROUD
IN TWO TO BE ATO REACH AND
SERVE THEM IN A SMALL WAY. BOB
BUT IT ROOM ME THAT PROGRAMS
LIKE THE ONE WERE PROPOSING
HERE IN THIS MAY REVISE GIVE US
A CHANCE TO IDENTIFY THE MISTER
MIMS IS YOUNGER. CHILDREN WE
KNOW THAT IT. HALF OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
EMERGING CAN BE DIAGNOSED BY
THE AGE OF FOURTEEN FULL THREE
QUARTERS BEFORE THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE- WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE UNDER SCALED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS ACROSS OUR
STATE AS A PRIMARY CARE
PEDIATRICIAN. SOMEBODY WORKED
WITH YOU'VE IN FOSTER AS I SAID
IN THE JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES IN LA. BUT NOT JUST
LOSS AND BUT STANFORD CAN.
SPEND LONG WAITS FOR OUT WHAT
FAN CAN EARLY HOW. EARLY
SUPPORT FOR CAN DISH THAT WE
KNOW JUST THE- OF MORE SERIOUS
CON. DOWN THE ROAD- THIS
OPPORTUNITY TODAY I THANK TO
MAKE THESE MEANINGFUL STRONGLY.
IN THIS PROGRAM AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. FIVE GIVE US. ENOUGH
LIKE NOT ANOTHER SOME P. HAVE
SAID. AND ASKED- WHAT WHAT
SORTS OF THINGS HAVE MORE. SUCH
A PROPOSAL- IN THE MAYBE BY
HELP HUMANS. IS IT'S LONG. A
FOCUS OF OURS TO REALLY BE
COMMITTED TO YOUNG PEOPLE
COMMITTED TO THEIR HOW. THERE
ARE WAS THE NEED FOR SOCIAL
SERVICES AND THOSE FROM. BUT A
UNIQUE TIME WHERE WE WILL SOME
ABOUT THE BAND. THROUGH THE
PANDA. ABOUT HOW TO DELAY.
EFFECTIVE HOW SERVICE. WHEN WE
DEPEND EVERYTHING HAPPENING IN.
ONE ROOM STRETCH NEEDED TO BE.
NOT JUST BUT MANY WAYS PERFECT.
WHERE WE KNEW THAT WE HAD TO
PEAK IN POWER OF OUR- IS WHERE
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO SERVICE
PREVIEW. WE JUST TO STICK ADAM
DID A LOT OF THE HIGH YEAH BUT-
TO. HELLO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. OF
THE MAN OF THOSE TOOLS. AS
BENEFIT BUT THEY CAN'T BE THE
ONLY STE. AND OUR PROPOSAL
DEPEND ON THOSE. BUT NOW
ENTIRELY. SIMILARLY WHEN HAVE
REACHED. LIKE WE DO NOW TO MAKE
ONE'S. IN FOR. INVEST SO THAT
IT YEARS DOWN THE ROAD WE NO
LONGER HAVE THE REASON THE
EXCUSE TO SAY WE WOULD REFER A
YOUNG PERSON TO SERVICES. IF
ONLY IT WERE AVAILABLE IF ONLY
IT EXIST AND TO REALLY FELT. ON
THE LESSONS AROUND EQUITY
LANGUAGE CONCORDANCE BUILDING
UP A WORK FORCE THAT NOT ONLY
SPEAKS OUR LANGUAGE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT LOOKS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED THE
SERVICES WE HAVE THIS
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY. HERE
AND NOW TO BUILD UP THESE
RESOURCES. AND SO THE PROPOSAL
WHICH WE HAVE PUT TOGETHER.
REALLY AREN'T WITH THE GOVERNOR
AT ITS FRONT AND BACK. TO FOCUS
ON ON KIDS PROBABLY CONNECTED
TO MANY OTHER THINGS THAT USE
AN THE JANUARY. REPOSE BUT AND
NOW READ MAY RECEIVE. WHETHER
IT'S THE CAN. TO THE CALLIN
BASSMAN THIS IN. THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED PROJECT. COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS OUR MANY INFRASTRUCTURE
AND BEING PER. AROUND THE BAY
HEALTH CAN. TO THOSE ARE
SERVICES LIKE B. R. OF YOU
THINK COMMUNITY REST. THE OTHER
SCHOOL MENTOR HEALTH IN. OF
WHETHER IT'S PLANNED MHSAA
FUNDING FOR THE PROPOSAL ON
BASEMENT HEALTH THROUGH OUR
MEDIC MANAGE CARE PLANS ARE WAS
PER IN. TODAY'S FROM THAT WE'RE
PRESENT I THINK IS THIS BROAD-
FOUNDATION TO BUILD UP THAT
RECORD. THE INVEST THAT ARE
READY X. SO TO SOME. THERE ARE
REALLY EIGHT COMPOUND TO OUR-
PROPOSE. THE FIRST IT'S WITH A
BEHAVE HEALTH SIR BY. THAT IS
FOCUSED ON BEING ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE ADULTS ZERO TO
FIVE IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT BEING HEY ERIC GNOSTIC
MEANING IT ISN'T JUST FOR KIDS
AND YOUNG PEOPLE ON MEDICAID
IT'S FOR ALL KIDS IN CALIFORNIA
FOCUSED ON EARLY INTERVENTIONS
FOCUSED ON IT BEING ANYWHERE
ANYTIME ANY LANGUAGE. MEETING
YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES
WHERE THEY ARE- AND THIS
VIRTUAL PLATFORM IS PLANNED TO
REALLY BE AVAILABLE TO ALL
YOUNG PEOPLE LINKED OUR SCHOOLS
ARE WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
EDUCATORS BOB BUILT ON A BIT OF
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOL MODEL BUT
HOPEFULLY AVAILABLE TO SCHOOLS
EVERYWHERE ACROSS THE STATE. OF
THAT BURCHELL POPCORN WILL
FOCUS ON ASSESSMENTS LINKAGES
TO OTHER TO- TO BEHAVIORAL TELL
OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH. WHETHER
THAT'S IN SESSIONS WORK BROUGH
BRINGING YOUNG TO FOR ACROSS
CAL SUPPORTING THEM IN THEIR
TO- THE VIRTUAL BUT KNOWING
THAT IS JUST FRONT. TO THE SINK
SET OF RESOURCES THAT NEEDS. TO
BE SO. THAT THEY ARE READY BUT
REALLY BILL. WE KNOW ALSO THAT
I'M- ON THE MENTAL HEALTH SO
WHERE WE HAVE A FRESH. SYSTEM
WITH GAPING HOLE FOR YEAH
PEOPLE ACHIEVING AND GETTING
THE CARE AND SERVE THEY- ON THE
SIDE USE DISORDER SIDE BRING WE
HAVE. A NEARLY NANA. SAID OF
SERVICE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE YES.
SOME STAR PROBE THAT I HAD TO
BRING OF SAN PAGE TO OVER THE
YEARS BUT THEY ARE FEW AND FAR
BETWEEN. THE OPERA TO BUILD UP
THE SUB USED SERVICES DO NOT
JUST VIRTUAL SERVICES A REAL
BREAK IN. SERVER AND A KEY
FEATURE OF THIS PLAN. THE
SECOND PIECE SORT OF BUILDING
ON THE A LITTLE BIT AS UP
CAPACITY AND IMPROVE. OF HEALTH
PLAN COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
ARE CBO INTERESTS AS WE
DISCUSSED THE THIRD. IS TO AND
SCALE UP APRIL HEALTH OF BASED
PROGRAM. THERE ARE MANY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE BUT THERE ARE THINGS TO
BE LEARNED FROM ACROSS THE
NATION AND THE GLOBE. THAT WE
CAN BRING TO CALIFORNIA IN THIS
MODEL THAT ALLOWS YOUNG PEOPLE
TO HAVE THEIR CARE ESSENTIALLY
STEPPED OUT. IF THEY NEED IT IF
THERE NEEDS CAN BE MET AND
SUPPORTED IN A VIRTUAL WAY.
TERRIFIC FANTASTIC BUT AS SOON
AS THEY WOULD NEED MORE WE
COULD TRANSITION TO MEANINGFUL
SET OF OTHER PROGRAMS AND THAT
LEADS TO THE DEEP COMMITMENT TO
BUILDING UP OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
MAIN. AND YOUNG PEOPLE'S BEHAVE
HEALTH THIS IS JUST OUTPATIENT
RESOURCE. WHERE CLINICIAN CAN
SEE YOUNG. FOR V. AND TREATMENT
BUT ALL- VIRGIN KERR CENTERS
WHICH I THINK'S COUNTY HAVE A
MANY DOWN. WHICH CAN SERVICE A
PLACE TO BE A CRISES PEOPLE IN
ALASKA CARE SETTING AREA FACT.
IN THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORLD
AND- SO WE COULD UP HERE MORE
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEN OF
COURSE WE'VE HIGH. BY THE DAY
OF THE END. AND OTHER-
EMERGENCY CARE SERVICE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE BUILDING UP THOSE
BEDS. SO THE WE HAVE TO
CAPACITY OF FOR THE MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTED YOUNG
PEOPLE TO GET THE CARE THAT
THEY NEED IT IN A CONVENIENT
WAY. CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY
NIGHTS I SPENT ON THE PHONE
WORKING WITH- COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IN LOS ANGELES BY
JENNIFER FIND PLACEMENTS FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE OUR REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY WERE IN. IN LOS
ANGELES WE OFTEN HAD TO SEND
YOUNG PEOPLE HOW TO COUNTY TO
GET THE THAT THEY NEED I THAT
IT ONCE EMPLOYED THIS FOR. DEAD
NO FAN NO. AND CAL. ASKED SEND
THEIR YOUNG TOO FAR AWAY TO GO
THE CARE NEED WE DO IT I CAN'T
BEING. AND BETTER WAY. AS WE
WANT TO. THE MEDI CAL. THROUGH
THIS PROPOSAL WE SEE AND- OF
IMPORTANT PIECES ARE BUILDING
UP DíAS SIR. ARE EVIDENT BASED.
THAT WE ON A- SO OF. THE GOAL.
SERVICES ACROSS- FAMILY ACROSS
YOUNG. THIS TREE AND THERAPIES
THAT ARE HAVE BASED BEING ABLE
TO SKI THOSE. KIDS IN THE MAY
ALSO. THERE AND SUPPORT AND SO
THAT BROUGHT YOUR NOT JUST IN
MATT. BUT- ALSO A- THE CARE CAN.
FOR CHILDREN EVERY INCOME- CAN.
TO OUR- HEALTH WORKER BEN THE
BEING. ALL IN JANUARY BUDGET.
INSURE THAT OUR- PROGRAM. FOR
AGES STE. THAT ARE SIR GENERAL
HAS BUILT UP. AND I KNOW HER
TEAMS HERE WITH US TODAY TO BE
ABLE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
BETWEEN. THAT THE IS SOMETHING
THAT ACCESS. ACROSS MY- IN THE
FUTURE WE ALSO LOOK AT THIS AS
A TRUCK. I TO BILL UP OUR FOR.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW. EXILE NEW
AND- I'VE HAD IT TO BE A PART
OF NOT JUST ON THE HEALTH SIDE
BUT SOCIAL. SIDE WHERE WE ABLE
TO BUILD FISCAL. FOR ABLE TO
BRING THE I. T. SYSTEM TO BEAR.
FUNDING IS NO LONGER THE MAIN
CHANNEL. YEAH WE- TO HAVE A
WORK FORCED. IT'S R. P. THAT WE
NEED WE NEED BUILD THEM UP WITH
AN AYE TO COLOR. NEW WHAT ARE
DOUBLE. COMMUNITIES SO THAT THE
WHO ARE WORKING IN CHOI AND
YOUNG. BEHAVE HEALTH ARE. ABLE
TO SEE TO CLAIM THERE FOR- AND
TO IT IN A WAY. THAT IS- TALK
HOLD TRUE ALIGNED SO. A LARGE
SET OF A- BOTH TO FOCUS ON BILL
UP THE WORK FOR. IN THE CAN.
THE AT OUR SCHOOL. AND IN
TRADITIONAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SPENDING- THERE'S AN EMPTY
PIECE WE NOW. THAT THE- BOTH
YOU AND YOUR DOCTOR PAN. WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
CONNECTIONS WHAT TO DO-
BUILDING UP THE CAPACITY TO
HAVE A STATE WIDE YOU REFERRAL
DE CONSUL TO STORM AVAILABLE TO
ALL PRIMARY CLINICAL- OF
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE
ENCOUNTERING YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
LINK NOT JUST TO SERVICES BUT
TO IMMEDIATE ADVICE ON HOW TO
SUPPORT THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE. AND
IF THERE ARE GUARDIANS AND
COMMUNITY IS TO- EARLY ON TO
GET THROUGH SOME UNIQUE
CHALLENGESWE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THE KEY ROLE ON COMMUNICATING
EDUCATING AND ENGAGING IN AND
OUT REACHING TO COMMUNITY IS SO
SIGNIFICANT CAMPAIGN PLAN. ROSS
YOU KNOW OVER BETWEEN OUR
PROFITS OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
AND DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REALLY BUILDING ON LESSONS THAT
WE- LEARNED DURING COVERED THAT
BALANCE THE NEED TO COMMUNICATE
CLEARLY AND SIMPLY BUT IN A
SOPHISTICATED WAY TO REACH ALL
PARTS. EVERY NOOK AND CRANNY OF
CALIFORNIA IN ALL LANGUAGES- SO
THAT NO ONE IS LEFT BEHIND- THE
LAST PIECE OF OUR PROPOSAL IS
FOCUSED ON COORDINATION AND
THERE'S A SPECIFICALLY THE PART
OF THE WORK THAT HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES WILL LEAD. THE
COORDINATION OF- THE BUILDING
BLOCKS ACROSS THE MANY
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS I THINK
WE HAVE SIX TO SEVEN
DEPARTMENTS OR OFFICES WITHIN
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES ALONE
THAT WILL BE WORKING ON THIS
PROPOSAL EACH WITH A DISTINCT
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE EACH PIECE
NEEDS TO BE CLEANED UP
COORDINATED FROM THE FRONT. AND
HHS LEADERSHIP AND POSITIONS
WITHIN OUR AGENCY WILL HELP DO
THAT COORDINATION THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO BRING ON. SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE TO BUILD
AROUND- STEPHANIE AND OUR
ENTIRE TEAM THAT IS VERY
ENTHUSIASTIC TO CONTINUE TO DO
THIS WORK. LEARN THE LESSONS
FROM APART COUNTY IS OUR
COMMUNITIES AND BE ABLE TO
ASSIMILATE BATTING THE BALL TO
MILLIE THE DESIGN OF OUR
PROGRAMS THE PROCUREMENT OF ANY
OF THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED TO
EITHER STATEWIDE OR BY REGION.
AND THEN OF COURSE THE VERY
NECESSARY IMPORTANT EVALUATION
COMPONENT THAT WE WANT TO BUILD
IN AT THE FRONT AND- WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT WUNDERBAR- I THINK
MANY CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE WILL
PAY DIVIDENDS TO YOUNG PEOPLE
TODAY. ARE REALLY ALSO TO OUR
FUTURE AND TO BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE AS ONE OF THE BOLDEST
STEPS THAT I'VE SEEN ACROSS OUR.
NATION FOR A BUILDING I'M
BEHAVE HEALTH. TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE CASE FOR WHAT WE LEARNED.
WHY WE DID IT AND HOW IT'S
CHANGED THE ARC OF YOUNG PEOPLE
AND FRANKLY THE COMPOSITION OF
OUR COMMUNITIES WHEN I LOOK AT
THE RATES OF INCARCERATION WHEN
I LOOK AT HOMELESSNESS AND I
SEE THE DIRECT TIES WE SPOKE TO
BEFORE. I SEE THE SHADOW IN THE
IMAGE OF MR MIMMS AND THOUSANDS
LIKE HIM IN OUR STATES I THINK
WE CAN BE PROUD OF AND EVALUATE
THE EFFORTS HERE THE SHOW. TO
SHOW THE IMPACT THAT WE HAVE.
SO WITH THAT MAN IN CHAIR I'LL
TURN IT BACK TO YOU WE ARE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS I NOW-
STEPHANIE AND- THE OFFICE OF
THE SURGEON GENERAL HERE THING
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS PROPOSAL-
AND WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO.
DOING THIS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE LEGISLATURE BUT ALSO ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE FOR SO
LONG. I REALLY COMMANDED THE
EXISTING LEADERSHIP AND LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING A PARTNERS.
LOCKSTEP FALL ALONG THE WAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- BEFORE
I TO THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND
ALEJO- ON BEHALF OF ME BUT I
BUT I THINK ALL OF US HERE DR
KELLY WE JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. DURING
THIS ENTIRE PANDEMIC YOU HAVE
REALLY BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES
AND PROVIDING A CALM VOICE OF.
REASSURANCE I THINK TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE- AND FURTHER I HAD AND I
KNOW WITH MYSELF AND I KNOW DR
PAM WE'VE ALSO MET. ALL OF
THOSE AT MISTER MEMBERS AND
HAVE A BEMOAN THE FACT. THAT WE
COULDN'T HAVE DONE MORE BEFORE
AND SEE SEE THE TRAGEDY ON OUR
STREETS TODAY OF. OF THINGS
THAT WE DIDN'T TAKE CARE OF
EARLIER SO THIS IS A BIG. AND
SO DOES THE SAME WE THANK YOU
FOR THE HEART THAT YOU BRING TO
US IN YOUR EXPERIENCES THAT
ARE- STILL CLEARLY VERY FRESH
AND YOU'RE ABLE THEN. TO BE A
VERY- ASTUTE PROBLEM SOLVER SO
WE THANK YOU AND YOUR ENTIRE
TEAM- WE'RE ALSO SAY THIS IS A
HUGE ENDEAVOR THAT THAT WERE
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING. AND THE
PROBLEM IS HUGE AND SO YOU'VE
GOT A- SOME OF THE HUGE ISSUE I
THINK WILL BE VERY. INTERESTED
IN THAT THAT TECHNOLOGY AS
WE'VE ALL BEEN STRUGGLING
THROUGH. ISSUES AROUND
TECHNOLOGY RIGHT NOW AND OF
COURSE. ALL OF THIS WILL TAKE
SOME TIME AND WE KNOW- I'VE
EXPRESSED DR PAN HAS CERTAINLY
EXPRESSED THAT WE HAVE A REAL
URGENCY NOW- IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- PORK THE FOLKS WE
TALKED ABOUT THE STREET A LOT
OF TIMES BUT- IN OUR CHILDREN
RIGHT NOW WE KNOW THAT THAT IS.
INCREDIBLY URGENT SO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT A LOT OF THESE LONG
TERM THINGS. WE CAN NEVER TAKE
OUR EYE OFF- THE EMERGENCY IN
FRONT OF US NOW. BERMAN FINANCE
ANYTHING FROM YOU ON THIS. AND
WE ARE ALMOST NOTHING MORE TO
ADD THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- LMAO NOTHING TO ADD ON
HERE. THANK YOU SENATOR EGGMAN
COREY WITH THE L. A. L. WE
CONDUCTED OUR INITIAL REVIEW OF
THIS INITIATIVE AND DO HAVE
SOME CONSIDERATIONS REYES. YOU
KNOW AS YOU KNOW THERE ARE
VARIOUS COMPONENTS TO THIS
INITIATIVE CUTTING ACROSS
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING
HHS AGENCY IN AUSTIN AT AS
BEING DISCUSSED TODAY. SO MY
COMMENTS TODAY WILL BE OVER
ARCHING IN NATURE FOCUSED ON
THE INITIATIVE AS A WHOLE.
FIRST WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
NO ACROSS THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS OF THE INITIATIVE
THERE ARE AREAS WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO NEED
FURTHER DETAIL TO PROPERLY
ASSESS THE MERITS OF EACH
PROPOSAL. YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS INDICATED
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
TRAILER BILL ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS INITIATIVE WHICH MAY
ANSWER SOME OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS BUT- THAT TRAILER
BILL IS NOT AVAILABLE FOR
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW AT THIS
TIME- IN ADDITION YOU KNOW
BASED ON THE INFORMATION THAT
IS AVAILABLE ABOUT THE
INITIATIVE WE FIND THAT IN
GENERAL- WHILE THERE ARE.
RELATIVELY SMALLER PORTIONS OF
THE INITIATIVE THAT RELATE TO
THE ONGOING PROVISION OF
SERVICES- SUCH AS A NEW
BENEFITING MEDIC CAL FOR DYADIC
CHAIR. STANDING UNDER THE
INITIATIVE WOULD LARGELY BE
FOCUSED ON ONE TIME INVESTMENTS
FOR CAPACITY IN INFRASTRUCTURE-
FOR EXAMPLE THE CREATION OF THE
VIRTUAL PLATFORM WHICH-
SECRETARY KELLY JUST MENTIONED-
THESE THESE ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS TO OVERALL BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DELIVERY HAVE MERIT. BUT
WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS TO CHILDREN
AND YOUTH AS A RESULT OF THESE
INVESTMENTS. MAY NOT ULTIMATELY
BE REALIZED UNTIL SOME YEARS
INTO THE FUTURE AND SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WISHES TO PRIORITIZE GETTING
SERVICES OUT TO CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
GIVING. YOU KNOW URGENT NEED WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THIS TRADE OFF
EXISTS BETWEEN PRIORITIZING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPACITY-
AND- OVER SORT OF SORT OF
SERVICES NOW. I NEXT THERE ARE
RELATIVE SMLLER COMPONENTS OF
THE INITIATIVE THAT- DO YOU
PROVIDE A FISCAL ESTIMATE OF
ONGOING SERVICE COSTS. IN
GENERAL THE ADMINISTRATION DOES
NOT SCORE ON GOING COSTS THAT
NEIGHBORS THAT MAY ARISE FROM
THE GREATER CAPACITY FOR
SERVICES THAT WILL- HOPEFULLY
RESULT FROM THE MAJOR ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OF THIS INITIATIVE-
THERE ARE ALSO THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER- PROPOSAL IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE TO. IMPLEMENT A STATUTORY
CHANGE TO REQUIRE COMMERCIAL
AND MEDICARE PLANS TO COVER
SERVICES IN SCHOOL- AND
SIMILARLY THERE'S- SORT OF NO
INDICATION OF A FISCAL ATTACHED
TO SORT OF THAT STATUTORY
CHANGE. YOU KNOW WE FIND IT
POSSIBLE THAT YOU KNOW THESE
INVESTMENTS WOULD RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL ONGOING COSTS THAT
WE SORT OF NEED TO BE ACCOUNTED
FOR- NEXT WE WOULD NOTE THAT A
SIZABLE PORTION OF THE
INITIATIVE. IS PROPOSED TO BE
PROVIDED IS GRANT FUNDING TO A
VARIETY OF ENTITIES- THESE
COULD INCLUDE YOU KNOW
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
SCHOOLS UNIVERSITIES COUNT
HEALTH- GIVEN THE MANY
DIFFERENT IN. THAT WOULD BE.
OUR WOULD SORT OF ELEGY TO FOR
IT FUNDS- WE FIND THAT KEEP.
WERE TO HOW THESE GROW PRO
WOULD BE TO. ESPECIALLY IN
TERMS OF WHAT RICK. PENSION ARE
MET. AT WOULD NEED TO MEET IN
ORDER TO OBTAIN FUNDS. WE NEED
TO SORT OF BE CLEARLY
ARTICULATED GIVEN THAT THESE
ENTITIES MAY HAVE DIFFERENT
CAPACITY- FOR MEETING
PERFORMANCE BENCHMARKS IN ORDER
TO- RECEIVE FUNDING UNDER THE
GRANT PROGRAMS- WE WOULD ALSO
JUST FLAG THAT YOU KNOW
SIZEABLE PORTIONS OF THE
INITIATIVES. ARE INTENDED TO
PROVIDE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
TO ALL CHILDREN AND YOUTH
REGARDLESS OF PAYER- SORT OF
BEYOND THE- SCOPE OF PUBLIC
PROGRAMS FOR WHICH THE STATE-
TRADITIONALLY WOULD HAVE MORE
RESPONSIBILITY OVER OVERSEEING-
YOU KNOW THIS THIS APPROACH MAY
HAVE MERIT BUT THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WISH TO CONSIDER- TO WHAT
EXTENT IT AGREES WITH THE
APPROACH OR- IF IT WOULD WISH
TO TARGET FUNDING TOWARDS- MORE
TOWARDS. PUBLIC PROGRAMS SUCH
AS MEDICAID HOW WHICH THE
STATUS REDUCE. BEEN MORE INFO
WITH- LAST WEEK GIVING YOU KNOW
THE ENORMITY OF THIS
INITIATIVE- WE FIND THAT
FLUSHING OUT THE EVALUATION
COMPONENT OF THE INITIATIVE IS
GOING TO BE VITAL- TO ENSURE
THAT. DEMONSTRATED MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES ARE ACHIEVED AS A
RESULT OF THESE PROPOSALS. THE
ADMINISTRATION MENTIONS IN ITS
AND MAKE IT INITIATIVE
DOCUMENTS THAT IT INTENDS TO
COMMISSION AN EVALUATOR TO SORT
OF EVALUATE ALL COMPONENTS OF
THE INITIATIVE- THIS IS REALLY
OUR EXTENT OF OUR END OF THE OF
WHAT EVALUATION COMPONENTS WILL
BE- BUILT. INTO THIS INITIATIVE
AND SO BASED ON THIS THE
LEGISLATURE MAIN WISH TO SORT
OF ASK ADMINISTRATION TO DRAW
OUT SPECIFICALLY HOW THE
INITIATIVE WILL BE. EVALUATED
IN MORE DETAIL YOU KNOW IT'S A-
SIZEABLE LIFT TO SORT OF HAVE
ONE EVALUATOR LOOK LOOK OVER
THE- EVERY ASPECT OF THE OF THE
INITIATIVE- THOSE ARE ALL OF
OUR OFFICES OVER ARCHING
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. YOU KNOW
AGAIN THIS IS BASED ON OUR
INITIAL REVIEW AND THERE MAY BE
ANSWERS TO SOME OF THE POINTS
THAT WE RAISED IN THE
FORTHCOMING TRAILER BILL WHEN
IT WHEN IT BECOMES AVAILABLE-
YOU KNOW WE'RE SORT OF HAPPY TO
PROVIDE. FURTHER ASSISTANCE AS
NEEDED- I BELIEVE MY COLLEAGUES
SONYA PATRICK IS ON THE- IS IN
THE HEARING AS WELL AND- WE
WERE HOPING TO SORT OF PASS
ALONG. A PASS ON OUR COMMENTS
TO HER SO THAT SHE COULD
COMMENT ON SORT OF THE HHS
AGENCY SPECIFIC PARTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL- IF THAT'S IF THAT'S
OKAY. MISTER THANK YOU- CENTER
EGGMAN AND- MY COLLEAGUE MR
SHIDA AND WE JUST HAVE A COUPLE
AS COMMON SPECIFIC TO THE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE WITHIN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY AND THE OFFICE OF SIR
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL-
WE HAVE A JUST A FEW QUESTIONS
THAT WILL BE REACHING OUT TO
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT AND
LIKE MY COLLEAGUES AND WE'RE
STILL AWAITING- ADDITIONAL
DETAILS FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
WHICH WILL HELP US CONDUCT OUR
ASSESSMENT- BUT JUST TO
MENTION- THE IN THE OFFICE OF
THE SURGEON GENERAL THERE IS A
TWENTY FIVE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED. A MOST OF IT
IN THE FIRST YEAR AND THE BULK
OF IT FOR- WHAT'S CALLED AN ACE
IS A WHERE CAMPAIGN OR ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AWARE
CAMPAIGN WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IN TWENTY TWENTY THERE WS A
VERY SIMILAR PROPOSAL BUT ONLY
EIGHT MILLION WAS PROPOSED FOR
THIS ACTIVITY AND SO WE'RE
HOPING TO GET MORE INFORMATION
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
HOW THIS CAMPAIGN WILL WORK
AND- AND ABOUT JUST THE
DISCREPANCY IN THE AMOUNTS
REQUESTED LAST YEAR AND NOW
THIS YEAR. IN ADDITION A MALE
DOLLARS FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL TO DEVELOP A
TRAINING CURRICULUM FOR.
EDUCATORS AND OUR PROVIDE TWO
PRIMARY QUESTIONS HERE ARE. Y.
OTHER SECTORS OF GOVERNMENT
WORKERS ARE NOT TERMINATED- FOR
THE TRAINING SO IN THE PROPOSAL
LAST YEAR- THE OFFICE OF
SURGEON GENERAL WAS-
CONSIDERING TRAINING FOR.
SECTORS SUCH AS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND- SOCIAL SERVICES AND THE
LIKE- SO WE WERE WONDERING WHY
EDUCATIONAL LOAN WAS TARGETED
HERE THIS YEAR. AND WE ALSO
WERE WONDERING ABOUT SOME OF
THE JUST THE IMPLEMENTATION
DETAILS ON THAT TRAINING SO FOR
EXAMPLE AND IS THE OFFICE OF
SURGEON GENERAL INTENDING TO-
DO THEY HOPE THAT ALL EDUCATORS
IN THE STATE WILL EVENTUALLY BE
TRAINED OR SORT OF WHAT'S THAT.
THE BRITAIN REACH OF THIS
TRAINING. AND THEN FINALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE ROLE OF THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY OVERALL THIS IS A
REQUEST FOR FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS- OUR
PRIMARY QUESTION HERE IS JUST
WHAT. HOW MUCH FUNDING WILL GO
TO THE INDIVIDUAL COMPONENTS
AND- HOWEVER THOSE ESTIMATES
DERIVED WE JUST- ARE STILL
MISSING SOME OF THOSE KEY KEY
DETAILS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND SO FOR
ALL OF THESE THINGS AND CLEARLY
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A LOT MORE
QUESTIONS WHEN WE GET A LOT
MORE DETAILS BUT FOR THE
PURPOSE OF TODAY AND SINCE HE'S
HERE WITH US WITH THE SURGEON
GENERAL LIKE TO AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT YOU NEED TO RESPOND
TO DISCREPANCIES BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW HOW. THE INVOLVED
YOU WERE BEFORE BUT DO YOU WANT
TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE ISSUES RAISED BY THE L.
A. O. A AND I WILL JUST SAY- IF
WE THINK ABOUT DOING A BIG
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
AROUND ACES WHICH IS GREAT I
WOULD GUESS YOU WOULD SAY IF
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS CALL OR
CONTACT THIS NUMBER WHICH WOULD
THEN SAY THAT WE WOULD HAVE
THIS- THIS NEW IT
INFRASTRUCTURE ALL SET UP YET.
AND I RAN OUT SO I DON'T ARE
THOSE TWO INEXTRICABLY LINKED
OR COULD ONE START WITHOUT THE
OTHER SURGEON GENERAL. MY NAME
IS MATT SCHULER ON THE CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL. SO WITH
RESPECT TO THE COST OF THE
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. IN
THE CURRENT BUDGET RELATIVE TO
THE PRIOR ASK. REALLY ABOUT
CAPACITY. BEING ABLE TO EXTEND
THE REACH OF THE CAMPAIGN AS A
SECRETARY GALLY MENTIONED
BEING. MINDFUL OF- THE
INCLUSION- AS MANY LANGUAGES AS
WE- CAN ACCOMPLISH- AND REALLY
JUST EXTENDING THAT REACH
BECAUSE OF THE IMPACTS OF THE
OF THE PANDEMIC. THESE ISSUES
ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BEFORE
THEY'RE EVEN MORE SO NOW SO WE
FEEL THAT THE AMOUNT ALLOWS US
TO DO THAT MORE COMPREHENSIVE
REACH THAT IS NEEDED- AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE QUESTION ABOUT
THE CONNECTION TO RESOURCES. IT
CERTAINLY DOES TAKE TIME FOR
PUBLIC AWARENESS TO BUILD. SO
WE BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO BE
GETTING THE MESSAGE OUT THERE
IN ADVANCE OF SOME OF THESE
SERVICES BEING AVAILABLE BUT WE
ALSO DO HAVE. SOME SERVICES
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE ACES AWARE
INITIATIVE WE'VE BEEN TRAINING
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. FOR THE
LAST ALMOST YEAR AND A HALF. TO
DO SCREENING FOR ACES AND TOXIC
STRESS IN TO BE REIMBURSED FOR
THOSE SCREENINGS. AND THEN
PROVIDE MITIGATIONS WITHIN THE
PRIMARY CARE CALL SO. IT REALLY
KIND OF SETS THE STAGE FOR
BEING ABLE TO BE READY FOR THE
SERVICES AS THEY ARE BUILT
THROUGH THIS INITIATIVE. OKAY
IT DOES- IT DOES MS WELCHER OR
SECRETARY KELLY WANT TO RESPOND
TO THE ISSUE AROUND EVALUATION
AND IT'S- KIND OF VARIOUS
COMPONENTS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A BIT MORE NAIL DOWN. YEAH
YEAH SO- AGREE WE THAT THAT-
THERE IS IMPORTANT COMPONENTS
OF THAT ARE ARE THE VALUATION
PROGRAM AND PLAN. THAT CAN AND
WILL BE SHARED I THINKTHE
POINT OF THE L. A. OWES AN
IMPORTANT ONE THAT IT'S A
COMPLEX OPERATED PROJECT AT THE
END IT. WILL REQUIRE CERTAIN
COMPONENTS TO BE EVALUATED
INDEPENDENTLY AND AS PART OF
THE HALL FOR EXAMPLE THE
VIRTUAL PLATFORM AT THE SCALE
OF CALIFORNIA WHETHER IT'S DONE
STATEWIDE OR IN. A COUPLE OF
REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA OR
SPLITTING THE STATE UP IN ALL
REGIONS THAT WILL REQUIRE
ITSELF MON EVALUATION THAT WILL
LOOK VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE
COMPONENTS OF A VALUATION ON
OUR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
PROJECTS THOSE MAY CERTAINLY BE
EVALUATED AROUND HOW QUICKLY-
AND HIGH QUALITY THE TRAININGS
ARE A QUICKLY THERE IN PLACE TO
STOP LENGTH OF TIME THOSE
PROGRAMS TAKE HOW SUCCESSFUL WE
ARE. TO RECRUIT A BROAD AND
DIVERSE SET OF CANDIDATES TO BE
PART OF THE WORK FORCE SO EACH
OF THESE THINGS IS WORTHY OF
ITS OWN EVALUATION AND THEN. WE
WILL LOOK TO EVALUATE THE
ENTIRETY OF THE PROJECT OVER
TIME THE EVALUATION IN MANY
WAYS WILL BE MANIFEST- AS YOU
SAID IT. DOWN THE ROAD WITH THE
IMPACT AND DID THE CHANGE OF
LIFE OPTIONS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND WE WILL BE MINDFUL OF THAT
I THINK WE HAVE SOME
TREMENDOUS- COLLEAGUES IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE OF
BOTH ACADEMIC AND OTHER
EVALUATION GROUPS. THAT CAN
SUPPORT AND HELP THE STATE AND
THEN OF COURSE THERE WILL BE
DEPARTMENT BY DEPARTMENT
SPECIFIC EVALUATION COMPONENTS
HERE AS WELL SO THAT IS
CERTAINLY BEING WORKED OUT- NOW
AND WILL FOLLOW. AND BE MODELED
AROUND. THE SPECIFIC
COMPONENTS. OF WHICH I LAID.
OUT SEVEN KEY BUCKETS THAT EACH
IN. EACH PART OF THAT WILL
REQUIRE SOME OF THE UA- IT STEP
MEASURE YOU WANT TO ADD TO THAT.
YEAH I THINK JUST TO CLARIFY
THERE IS- AT AT THE SECRETARY
SAID THERE IS A RESPONSIBILITY
TO LOOK AT PROCESS MEASURES AND
TO SEE IF INDIVIDUAL PIECES ARE
AFFECTED. BUT THEN THERE'S THIS
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
THE TIME TO LOOK AT HOW THEY
ALL WORK TOGETHER- AND AS I
THINK THAT'S KIND OF WHAT WE
SEE IS THAT THE NECESSITY OF
REALLY COORDINATING THE
EVALUATION. TO REALLY LOOK AT
ALSO- WHERE DO WE GO WHEN THE
FIVE YEARS IS THAT WHERE DO WE
SUSTAIN WHERE TO RECREATE
FUTURE INVESTMENTS WHAT DID WE
LEARN- AND REALLY HOPE THAT
THAT THE FINDINGS FROM. A
COORDINATED. EVALUATION FLEET.
MORE POLICIES CHANGE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SOME. WE GOT ALL OF
THE OLD COMPUTER TO PAN HAS
SOME QUESTIONS AND AGAIN THE
DOCTOR GOING EVERYBODY WE AT
NOBODY AGREES NOBODY DISAGREES
ABOUT THE PROBLEM- I THINK WHAT
WE'LL JUST WE'LL JUST HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE THIS THE
SOLUTION THAT YOU'VE COME UP
WITH DOCTOR PAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- CARE EGGMAN AND-
FREESHEET THE PRESENTATIONS I
THINK WE COULD BUY SPEND ALL
AFTERNOON ACTUALLY TALKING
ABOUT THIS BUT- WILL. I KNOW WE
HAVE MANY OTHER ITEMS. I DID A
FEW QUESTIONS. AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. PLANS TO THE
SAID FELL THIS- AND THE
BASICALLY- SOCIALLY- THIS
INVESTMENT AND CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH. AND JUST VERY
FIRST COMMENT THAT- YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THE EIGHT DELEO
TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW DO YOU
FOLKS ALL CHILDREN OR SOME-
JUST ESPECIALLY SINCE SEEMS
LIKE A LOT OF THIS PROPOSALS
BEING SCHOOL CENTERED- SOMEONE
WHO USED TO BE A MEDICAL
CONSULT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT
IT'S VERY HARD FOR A PUBLIC
SCHOOL DISTRICT- TO. GO AND
ACTUALLY ONLY OFFER SERVICES TO
SOME OF THE STUDENTS THAT
TENDER SCHOOL AND NOT TO
OTHERS- AND- IT AND SORT OF AS
WE SAY AT IS THIS WEEK SERVICE.
OF THE SITE IS SOCIETY THAT OF
PEOPLE HAVE UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
YOU KNOW TO PUBLIC EDUCATION
WHETHER SOME FAMILIES PARTAKE
OF THAT OR NOT- IS THE
DIFFERENCE IT IS THEIR OWN
DECISION BUT IF THEY DO- THAT-
ALL STUDENTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TREATED EQUALLY
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO- THE VERY
SERVICES IN SCHOOL SO. I WOULD
I GUESS I WOULD ARGUE AND
AGREEMENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT WE SHOULD
COME UP WITH A PROGRAM THAT-
ESPECIALLY. THE PARTS THAT ARE-
SCHOOL ORIENTED THAT THEY NEED
TO BE UNIVERSAL AND NOT- NOT
SUBDIVIDED ACCORDING TO WHETHER
SHARON'S COVERAGE OR OTHER
TYPES OF. METRICS- NOW. THANK
YOUNG OF THE- SO WELL I GUESS
ONE THINGS WOULD NOTE IN THIS
PROPOSAL IS THAT IN THE END IT
REALIZE IT TAKES TIME BUT- FOR
EXAMPLE- THAT'S THE LIKE ONE OF
THE CORE THINGS IS BEHAVIORAL.
HEALTH SERVICES VIRTUAL
PLATFORM. AND CERTAINLY I THINK
THIS COULD BE A VERY IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT BUT AND IT ALSO
TAKES TIME TO DEVELOP. BUT ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT IT BEGINS IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE SO IF
YOU TAKE A- HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
IS A NINTH GRADE WHO IS HAVING
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES BECAUSE
OF. COVERAGE BABY GRADUATED FOR
THE EVEN CAME ONLINE. AND
GRADUATE AND PERHAPS NOT GOING
TO COLLEGE BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO HELP THEM NOW I
KNOW WE HAVE OTHER THINGS THAT
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO FOR THEM
BUT- THE SITE SO I GUESS ONE
QUESTION I HAVE AND I THINK
THIS CAME OF THEIR PREVIOUS
HEARING IS THAT'S WHY CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE MANY INVESTMENTS ON
THE ALL OF THE WORK FORCE PART
AS WELL AS GOING TAKE TIME TO
TRAIN PEOPLE AT CETERA- HOW.
HOW DO YOU SEE STAGING AT A
STAGING OUT DIFFERENT THINGS SO
THAT WHAT WAS THE WHAT ABOUT
THE KIDS RIGHT NOW WHO ARE
SUFFERING MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
AS A COVETED. ARE HOW YOU PLAN
TO RUN BASICALLY STATES THINGS
OUT SO THAT THEY CAN GET HELP
EVEN AS WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD
UP ITS INFRASTRUCTURE SO IN
TERMS OF THE OVERALL BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND I KNOW DOOR FOR
EXAMPLE- WE HAD. THEIR
PROPOSALS PUT FORTH IN CERTAIN
REGIONS- FOR EDUCATION MENTAL
HEALTH THAT MORE FUNDED THAT
YOU KNOW THERE WAS ENOUGH MONEY
FUND MALES HEALTH. SERVICE
OVERSIGHT SO HOW DO YOU SEE
ESSENTIALLY I MEAN PROGRAMS
FOR. STUDENTS WHO NEED IT RIGHT
NOW AND THEN PERHAPS THINKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW THAT SORT OF
MERGES INTO EVENTUALLY INTO AN
OVER TO FOUR YEARS THREE FOUR
YEARS THAT WOULD TAKE TO BUILD
INSTRUCTORS. SO TO CREATE THAT
SYSTEM SO CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO
THAT PORTION OF- WHAT WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO TO HELP THE
MORE IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND TELL
THAT THEN EVENTUALLY MERGES
OVER LET'S SAY OUR DEBT THIS
INVESTMENT. AND OVER TO YOU
KNOW THREE TO FIVE YEAR PERIOD
TIME PERIOD AS THE OTHER
INVESTMENTS ARE NOW COMING
ONLINE TO BRING THOSE TOGETHER.
AS THE RENT. UP THOUGHT OF OUR
PLANNING ABOUT THAT. SIR OUR-
BRANDON LET ME JUST BEFORE
ANSWERING THAT QUESTION. JUST
REALLY EMPHASIZE AND ENDORSE
YOUR POINT ABOUT ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE AND NOT JUST K. THROUGH
TWELVE. OUR FOCUS IS ZERO TO
TWENTY FIVE. THERE IS A
DESPERATE NEEDWE SAW CLEARLY-
IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
OTHER CAMPUSES ARE OTHER- YOUNG
PEOPLE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE
ARE. IN WORK AND IN EDUCATION
WHO HAD A TREMENDOUS BURDEN AND
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TOOLS. FOR
THAT POPULATION TO REALLY SERVE
THE NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE- SO-
YOU KNOW THIS FOCUS ON. THAT
ENTIRE SPAN AGE SPAN- AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT WHAT WORKS
FROM ZERO TO THREE IS QUITE
DIFFERENT THAT WHAT WORKS FROM
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE. AND A
KNOWLEDGE GENE HOW NIMBLE AND
THE TOTAL THESE TOOLS REALLY
HAVE TO BE COME. OVER TIME AND
THAT'S THE KEY PIECE IT WILL
TAKE SOME TIME TO DEVELOP THESE
PROPERLY. IN THE EVIDENCE BASED
HIGH QUALITY SCALABLE WAY BUT
IN THE MEANTIME WE DO HAVE.
OTHER SOLUTIONS OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT. EVEN IF SOMEWHAT POORLY
COORDINATED BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF. DIFFERENT WAYS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HAS BEEN
DELIVERED ACROSS OUR STATE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE SOME COUNTIES WITH
THE RICH MENU OF SERVICES IN
ANOTHER COUNTY IS. NOT SO MANY.
AND SO TAKING WHAT IS ALREADY
IN PLACE AND LOOKING WHERE
THOSE INVESTMENTS CAN BE MADE-
SENATOR PAN YOU MENTIONED- THE
IMPORTANCE OF- THE- BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INVESTMENTS IN SCHOOLS.
WE HAD A JANUARY PROPOSAL THAT
IS STILL PART OF. THE OVERALL
BUDGET AND LOOKS TO CREATE
MEANINGFUL PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
MEDICAID MANAGED CARE PROGRAMS-
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AS
WELL AS SCHOOLS SO THAT THEY
CAN IMMEDIATELY. BUILDING
CONNECTIONS THE RELAY CHEN
CHIPS THE IN. IS TO GET OUNG
WITH NEEDS A MEETING CONNECTED
I THINK WHAT WE RUN INTO
CONSISTENTLY AND THIS IS THE
HARD PIECE TO SOLVE OVERNIGHT
IS THAT WORK FOR SHORTAGE THERE
WILL BE CONTINUED TO BE WAIT
FOR SOME OF THOSE PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES SO. AS WE TURN TO
INVESTING IN ADDITIONAL
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
REALLY BUILDING UP THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH THIS
PROPOSAL AND EVEN THOUGH SOME
OF THE COMPONENTS WILL BE
COMPLETE INTEL- YOU KNOW A YEAR
OR TWO. DOWN THE ROAD WE CAN
START TO TAKE PARTS OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND PUT THEM INTO
PLACE RIGHT AWAY WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT POTENTIAL FOR BUILDING ON
SOME OF THE EXISTING PLATFORMS
WE HAVE ACCOUNTS HOPE. THAT
EXISTS WAS BUILT UP FOR THE
PANDEMIC THAT COULD BE INVESTED
IN AND THEN OF COURSE AT THE
PARENT DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE WE HAVE THE HELP
LINE THEY COULD BE A RESOURCE
AND WE'VE CONSIDERED ALL THAT
CAN BE CALM AND EVOLVE INTO
SOMETHING. THAT COULD BE
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE TO
FAMILIES I DO THINK THOUGH THAT
IT DOES- IT DOES TAKE TIME TO
SCALE THE COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS AND IN THE MEANTIME
WE CAN MAKE SOME OF THESE
INVESTMENTS AND I DO THINK THE
WAY YOU DESCRIBED IT. IS
EXACTLY RIGHT THAT WILL TAKE
SOME OF THESE INVESTMENTS NOW
AND ALLOW THEM TO FLOURISH AND
BRAID INTO THE BROADER- PLANNED
AS OUTLINED IN THIS PROPOSED.
AND THEN- SO FOR EXAMPLE IT'S
JUST THAT THIS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES VIRTUAL
PLATFORM IS THAT PLATFORM-
CLOSER TO SAY AT. IS THERE A
FOR CLASS THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS
ARE WE ESSENTIALLY INVENTING IT
AND THEN THE SECOND QUESTION IS
THAT. THIS IS A PLATFORM YOU
ENVISION THAT WOULD BE.
AVAILABLE. MORE BROADLY LET'S
SAY THAT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT JUST
FOR LET'S A STATE OR LOCAL GAL
SERVICES BUT A POTENTIALLY BE
AVAILABLE MORE BROADLY AS A
MENTAL HEALTH PLATFORM FOR
OTHER- MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
AND SYSTEMS AND SO FORTH- IN
TERMS OF HELPING DELIVER CARE
SO IT NEEDS THIS. COULD THIS BE
A PLATFORM ACTUALLY THAT AND
SERVICE ALL PATIENTS NOT JUST
FOR THE STATE PROGRAM SO I JUST
AND MAYBE THAT'S EVEN FURTHER
TO THE FUTURE BUT I WAS JUST
WONDERING AS TO WHAT THE VISION
FOR THIS PLATFORM IS THAT AND
IS THERE AN EXISTING MODEL.
THAT YOU'RE BASING THIS-
PLATFORM IDEA ON OURS THIS-
THAT'S ACTUALLY UP AND RUNNING
RIGHT NOW OR IS THIS A IT IS AN
INNOVATION THAT WERE TRYING TO
BUILD ON A CREATE. HERE AND
STATE. SO BOB IT IS BOTH RIGHT
SO THERE ARE. TWO MODELS OF A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS THERE IS SOME
WORK IN THE UK AND THE DOG MORE
COMPREHENSIVE MODEL- AND THAT
YOU CAME OUT IT WAS REALLY. FOR
COLLEGE AGE- HIGHER AT AGE-
CITIZENS THERE IN THE UK AND
THEN CANADA. HAS THE CLOSEST
MODEL CHáVEZ. MARKETS STEP
MODEL THAT ALLOWS THE TOOLS TO
BE AVAILABLE TO ALLOW. PEOPLE
ARE HARD TO STEP UP THEIR
NEEDING CARE I THINK THE ISSUE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT THIS
IS BROADLY AND WIDELY GOING TO
BE AVAILABLE TO YOUNG PEOPLE TO
YOUR POINT IS IT JUST FOCUSED
ON PUBLIC PROGRAMS OR THOSE WHO
HAVE ACCESS TO PUBLIC PROGRAMS
NO IT IS MEANT TO BE AVAILABLE
FOR ALL YOUNG PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW AND I YOU
KNOW AGAIN THAT PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WHERE- SOME
INDIVIDUALS EVEN WITH THE BEST
HEALTH COVERAGE OFTEN RUN INTO
SOME OF THE MOST DIFFICULT
CHALLENGES GETTING THE BAY FOR
ALL HEALTH CARE AND SERVICES
THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE NEED-
EVEN EVEN HARDER SOMETIMES THAN
THOSE WITHIN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM SO REALLY MAKING SURE
THAT THIS PLATFORM. IS THE
GATEWAY OF THE FRONT DOOR FOR
ALL YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS CARE SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HOPE WILL
BUILD AND EVOLVE OVER TIME AND
WILL REQUIRE ADOPTING
CONVERSATIONS WITH PARTNERS NOT
JUST. IN GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO
WITHIN THE BROAD HEALTH PLAN
AND. HEALTH- PROVIDER COMMUNITY-
AND THEN- MAY JUST A FEW MORE
COMMENTS- AT AN AS YET AND SAID
REALIZE WE COULD SPEND ALL
AFTERNOON TALKING ABOUT THIS-
BUT- KNOWING THAT WE- DON'T
HAVE THAT KIND OF TIME. YOU
KNOW APPRECIATE THE INVEST IN
THE WORK FORCE I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT- DALY AS COMMENTS
ABOUT ONGOING COSTS- IS
SOMETHING THAT I. THINK WE NEED
TO BETTER DEFINE- BECAUSE THE
SERVICE WAY I MEAN THE REASON
WE HAVE THE WORKFORCE WE HAVE
IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH YOU KNOW
SOME OF ITS PIPELINE PERHAPS
AND- THAT'S WHERE THE
INVESTMENT IS GOING HERE. BUT I
ALSO POINT OUT THAT. YOU CAN
TRY TO GET MORE PEOPLE INTO THE
PIPELINE. WHAT HOW MANY PEOPLE
ACTUALLY ENTER AND THEN HOW
WHAT THEY'LL DO WHEN THEY COME
OUT THE PIPELINE DEPENDS ON THE
LABOR MARKET WHAT THE WORKING
CONDITIONS THEY HAVE. IN FACT I
THINK IN A PREVIOUS HEARING I
ALSO ASKED NOT ONLY ABOUT THE
BUILDING THE PIPELINE BUT ALSO
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
INCENTIVIZE. YOU KNOW WHAT IS
THE OVERALL WORK FORCE THAT'S
OUT THERE HOW MANY PEOPLE
PERHAPS ACTUALLY HAVE THE
SKILLS AND TRAINING. BUT
ACTUALLY AREN'T IN THE FIELD
ANYMORE BECAUSE THE WORKING
SITUATION THAT THEY FIND
THEMSELVES AND IT IS NOT ONE
THAT THEY WERE INTERESTED IN
OUR DEBT- THEY DECIDE TO FIND
SOME OTHER. PASSED AND SO- AND
IT'S ALL THAT SIR RELATED IT TO
THE ON GOING COST PART BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT IS THE YEAH PAY
AND BENEFITS OF THE FEDERAL
WORKFORCE THAT WE CAN FIND WAYS
PEOPLE ARE ATTRACTED THOSE TO
ENTER BUT ALSO PEOPLE TO STAY
IN BE RETAINED. AND NOT EITHER
MOVED TO OTHER STATES ARE GO
YOU KNOW FINE PRINT YES. IT'S
THAT ARE SO- SO I THINK YOU
KNOW AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
ON GOING COST PART. THE DAILY
APPOINT OUT THAT IS A BIT ILL-
I THINK WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE WE CAN TRY TO GET
MORE PEOPLE IN THE PIPELINE
AND- WILL TAKE YEARS FOR PEOPLE
TO GO THROUGH BUT WHEN THEY
COME OUT. ARE THEY GOING TO
FIND THE KIND OF JOBS. THE KIND
OF WORK. THAT WE WANT THEM TO
DO. AND ARE WE SUPPORTING THAT
KIND OF WORK RIGHT- AND I THINK
THOSE OF US ON PRIMARY CARE AND
A DOCTOR TELL YOU AND I BOTH
PRIMARY CARE PEDIATRICIANS. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT PRIMARY CARE
PEDIATRICS IS ONE THE LOWEST.
PAID OF ALL THE SPECIALTIES
AND- THEREFORE- YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES A YOU HAVE PEOPLE NOT
YEAH. CITING TO DO OTHER THINGS
BECAUSE- BECAUSE THERE IS FOR
THE SAME TRAINING THEY COULD
HAVE OTHER REWARDS ALTHOUGH I'D
LIKE TO THINK MANY OF US IN
PEDIATRICS STICK TO OUR GUNS.
DESPITE THAT- BUT I THINK IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT FROM THE WORKFORCE
PERSPECTIVE NOT SIMPLY THE
PIPELINE BUT ALSO THE-
ENDPOINT. AND THEN I GUESS THE
OTHER THING OUT ALSO JUST
MENTION IS I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP THE SURGEON
GENERAL AND- ISSUE OUT ASUS BUT
WE ALSO OTHER MODELS AS WELL.
THAT AND TERMS OF AGAIN MOVING
THINGS QUICKLY FOR OUR STUDENTS
ARE HERE FOR EXAMPLE MENTAL
HEALTH FIRST AID. TRAINING
EDUCATORS AND TECHNIQUES LIKE
THAT SO. IT IS GOOD TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF IT. YOU KNOW-
ASSESSMENT AS TO. WHAT TYPE OF
SKILL SETS AND HOW WE EDUCATE
AGAIN EDUCATORS AND SCHOOLS
ARE. LOT FOR OTHER FOLKS- FOR
SOME OF THESE OTHER TOOLS
EVIDENCE BASED TOOLS NAY- AND
HOW THEY COMPARE AS WELL IN
TERMS OF. FAILED TO PROVIDE.
BOTH A DEDICATION OF- OF.
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO NEED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. HELLO
THERE IS THERE SOME OTHER TOOLS
ALSO WE SHOULD BE CONSIDERING
AS WELL IN TERMS OF DOING
TRAININGS. FOR PEOPLE SO- SO
THEY CAN GET SOME INITIAL HELP-
THAT IS AS WE GET THEM TO-
MELTZER SECTIONALS. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PROPOSAL. OKAY THE- CAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND YES A- AT. I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY IN THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FIELD GOES IN
TO THIS FIELD TO GET WEALTHY-
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE COME IN
TO HELP PEOPLE. AND THERE IS
NOTHING MORE FRUSTRATING. THAN
TRYING TO HELP SOMEBODY AND NOT
HAVING THE RESOURCES TO DO
THAT- AND THAT'S ANOTHER THING
THAT BURNS PEOPLE OUT VERY
QUICKLY. EARLIER IN MY CAREER.
YOU KNOW I MEAN WE HAD A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN AND THE WORKING GROUP
HOMES SO WE JUST GOT A CALL
THAT BURNOUT FACTORIES BECAUSE
YOU COULDN'T. YOU COULDN'T LAST
A LONG NOW WE'VE BEEN THAT WE
CLOSE THAT DOWN BUT WE I MEAN
WE STILL HAVE. THE ISSUE OF
KIDS WE STILL HAVE THE ISSUE OF
WAY TOO HIGH- CASELOADS AND OUR
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. AND THE
LAW AND THE LACK OF JUST OF
THE- AS YOU I WAS WE HAVE ALL
STATED- THE LACK OF CAPACITY IN
OUR SYSTEM MUST GROW. AND THAT
THAT IN ITSELF CREATES A BETTER
WORK ENVIRONMENT BEING ABLE TO
REIMBURSE PEOPLE- AND HAVE THEM
HAVE. A BRIGHT ENOUGH HOPE THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY HELP SOMEBODY
AND TO BE ABLE AND THROUGH THAT
MAKE THE SYSTEM WORK- BUT THAT
JUST. THAT WITH WITH A NICE
RATE OF PAY IS- IS ALSO
INCREDIBLY REWARDING. SO WE
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK WE KNOW
THAT THAT THERE'S MORE TO BE
DONE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU- I THINK WE
ALL HAVE THE SAME GOAL IN MIND.
IS TO REALLY INCREASE CAPACITY
IN OUR SYSTEMS AND- AND TO MAKE
SURE EVERY CHILD WHO GETS WHO
NEEDS HELP KIDS THAT HELP. SO
THAT EVERY. ADULT HAS A BUNCH
BETTER SHOT AT BEING ABLE TO
LIVE TO THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
AND WITH TAT I THINK WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING. AND-
DIRECTOR LANDS BURKE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ELIZABETH PLANS FOR. THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. SO I WILL START
WITH ISSUE ONE. WHICH IS AN
AUGMENTATION OF THE SONG BROWN
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
THIS REQUEST IS AN INCREASE OF
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME.
AVAILABLE OVER SIX YEARS. FOR
ADDITIONAL AWARDS TO FIND NEW
PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS. THROUGH THE SONG
BROWN HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAM. THE FUNDING
IN PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
REQUESTED WOULD ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL WARDS TO HOSPITALS
AND CLINICS TO SUPPORT NEW
PRIMARY RESIDENCY TRAINING
PROGRAMS IN UNDERSERVED AREAS.
WE ESTIMATE THIS FUNDING COULD
SUPPORT UP TO TEN NEW PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
ANNUALLY. HOSPITALS THAT ARE
NEW TO GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION CAN ALSO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A HIGHER CAP ON
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL DOLLARS IN THE
EXPANSION OF THE PRIMARY CARE
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
IS A CRITICAL EFFORT TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S NEED FOR MORE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS. SHOULD
I GO ON TO THE OTHER ITEMS
MADAM CHAIR- BUT BUT JUST
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THAT THE-
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCER EARLY-
HAS ANYTHING ON THIS. I THINK
IS A GOOD PROGRAM WILL SUPPORT.
ON THE CAMPAIGN. THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE THIS INVESTMENT-
SOMEONE WHO'S A FORMER- PROGRAM
DIRECTOR RESIDENCY PROGRAM
DIRECTOR IN THE PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCY PROGRAM. I DO
APPRECIATE THIS INVESTMENT I
THINK THE ONE THING I WOULD
JUST KEEP IN MIND AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS OVER.
THE YEARS IS THAT YOUR TRAINING
FOR A PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN
IS- WAS FAMILY MEDICINE
COUNTERMEASURES AND JON P.
ASHES THREE YEARS. AND SO AS A
PROGRAM DIRECTOR WHAT YOU DON'T
WANT TO DO IS HAVE FUNDING THAT
LETS YOU FIND SOMEONE FOR THE
FIRST TWO YEARS AND THEN THEY
DON'T HAVE A FOR THE THIRD
YEAR. PLUS ALSO IN ORDER TO GET
ACCREDITATION YOU NEED TO HAVE
THAT BUILD THAT CAPACITY AS
WELL- SO AND THAT TAKES SOME
EFFORT AND WORK AS WELL SO- I
HOPE YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT THIS ISN'T YEP
THAT THAT FIRST OF ALL IT'S
OVER I THINK SIX YEARS HE SAID.
AND SO THAT THAT SO WE'RE
REALLY TALKING AND THINKING
ABOUT TERMS OF RESIDENCY
CLASSES SO ESSENTIALLY SINCE
IT'S THREE YEARS THAT MEANS.
MAYBE IT THAT THEY'LL GET
THROUGH THREE- FOR RESIDENCY
CLASSES AND THEN PERHAPS WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT HOW WE
EXTEND THIS BECAUSE OTHERWISE
WHAT HAPPENS POSITIONS WITHIN
HAVE TO GO AWAY NOT IN SIX
YEARS BUT ACTUALLY A FEW YEARS
BEFORE. BECAUSE AS THE
RESIDENTS ARE GOING THROUGH YOU
HAVE TO BE SURE YOU CAN ASSURE
FUNDING. THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRETY OF TRAINING NOT JUST A
PORTION OF TRAINING- SO HOPE
JUST THAT. THREE POINT TO KEEP
THAT IN MIND AS WE THINK ABOUT
THE FUNDING FOR- FOR THESE
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT SEEMS LIKE THAT
THOUGHT WAS. PUT IN THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR PER YES THE FOCUS IS ON
YOUR- CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
IN PART BECAUSE- THE WAITED TO
BRING A NEW MEDICARE DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS IS WITH-
WITH THE NEW RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
OKAY THANK YOU. LET'S MOVE ON
THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO JERRY
AT GERIATRIC CAKES CARE WORK
FORCE PROGRAM YES SO THIS IS A
REQUEST FOR A FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME INCREASE. AVAILABLE OVER
SIX YEARS TO AUGMENT THE THREE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
PROPOSED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR GERIATRIC WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS. THE TOTAL AWARDS
FUNDING REQUESTED WILL UTILIZE
EXISTING WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
ADDING ADDITIONAL CAREER
EXPLORATION PIPELINE
SCHOLARSHIP AND LOAN REPAYMENT
AWARDS TO EXISTING PROGRAMS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
GERIATRIC CARE PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. SO USING
CURRENT PROGRAMS WILL ENABLE US
TO LEVERAGE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE INCREASE AWARDS
GERONTOLOGIST AND OTHER
GERIATRIC CARE PROVIDERS MORE
QUICKLY. THAN DEVELOPING A NEW
PROGRAM. THANK YOU ILIO
ANYTHING. A CORE ISSUE DAILY
AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS TO
REASONS. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. NO COMMENTS THANKS
OKAY- WE ALL KNOW THIS NEEDS TO
INCREASE OUR WORKFORCE HERE
DOCTOR PAN ANYTHING ON THIS ONE
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
LET'S THEN MOVE ON. SO ISSUE
THREE IS OXFORD FORTUNE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HALTH INITIATIVE
WHICH SECRETARY GALLEY GAVE
SUCH A IMPASSIONED- INEFFECTIVE
OVERVIEW OF SO I'LL JUST
QUICKLY GO THROUGH ASHRIDGE
PIECES. THE WASHINGTON IS
REQUESTING A TOTAL OF NINE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS OF
THIS AMOUNT SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION IS ONE TIME CORONAVIRUS
FISCAL RECOVERY FUNDS AND THE
REST WOULD BE GENERAL FUND. AND
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD SUPPORT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING. THROUGH
BOTH THE US HAS EXISTING HEALTH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
PROGRAMS WE'RE FOCUSING ON
THREE MAIN GOALS INCREASING A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE IT
IS CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY PROFICIENT AND
CAPABLE OF PROVIDING AGE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES TO
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES.
EXPANDING TRAINING FOR EXISTING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
AND TARGETING PROFESSIONALS IN
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS AND
POPULATIONS. SO OUR FIRST PIECE
OF THIS WOULD CREATE A SCHOOL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COACH AND
COUNSELOR WORKFORCE. THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OVERSIGHT COMMISSION'S
RECENT REPORT OUTLINED THE NEED
TO CREATE SCHOOLS AS CENTRES OF
WELLNESS AND AGAIN SECRETARY
KELLY TALKED ABOUT THIS. THE
REPORT EMPHASIZED THAT UNMET
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS CREATE
LEARNING BARRIERS FOR SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN. TO ESTABLISH
SCHOOLS AS CENTRES OF WELLNESS
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TRAINED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COUNSELORS
AND COACHES TO PROVIDE A
VARIETY OF INTERVENTIONS AND
ASSIST EDUCATORS AND IMPROVING
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES. APRIL
HELPED AND COUNSELORS ARE ALSO
VITAL TO IMPLEMENTING THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS MODEL WHERE
SCHOOLS ARE FOR A WIDE ARRAY OF
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. FROM
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH TO
FAMILY SUPPORTS FOR FOOD. AND
SUCH ABUSE. PRICE CENTER OF AND
HOW. SO WE'RE- WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING TO HAVE THESE. AND
COACHES HELP PROVIDE CHILLED
YOU. A IN HOW WHERE AN WHEN
THEY RECEIVE SERVICES INCLUDING
VERGE SIR THAT. THAT SIX
PRIVACY IN PROVIDE ANONYMITY
THROUGH THE PORTAL THAT WAS
ALREADY DISCUSSED. DURING THE
INITIAL YEAR ASHKHABAD IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS INCLUDING EDUCATION
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WOULD DEVELOP
A MULTI YEAR PLAN TO LAUNCH AND
IMPLEMENT THE SCHOOL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COACH AND COUNSELOR
SYSTEM. ANOTHER BIG COMPONENT
OF OFSTED'S PIECE WOULD BE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER ASIDE WORKFORCE SO
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE A SHORTAGE OF SUCH
COUNSELORS AND CLINICIANS. SO
RECOGNIZING THIS NEED. WE'RE
LOOKING TO DEVELOP THE SAID
WORKFORCE THAT PROVIDES AGE
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT. IF LINE
OF SIGHT COUNCILLOR ISN'T
SPECIALIST REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES TO
HELP GET FROM THE TREATMENT
THEY NEED IN A MANNER THAT IS
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
PROFICIENT. SO WE'RE SEEKING TO
DEVELOP A CULTURALLY COMPETENT
SAID WORKFORCE THAT EXPANDS THE
KNOWLEDGE OF EXISTING LICENSE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CLINICIANS TO
PROVIDE AGE APPROPRIATE SUCH
TREATMENT. AS WELL AS AN
INVESTING SUBSTANTIALLY TO
ADDRESS SIGNIFICANT WORK FORCE
AND DIVERSITY SHORTAGES BY
PROVIDING FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
INDIVIDUALS ENTERING SIDE
CAREERS. SO IN THIS BUDGET YEAR
WE WOULD COLLABORATE WITH
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A NEW
SAID WORKFORCE FRAMEWORK AND
THEN PLAN FOCUSED ON YOUTH AND
FAMILIES. ANOTHER PIECE OF THE
PROPOSALS WOULD EXPAND TRAINING
CAPACITY FOR PSYCHIATRY AND
SOCIAL WORK- AGAIN WHERE WE SEE
RESEARCH THAT ONE OF THE
LARGEST BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE NEEDS ARE IN
PSYCHIATRY ESPECIALLY CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS. ARE PROPOSAL WOULD
PROVIDE FUNDING TO SUPPORT AND
GROW RESIDENCY IN TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT DEVELOP THIS
NEEDED WORKFORCE WE'RE LOOKING
TO BUILD ON EXISTING PROGRAMS
SUCH AS THE WET PSYCHIATRIC
EDUCATION CAPACITY EXPANSION
PROGRAM. AND THAT PROGRAM TO
TRAIN NON PRESCRIBING
CLINICIANS AND CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT SOCIAL WORKERS AND
CHILD WELFARE WORKERS. WE ARE
ALSO LOOKING TO BUILD THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
PIPELINE. THE FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION REPORT
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED TO BUILD A
PIPELINE OF HEALTHCARE WORKERS.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL BUILD ON
EXISTING PROGRAMS SUCH AS ARE
MANY GRANTS PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
CAREER EXPLORATION AND SUSTAIN
AND BUILD PIPELINE PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE MENTORSHIP AND
ACADEMIC CAREER AND PSYCHO
SOCIAL SUPPORTS TO PREPARE
STUDENTS FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
AND LOW INCOME BACKGROUNDS. FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CAREERS- AND
THEN WE'RE LOOKING TO BUILD
EARN AND LEARN APPRENTICESHIP
MODELS. TO HELP PROVIDE A
PATHWAY TO A JOB FOR TO LEARN
MODELS HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN TRAINING AND
PLACING INDIVIDUALS AND NEEDED
OCCUPATIONS. THESE MODELS
PROVIDE TUITION SUPPORT AN ON
THE JOB TRAINING AT A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDER
ORGANIZATIONS WHILE THE
PARTICIPANTS ATTEND POST
SECONDARY SCHOOLS WORK COMPLETE
TRAINING. LAWYERS PROVIDE A
POSITION FOR THE GRADUATE AND
THEN THERE'S A PERIOD OF
SERVICE OBLIGATION. THE PROGRAM
WOULD PROVIDE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
TO THE IMPLIED EMPLOYER TO
SUPERVISE AND MENTOR THE
STUDENTS. HAVE PROSPERED WOULD
LEVERAGE THIS MODEL AND WORK
WITH SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS TO
DEVELOP A PLAN TO BUILD THE
WORKFORCE FOR THESE COUNSELORS.
INCLUDING FOR UNLICENSED BUT
TRAINED PROFESSIONALS. THERE IS
A FOCUS BUT INCLUDE COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS AND PSYCHO
SOCIAL REHABILITATION
SPECIALIST THAT SERVE CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES. GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT WEALTH GAP ALONG
RACIAL LINES THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT APPROACH TO HELP
DIVERSIFY CALIFORNIA'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE-
AND THEN WE HAVE A GOAL AROUND
EXPANDING TRAINING FOR EXISTING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. SO WERE ONE IS
FOCUSED ON ENHANCING TRAINING
TO SERVE JUSTICE AND SYSTEM
INVOLVED YOUTH. THAT PROPOSAL
WOULD DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
ENHNCED TRAINING TO EXISTING
AND NEW STAFF ACROSS A VARIETY
OF SECTORS INCLUDING CHILD
WELFARE EDUCATION AND PROBATION
ON EFFECTIVE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
STRATEGIES WITH JUSTICE AND
SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH AND
PREVENTING SUCH INVOLVEMENT
AMONG HIGH RISK VULNERABLE
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES
FAMILIES. IMPLEMENT THESE
TRAININGS ARE SPREAD WOULD
CONSULT WITH RELEVANT STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND ORGANIZATIONS
AS NECESARY TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A PLAN TO PROVIDE
THIS TRAINING. THE SECOND
PROPOSAL WOULD EXPAND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TRAINING FOR
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS THROUGH
OUR TRAINING NEW TRAINER
PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIP THE-
TRAIN NEW TRAINERS PSYCHIATRY
FELLOWSHIP SCHOLARSHIP SO THIS
CURRENT PROGRAM WOULD BE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
PEDIATRICIANS AND OTHER
PROVIDERS SERVING CHILDREN AND
YOUNG ADULTS. THE PROGRAM
PROVIDES TRAINING TO EXISTING
PRIMARY CARE STAFF TO DIRECTLY
SERVE RATHER THAN REFER FOR
MODERATE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS. HI MERRY CARE
PROVIDERS CONTINUE TO BE A
PRIMARY SOURCE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT. PROVIDING
ADEQUATE TRAINING ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES TO THESE
PROVIDERS THIS PRODUCT IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT TO THE
INTEGRATED TEAM MODEL OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND THEN
THERE TO LAST PIECES THAT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT- FOCUSED ON.
TARGETING PROFESSIONALS IN
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS AND
POPULATIONS ONE WOULD BE TO
EXPAND THE CARE PERSONNEL
TRAINING AND PLACEMENT
PROGRAMS- SO WE'VE SEEN THE
FUTURE HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMISSION REPORT HIGHLIGHTS
THE NEED FOR FRONT LINE WORKERS
TO CONTRIBUTE TO ADDRESSING
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES RELATED TO SUPPLY
DIVERSITY. AND GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION. TELL HEALTH
SYSTEMS WE'RE SEEKING TO EXPAND
THIS PROGRAM BY TRAINING UP TO
TWO THOUSAND YOUR PERSONNEL
BUILDING A DIVERSE WORKFORCE
THAT SUPPORTS IMPROVED HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND PROMOTES RECOVERY
AND SELF SUFFICIENCY. WE ARE
ALSO SEEKING TO TRAIN UP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY PAIR
PERSONNEL TO FOCUS ON
TRANSITION AGE YOU. THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL FILL AN
IMPORTANT GAP IN THE WORK FORCE
TO WORK WITH AT RISK YOUTH. AND
THEN FINALLY WE'RE LOOKING TO
AUGMENT OUR EXISTING LOAN
REPAYMENT SCHOLARSHIP AND
STIPEND PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- DISCIPLINES.
THOSE PIECES ARE ALL OUTLINED
IN YOUR- IN IN THE AGENDA-
HAPPY ANSWER ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS AND I'M
JOINED A STEPHANIE WELCH OF
COURSE IS STILL HERE AS IS
KAREN RISE L. R. WORKFORCE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR- BUT I REALLY
WOULD NOTE THAT THEY DESERVE A
LOT OF CREDIT FOR PUTTING THIS.
PROPOSAL TOGETHER I'M TRYING TO
LEVERAGE JOSH BECAUSE EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND REALLY FEEL THE
NEED AND RED MEAT THIS UNIQUE
MOMENT IN TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ANYTHING. ANDERSON SHEFFIELD
FINANCED A COMMON THING THANK
YOU MISTER SHE DON'T THE SEER
HAND UP. THANK YOU SENATOR A
MAN- OR YOU SEE IT AGAIN WITH
THE L. A. I'LL BE BRIEF WITH
THE ARE COME ON THIS YOU KNOW
FOR THIS. OF THAT SHE AND YOUTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INITIATIVE YOU
KNOW SIMILAR TO LIKE A THE CALL
THAT WE ON- ON THE OVER
INITIATIVE THAT WE RELEASE THE
IN. OF DESIGNING IN EFFECT THE
VALUE STRAIGHT FOR THESE. YOU
KNOW- SO OF THIS IS GOING TO A
ON EDWARD PRO AND SOME OF THAT
IS GOING TO STAB NEW. YOU KNOW
GIVEN THAT THE STATE GENERALLY
IS NOT SORT HAD A CLUE PICTURE
OF THE NAY OF A- WORKFORCE WITH
AN ARCHED AND YOU KNOW WE WOULD.
THIS YOU KNOW- INSIDERY ABOUT
THE VALUE. IS OF THIS FUNDING-
THE NEW. AS WELL AS POTENTIAL
SORT OF REFINED THAT CAN BE
MADE. I TO EXISTING. JOSH
EXISTING PROGRAMS ALREADY SORE
OF GAME A CLEARER PICTURE OF.
WHETHER THERE ARE- SPECIFIC
OUTCOME. METRICS HAVE BEEN RE
AS A- OF- OF THESE INVESTMENTS.
THOSE ARE ALL OUR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME HAPPY TO PROVIDE.
ASSIST FOR NEEDED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I GUESS I'M I WOULD
JUST FIRST I'M YOU KNOW WE JUST
KEEP THIS ENOUGH THAT THAT WHEN
SOMEONE IS TRAINED WORKFORCE
ISSUES REMAIN- HUGE AT AT JOB
RETENTION BE ABLE TO KEEP
PEOPLE AND- AND I GUESS I DON'T
HAVE AS MANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
AND AGAIN YOU KNOW ALL OF THIS
WILL NEED MORE DETAIL BUT- OF
THE- EXISTING. PROFESSIONS AS
WE KNOW ON. BUT I GUESS I AM I
AM INTERESTED IN KNOWING YOUR
IDEAS ABOUT WHO ARE THESE
HEALTH COACHES AND COUNSELORS.
AND WHO ARE THESE- EARN AND
LEARN FOLKS. WITH THE
APPRENTICESHIP MODEL I GUESS
THAT MAKES A LOT MORE SENSE TO
ME- BECAUSE WHAT RECOMMEND WE
ALREADY HAVE A NOT ENOUGH.
BEHAVIOR HEALTH FOLKS NOW
SILICON CREATING. NEW NEW- AND
AS WHO SERVED ON MY BUSINESS A
PROFESSION FOR A LONG I CAN
TELL SCOPA THEN BE THAT BECOMES
A BATTLE AND- DO WHAT- AND THEN
MY OTHER ISSUE ALSO IS. IN THIS
FOR A WHILE IS A ISSUE OF IT
WILL TO CREATE THESE NEW. ARE
WE ALSO GONNA THEN DO COURSE.
INVESTMENT IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM OTHERWISE WE
ARE ASKING THE FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE SYSTEM THAT IS OUT
THERE AND THRIVING TO CREATE TO
CREATE ALL THESE AND PROVIDE
THE EDUCATION AND SEND ARE
PROBABLY LOWER WAGE EARNERS IN
OUR BEHAVIOR HEALTH SENTENCE.
SYSTEM INTO HIGHER RATES OF
DEATH SO CAN YOU TALK ABOUT WHO
ARE THESE COACHES AND
COUNSELORS. AND EARN AND LEARN
WHICH PEOPLE. THANK MADAM
CHAIRMAN SEE IF THAT DIRECTOR
WELSH TO THAT THAT SECRETARY
WELSH WANTS TO- TALK ABOUT THE
A LITTLE AND WERE HAPPY ADD ON
THIS NEEDED. ABSOLUTELY AND- SO
WE WERE LOOKING AT MY THAT ARE
AND IN A OF PLACES BUT THE
PRINCIPLE ACTUALLY BOTH THE
COACHES AS AS THEIR AND LEARN
MODEL IS TO HAVE A LOW BARRIER
TO ENTRY INTO THE WORK FOR AND
FOR US TO RECRUIT UNDERSERVED
THAT COULDN'T THANK COME INTO
THIS WORK FOR AND BROUGHT THE
CULTURAL LINGUIST AND. FIRST
THAT WE NEED IN OUR WORK CENTER
A CULTURE REALLY AT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT WAS. THAT IT WAS
THE AS COMMUNITY HEALTH WHERE
IN WASN'T THIS. NEXT AS A HERE
BECAUSE THE THING THAT MAKE
THEM YOU NEED WOULD BE THE
SPECIFIC INTO TRAINING THAT
THEY GET TO READ IN. AND
SUPPORT CHILDREN AND USE SAID
THAT- I TO BE SPECIFIC ALSO AS
A SOCIAL SPEAKING TO YOU THIS
IS A I'M LICENSE- YOU KNOW
ENVISIONED AND I'M LIKE. BUT
TRAIN AND HIGHLY. WORK FORCE
AND KIND OF SEVEN TO AN EARLY
LEARN MY- THIS MODEL ONLY WORK
AS- IF WE'RE GOING TO RECRUIT
FROM COMMUNITIES- ARE CURRENTLY
AS REPRESENT IN OUR- WOULD BE-
ASSEMBLY NET THE PROVIDE A
STATE. PROVIDED AT. PERFECT
NINE SHIP- AND IT ENDS. IN
ATTENTION JOBS. BUT AGAIN THE
THING WOULD MAKE A GIVE ME.
WOULD BE THE THEY- HAD THE OF
IN THE OPERA. AT NO COST AND-
TO GET THIS IN TEN TRAINING.
THAT MAKE THEM. ABLE TO WORK
VERY AFFECT WITH CHILDREN I
THINK PROBABLY SO THAT YOU
HEARD AND I HEARD IT IN PRETTY
HEARINGS IS THAT. WE SIMPLY A
YES WE HAVE A WORKFORCE DEFICIT
ALL AROUND THAT'S- WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THAT TWO DECADES
pHAVE A DENTIST IN TERMS OF A
FEW REALLY YOU TO NOT ONLY A-
BUT YOU'RE REALLY WERE WITH
CHAU AND THEIR- AND SO OF THIS
IS A THAT WILL. REALLY NEED TO
BE DEBT IN THE A BEING THE WITH
THE EXTRA AND- OF OUR AT. PART
AS WELL AS OUR PART IN ADVOCATE
TO TWELVE. AND SO WE STARTED
THOSE COME. WE RECKON THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS A VISION
THAT WE HAVE THAT IS QUOTING
NEW AND IT WILL. SOME SOME
PLANNING BECAUSE WE WANT AGAIN
THE SYSTEMS YOU UTILIZE THESE.
BE. SIX YEARS CANCERS IT COULD
REPRESENT SOMEBODY WHO HAS
THEIR ABLE HAS HAS GRADUALLY
FROM US WORK PROGRAM AND TO
BECOME A CASE MAY. IT'S AT THE
END IS THAT THESE ARE INDEED
WHO. WOULD HAVE A AND- A
STRONGER SKILL SET SO SPEAK OR
A MORE SKILL SET DEBT AT YOU
KNOW SINCE A CO COULD. DO A
WARM HAND OFF TO OR. FOR TO.
AND ANOTHER- QUESTION THAT
WE'VE GOTTEN ABOUT THE KIND. OF
REALLY RAPIDLY BEATING TO
PRODUCE A WORK FORCE THAT CPAS.
HAS STILL SETS TO WITH YOU
YOUNG OF FAMILY- CHIU YOUTH AND-
WHAT BE THAT AS- THEY WOULD
YEAH. AND SEE AND APPLY FOR A
JOB IN AN EDUCATIONAL SETTING
THEY MAY CHOOSE TO WORK IN A
SMALL CBO OR MAYBE IT WAS EVEN
THE CBO WHERE THEY DID THEIR
INTERNSHIP- MAYBE THEY CHOOSE
TO WORK FOR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH I THINK- OUR CONCEPT
AROUND THIS POPULATION IS TO
PRODUCE- I DON'T SEE A NEW
GENERATION BUT HOPEFULLY A
LARGE GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO. MAY
NOT NECESSARILY HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY- HAD MAYBE EVEN
CONSIDERED GOING INTO- THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CARE FIELD BUT
THAT IT CAN BE A REWARDING AND
ALSO FINANCIALLY AS- AS- WELL I
DO WANT SAY FINISH REWARDING
BUT STILL EIGHT EIGHT GOOD JOB
A GOOD PAYING JOB. AND IT'S
EVERYTHING FROM SOMETHING
THAT'S MORE ENTRY LEVEL TO. A
JOB THAT PROVIDES MANY
OPPORTUNITIES INCLUDING
RETURNING TO SCHOOL AND GETTING
ADDITIONAL LICENSURE- AND SO
THAT'S REALLY OUR VISION AND WE
DO THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING.
REALLY WANT TO WORK WITH OUR
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS ON TO
HELP- NOT ONLY IDENTIFY
EXISTING. STUDENTS MAY BE
GETTING READY TO GRADUATE AND
MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN IN IN
BEING A PART OF A PROGRAM WHERE
THEY COULD GET SOME INTENSIVE
TRAINING AND BE MORE WORK FORCE
READY- TO THE WAYS IN WHICH WE
CAN PARTNER WITH- OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND OTHER
TRAINING ENTITIES. TO RAPIDLY
TRAINED INDIVIDUALS EFFECTIVELY
TO HAVE THIS UNIQUE SKILL SET.
SO I THINK. THAT ANSWERED MOST
OF. YOUR QUESTIONS ON THAT.
YEAH AND YOU AND AN- AND WE
BOTH KNOW THIS IS A MEMBER
OPTIMISTIC AND THIS IS I MEAN
THIS I A- THAT THIS IS THIS I
SEE IT. RIGHT I SEE THE I SEE
THE OPTIMISM AND I SEE THE- THE
DREAM BUT- AND I SEE A LOT OF
LAND MINES IN IN BETWEEN THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE ABOUT THE
SUBSIDIES ARE ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT KATE ACT PEOPLE THAN
CERTIFICATION ARE YOU TALKING.
THEY'RE ALSO ABOUT A RANGE OF-
IT IS A CAREER PATH I GUESS I
GUESS IS THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT AND THEN IF WE IF WE DO
THAT. THEN AGAIN THIS ISSUE OF
PAY BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT WE
DON'T WANT TO CREATED A WHOLE.
GREAT PEOPLE THAT ARE VASTLY
UNDERPAID- SOMEBODY WITH A
DEGREE AND THEN. SO ANY ANY
POTENTIALLY MIGHT BE A QUESTION
FOR KAREN- WE'RE KIND OF
THINKING THROUGH THE PROCESS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO EMBARK ON
IN ORDER TO REALLY EXAMINE HOW
TO BUILD OUT THE SUBSTANCE USE
WORKFORCE THAT WE NEED AND
WOULD THAT BE SOMETHING THAT
KAREN COULD SPEAK TO. BUSINESS
RESULTS. PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- WELL I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT AND SPECIFICALLY AROUND
THAT- AS YOU THE WORK FORCE IS
HOW TO BUILD A CAREER LADDER
AND SO I THINK THAT- BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE WANT TO BUILD
A PATHWAY- FROM THE LOWER-
ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS AND A
HIGHER LEVEL POSITION SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE KEY PIECES OUT OF
THIS OUR PROPOSAL IS REALLY
DEVELOPING THAT CAREER LADDER.
SO WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT QUITE
SURE ABOUT. SO THAT WE'RE WE'RE
STILL WE'RE STILL WORKING OUT A
LOT OF THE DETAILS OF IT. BUT
BUT I BUT I WOULD CONCUR WITH
YOUR GOAL OF. TRYING TO CREATE
SOME KIND OF WORKFORCE LADDER-
THROUGH THIS AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE PARTNER WITH OUR-
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING
SO WE HAVE THE TRAINING- EASILY
AND AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE- AND-
AND WE KNOW IT. IT IT'S A LOT
OF YEARS AND AN EDUCATION TO
GET A- AN ADVANCED DEGREE. BUT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH HUMAN BEINGS AND SO IT'S
IT IS VERY ALSO DELICATE WORK
AND WHAT WE WANT TO. EXPAND IT
TO MORE PEER SUPPORT WE- WE
ALSO LEARNED THAT COMES WITH
SOME LIABILITIES AS WELL SO
SUPERVISION WOULD HAVE TO BE AT
A- HUGE COMPONENT. OF THIS SO.
I'M A LOT STILL T BE
DETERMINED BUT WE THANK YOU
DOCTOR PAN. THANK YOU TRACK
MAN- BUT YOU KNOW- AFTER THAT I
AM A LITTLE THIN I STILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS- AFTER
HEARING THE ANSWER FROM-
ARGUMENT AND- NO JUST
RESPECTFULLY- YOU KNOW HONORED
TO BE WORKING WITH A CHAIR WHO
HAS A DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK AND
ADVANCED DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK
BY MYSELF. NOT ONLY A PHYSICIAN
BUT I'VE DONE ADVANCED TRAINING
AND BEHAVIOR DEVELOPMENT- AND
OF COURSE I ALSO RAN A TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR- PEDIATRICIANS AS A
PROGRAM DIRECTOR. AND SO AS AN
EDUCATOR I'M HEARING SOME OF
YOUR ANSWERS AND IT'S ACTUALLY
MAKING ME VERY CONCERNED.
BECAUSE I'LL TELL YOU AS A
PROGRAM DIRECTOR SO I GET
PEOPLE WHO GRADUATE FROM
MEDICAL SCHOOLS THEY'VE HAD
FOUR YEARS OF COLLEGE FOUR
YEARS OF MEDICAL SCHOOL THERE.
PRIDED PRETTY WELL IN COLLEGE
TO GET THE MEDICAL SCHOOL SAID
PRETTY TALENTED PEOPLE. AND YOU
KNOW THEY SHOW UP AND WE'RE
GOOD AND WE- HAVE THEM GO TAKE
CARE OF PATIENTS BUT WE DON'T
TO SOMEONE TO TAKE CARE OF
PATIENTS WE KEEP A VERY CLOSE
EYE ON THEM- BECAUSE- IT'S HARD
WORK. AND IT'S NOT JUST
DIFFICULT- THE CONSEQUENCES ARE
SIGNIFICANT IF THEY MAKE
MISTAKES. ARE IF THEY'RE WRONG.
AND SO THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
REALLY GOING TO EIGHT YEARS OF
TRAINING AND BY THE WAY EVEN
WHEN THEY'RE FINISHED THEY'RE
ADDITIONAL THREE YEARS OF- IN
PERSON EXPERIENCE- THEY'RE
STILL NOT QUALIFIED TO TRAIN
THIS. AS AN EXPERT AND
SPECIALIST IN- BEHAVIOR
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S ANOTHER
THREE YEARS OF TRAINING. AND I
ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT ONE OF YOUR
TRAINING PROGRAMS HERE'S
ACTUALLY TO TAKE THESE VERY
SAME PEOPLE WHO'VE GONE THROUGH
THAT MUCH TRAINING- FOUR YEARS
FOUR YEARS OF COLLEGE FOUR
YEARS OF MEDICAL SCHOOL THREE
YEARS OF RESIDENCY. AND SAY
THAT- BY THE WAY YOU NEED EVEN
MORE TRAINING TO TAKE CARE OF
MODERATE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONDITIONS. AND ACTUALLY YOU
KNOW THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY AN
ACCURATE BECAUSE THE SONG IS
ACTUALLY DONE MY FELLOWSHIP
TRAINING. THE THING THAT I
REALIZE IS THAT IT'S YOU KNOW
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS SOME YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT SIMPLE. IT'S
CHALLENGING. AND SO THE
QUESTION STARTS TO RAISES THAT
NOT I GET YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING
TO BUILD UP THE WORK FORCE IS
THAT THESE HEALTHCOACHES AND
COUNSELORS YOU YOU TALK ABOUT
INTENSIVE TRAINING BUT THEY'RE
UNLICENSED. SO THAT SEEMS TO BE
AN OXYMORON. HOWARD INTENSIVELY
TRAINED I MEAN I GUESS WE KEEP
WE DON'T HAVE THE STAFF TO GIVE
A LICENSE FOR INTENSIVE
TRAINING BUT HOW DO YOU SAY
DON'T TENTATIVELY TRAINED. AND
DOESN'T NECESSARY HAVE TO LEAD
TO LICENSE SO WHAT IS THIS
INTENSIVE TRAINING HOW MANY
YEARS HOW MANY HOURS OF
TRAINING IS INTENSIVE TRAINING
BEFORE WE UNLEASH THEM. ONTO A
BUNCH OF. STUDENTS AND CHILDREN
IN SCHOOLS. RIGHT AND- I'LL
TELL YOU AGAIN AS A AS A AS AN
AT THE HOUSE AS A PROGRAM
DIRECTOR- THE THING THAT ALWAYS
WORRIES ME MOST WERE THE
RESIDENTS WHO THOUGHT THEY KNEW
MORE THAN THEY REALLY DD. AND
THOSE ARE THE ONES I HAD TO
KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON RIGHT- LATE
DEL SO SOMETIMES KNOWING JUST
ENOUGH IS ACTUALLY MORE
DANGEROUS BECAUSE YOU DON'T
REALIZE THE LIMITS OF WHAT YOU
KNOW OR DON'T KNOW. SO WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IS WERE RUSHING
TO GET THE BUT WE'RE GONNA
CREATE THIS PROGRAM THAT
DOESN'T EXIST RIGHT SO WE CAN
VENT THIS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
COACH OR WHATEVER. AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO DO WHAT AND I
AGAIN I'M INTERESTED IN THE
QUESTION AS TO HOW MUCH
TRAINING TO GO TO HAVE THEIR
OWN LICENSED OKAY BUT EXACTLY
HOW MUCH TRAINING IS
INTENSIFIED THE WORD INTENSIVE.
WHAT IS THE DEFINITION OF THAT.
AND THEN- I WONDER IN THESE
SCHOOLS. RT UNSUPERVISED- IS
SOMEONE KEEPING AN EYE ON WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IN CASE THEY- YOU
OVER EXTEND THEMSELVES. IS
THERE SOMEONEIS THERE GOING TO
BE A MASTER YOU KNOW SOMEONE
WHO ACTUALLY HAS PROFESSIONAL
TRAINING IS LICENSE AND
ACCOUNTABLE- TERMS OF THEIR-
THEIR- YET TO MONITOR HOW MANY
OF HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE
SUPERVISING YOU KNOW HOW MANY.
HOW HOW MANY PROFESSIONALLY
LICENSE PROFESSIONALS CAN BE
WATCHING OVER THEM SO THAT A
PERSON CAN HAVE TWELVE OF THEM
KEEP AN EYE ON THE TWO GOT IT
FOR OR HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE. SO
SO I APPRECIATE THE GENERAL
IDEA YOU TRY OKAY HOW CAN WE
TRY TO RUSH THIS WORK FORCE BUT
I ALSO WANT BE VERY CAUTIOUS
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE TELLING PEOPLE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GETTING. AND I
DID AND I DID BY THE WAY I DO
AGREE THAT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE BUILD A
CAREER LADDER SO I'M NOT SAYING
THAT YOU CAN'T HAVE PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING UP THE CAREER LADDER
IN TRYING TO GET THEM AND
OPPORTUNITY. AND ALSO BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE WHAT THEY HAVE
LEARNED TO BE ABLE HELP DELIVER
SOME SERVICES. BUT ONLY VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT. YOU KNOW A- WHAT.
KIND OF EXPECTATIONS WERE
SETTING ON THE PEOPLE RECEIVING
THOSE SERVICES AND WHAT THESE
PEOPLE CAN DO. NOT ONLY THE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES BUT
ALSO EVEN THE TEACHERS AND
OTHER STAFF IN THE SCHOOL. BUT
WHAT THEY CAN DO. BECAUSE I
KNOW WHEN YOU'RE SHORT YOU KNOW
YOU JUST DESPERATELY BY THE WAY
FUND THAT BACK IN THE GREAT
RECESSION- I HAD. YOU KNOW I.
AS YET AS SOMEONE WHO TAKES
YOUR LIFE CHILDREN WHO HAD
LEARNING DISABILITIES
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES. I HAD
PARENTS BECAUSE THEY HAD TO
MENTAL HEALTH CUTS. WHEN WE
WERE CUTTING STATE SERVICES
BACK IN DOUBT. THAT BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE. ASKING WHAT I COULD DO
THERAPY FOR THEM AND I SAID
WELL YOU KNOW I'M A FULLY
TRAINED PHYSICIAN BUT I'M NOT A
PSYCHOLOGIST I CAN'T. THEY
DON'T DO I CAN'T DO THERAPY I'M
NOT TRAINED TO DO THAT. AND SO
WILL THIS PERSON KNOW ENOUGH TO
SAY NO I CAN'T DO THAT FOR YOU.
I DON'T KNOW. I'M NOT SKILLED
ENOUGH. SO SO CAN YOU PLEASE
HELP ANSWERED THAT HELP ME
UNDERSTAND. WHAT'S INTENSIVE
TRAINING MEAN. WHO'S
SUPERVISING WHAT KIND OF
STANDARDS ARE WE PUTTING ON
THESE EAR HEALTH COACHES AND
COUNSELORS. SO- WAIT WAIT COACH
IS- I THINK WHAT I MEAN SO WHEN
USING THE TERM INTENSIVE- THESE
ATTENTION YOUR INVISION TO BE
FULL TIME. TWELVE TO SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR WEEKS OF FORTY
HOURS OR FORTY HOURS A WEEK AT
TRAINING AND TWENTY- ATTORNEYS
ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO WILL NOT BE
SUPERVISED THE- THEIR TRAINING.
IS SIMPLY TO GET THEM INTO A
PLACE WHERE THEY CAN BEACH
SUPERVISED FOR UP TO TWO YEARS
BY A LICENSED PROFESSIONAL-
KIND OF LIKE A AND ON THE JOB I
DON'T SEE IT ON THE JOB IN
SOCIAL WORK WE DO THAT WE HAVE
TO GET OUR FIVE THOUSAND HOURS.
SO AGAIN AT THE IDEA IS TO HAVE
SOME CLASSROOMS SO TO SPEAK
INTENSIVE TRAINING BUT THEN TO
REALLY- WORK WITH A MORE
PROFESSIONAL STAFF STAFF THAT
LEADS THAT THEY COULD REFER
CLIENTS TO A PART OF A LOT OF
THAT TRAINING IS EXACTLY WHAT
YOU JUST MENTIONED. AND THEY'RE
IDENTIFYING SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS
AND THEY'RE RECOGNIZING- WHEN
THEY SHOULD WORK FOR THE YOUNG
PERSON TO A PROFESSIONAL AND SO
IT REALLY IS- GETTING BACK TO
THAT ORIGINAL CONCEPT WE TALKED
OF AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
HEARING WHICH IS. IN POWER IN
MORE THAN ABILITY TO IDENTIFY
AND WORK FOR AN OPENING THAT
DOOR SO THAT. MORE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO HAVE AN ABILITY TO
HAVE A WARM HAND OFF TO THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED SO IF IT
WAS THAT FOR TRADE THAT THE
COACHES THEMSELVES WOULD BE
DELIVERING A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF CARE THAT
WAS CLINICALLY BASED I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY WHAT WE DO. BEST
THESE COACHES OKAY CLARIFIED
AND- SO I'M JUST TRYING
MANAGING THE SEQUENCE OF EVENTS
A YEAR IN SCHOOL YOUR CHILD
APPEARS TO HAVE SOME BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES NOT DOING WELL IN SCHOOL.
PERHAPS NOW ACTING OUT SOMEWHAT.
THERE'S THIS BEHAVIOR HOW COACH
IN THIS SO. OUR DAY IN THE-
WATCHING. ARE TEACH. THEN HAVE
TO REFER TO THEM PRINCIPLES-
AND THEN AND THEN WHO'S AND
THEN THE SUPERVISION IS THAT IN
PERSON SUPERVISION AT THE
SCHOOL SO WE'RE GONNA BE SURE
WE HAVE A LICENSED HEALTH FOR.
A MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL TO
SCHOOL SO HE JUST I JUST I GET
BETTER MORE CONCRETE HE'S IDEA
ABOUT EXACTLY WHERE THESE
COACHES SIT AND HOW THEY GET
THERE HOW DID HE GET THE PEOPLE
IN FRONT OF THEM AND THEN. AND
OF COURSE THEN DAY HOPEFULLY
THEY'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
MAKE A REFERRAL TO A LICENSE
PROFESSIONAL BUT- HOUSE AT
SEQUENT EVENT SUPPOSED TO
HAPPEN OKAY AND LET ME- BEFORE
YOU TRY TO ANSWER THAT MUST
MISS WORK BECAUSE THAT BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW OR BUTTONS RIGHT I
DON'T KNOW THAT ANYBODY CAN
REALLY ANSWER THAT RIGHT NOW I
THINK YOU ARE STILL IN A-
CONCEPTUAL PHASE AS AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. AND SO I THINK
WHAT YOU SHOULD TAKE FROM THIS
IS THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS- I WILL ALSO SAY THAT
AS A PEOPLE I STARTED OFF
BEFORE I WAS LICENSED- AND I
WORKED IN THE SUBSIDIES PROGRAM
I WORKED IN A THERAPEUTIC LONG
TERM SUBSIDIES PROGRAM. THE
FIRST TIME I EVER HEARD THE
WORD THAT SOCIAL WORKER A CAME
WITHIN AN M. F. IN FRONT OF IT-
PARA PROFESSIONAL WAS ASKING ME
ABOUT WHAT I WAS BECAUSE HE
THOUGHT I WAS BEING TOO KIND-
SO I KNOW THAT THE PEOPLE COME
IN ALL KINDS OF. OF FLAVORS OF-
OF- EXPERIENCE AND SOMETIMES
THOSE WITH DIRECT EXPERIENCES
ARE VERY HELPFUL BUT I ALSO
THINK IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE
A REAL A BLAND AND MAKE SURE
AGAIN THE ISSUE OF SUPERVISION.
I THINK IT IS IMPERATIVE I KNOW
IN CLASSROOMS OF A TEACHER CAN
HAVE A PARA PROFESSIONAL THAT
IS FANTASTIC AND I KNOW THEY
ARE OFTEN NOT A DEGREE PEOPLE
BUT CERTIFIED AND TAKEN SOME
CLASSES. SO I UNDERSTAND THE
MODEL I THINK THAT YOU I THINK
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT MODEL
BUT I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE
A LOT OF QUESTIONS GOING
FORWARD ABOUT ABOUT SUPERVISION
AND WHO THESE FOLKS ARE AND
WHAT THEIR TRAINING IS. AND ALL
OF THAT BUT I THINK WE ALL
UNDERSTAND. THE NEED FOR A
CAREER LADDER AND WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYBODY IS
NOT GOING TO BE A DEGREED
PROFESSIONAL- BUT. THAT THERE
WILL BE A CHECKS AND BALANCES
IS SUPERVISION. BUILT INTO THIS.
AND THAT WHAT I'M UNDER. YES
THAT IS OUR GOAL AND AGAIN WHY
WE- REALLY WANT TO HAVE THAT
PLANNING HERE TO WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS. AND TO DESIGN
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO.
HAVE THEIR EXPERTISE OBVIOUSLY
BUT AGAIN HOPEFULLY HELP US IN
THE IN THE LONG TERM CAPACITY
YOU HAVE AS A GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO CAN COME IN- AND MAYBE BE A
COACH FOR BURKE WHAT AS LONG AS
THEY WANT OR POTENTIALLY
CONTINUE ON WITH THEIR
EDUCATION. AND THEIR SKILL SETS
SO I THINK WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
IT BEING A NEW OPPORTUNITY TO.
I HAVE A DIFFERENT CHAD.
EXPANDING CAPACITY IN
PARTICULAR AGAIN OUR HOPE IS
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO RECRUIT
PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
INTERESTED IN GOING INTO THIS
FIELD AND OR- REALLY WANT TO
GET BACK TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
IN A MEANINGFUL WAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO I GUESS THE END
AGAIN- DO APPRECIATE YOU
GETTING BACK TO ME WITH THE
ANSWERS TO SOME OF THOSE
THOUGHTS A FORGET REALIZE
YOU'RE STILL BOMBING BUT THAT
ALSO MEANS. WHAT IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR ALL THE
SUPERVISORS TO RIGHT- SO YOU
KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE THESE
COACHES WE HAVE THIS. BUDGET
LINE FOR COACHES STAND FOR THE
SUPERVISORS COME FROM BECAUSE-
THIS IS WHAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH SCHOOL NURSES FOR ALL
THE SCHOOLS. WE CERTAINLY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH LICENSED MENTAL
HEALTH WORKERS IN SCHOOLS AS
WELL SO WE'RE GOING TO CREATE
THESE COACHES IN THE SCHOOLS
AND THERE CAN BE SUPERVISED AND
WE NEED TO KNOW WHO THE
SUPERVISORS ARE WHERE WE CAN
SUPERVISORS. I'LL JUST MAKE ONE
OTHER LAST COMMENT AS WELL- AND
THIS GOES BACK TO- SO. AGAIN
THIS BEHAVIOR HEALTH TRAINING
FOR PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
WHICH AGAIN I AGREE WITH- AND
THAT WE SHOULD ENCOURAGE A
PRIMARY CARE US- STAFF
INCLUDING PHYSICIANS. FOR
MODERATE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS BUT I'LL TELL YOU TO
SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY DOES THAT
WORK DID THAT WORK CLINICALLY-
THE TO THE ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES IS OF YOU KNOW THAT.
IS NOT SO MUCH I MEAN JUST PART
OF IT'S THE TRAINING PART BUT
ACTUALLY THE REAL CHALLENGE IS
THIS I THAT AND- AND AGAIN
THIS PERHAPS MORE QUESTION FOR
DH YES ACTUALLY IN THE LONG RUN
THEN YOU. BUT SINCE YOU'RE
DOING THIS PART THE WORKFORCE
PIECES THAT- AS A PRIMARY CARE
DOCTOR I DIDN'T GET REIMBURSED
FOR. THE TIME IT TOOK TO DO THE
MENTAL HEALTH WORK. SO ON ONE
HAND WELL I WOULD TRY TO DO
SOME OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
WORKERS SOMEONE AGAIN FIFTY S.
FELLOWSHIP TRAINED B. L.
BEHAVIORAL DEVELOPMENTAL
PEDIATRICIAN- THAT- THE- THE
BILLING MANAGERS WOULD GO WAIT
A MINUTE YU'RE DOING ALL THIS
WORK THAT. CAN'T BE BILLED FOR
IN YOUR. SPENDING TIME. THAT IS
THAT AGAIN. IS NOT SOMETHING WE
KNOW BILLS. AND SO MAYBE YOU
SHOULD STOP DOING THAT AND
JUST. REFERRED THOSE PEOPLE
INSTEAD OF TWENTY- AND SO I
THINK YOU KNOW AGAIN JUST GOES
TO THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN
SOMEONE BEING TRAINED FOR
SOMETHING AND THE SYSTEMS THAT.
SUPPORTER DON'T SUPPORT THOSE
TYPE OF ACTIVITIES. AND SO
AGAIN I REALIZE THIS PERHAPS
OUTSIDE YOUR DEPARTMENT BUT
BEGAN AS WE'RE BUILDING THIS
WORKFORCE PIPELINES WE NEED TO
BE SURE THAT. THEY CAN GO INTO
POSITIONS. AND THE POSITIONS
THEMSELVES SUPPORT THE TYPE OF
ACTIVITIES ARE TRYING TO TRAIN
THEM FOR. OTHERWISE YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE- THE GROUP WILL
GIVE PEOPLE THROUGH PIPELINES
SHOULD. WE FIND OUT ARE DOING
THE THINGS WE HOPING THEY WOULD
DO BECAUSE THE OTHER- POSITIONS
DON'T ACTUALLY ALLOW THEM TO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY. LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR
MISCELLANEOUS TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS FROM THE LAST ONE
HERE. THOROUGHLY MADAM CHAIR SO
WE HAVE TO TECHNICAL ISSUES THE
FIRST IS THE WITHDRAWAL OF THE
PROPOSED LOAN FROM THE HOSPITAL
BUILDING FUND TO THE GENERAL
FUND IN THE AMOUNT OF FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH WOULD BE
REPAID. AND THE NEXT IS THE
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED ACCOUNT
FOR PHYSICIANS- THE AGE HAVE
EXTENSION FOR THE ENCUMBRANCE
LIQUIDATION PERIOD TO GIVE US
MORE TIME TO LIQUIDATE THE
GRANT AGREEMENTS THAT SUPPORT
THE STEVEN M. THOMSON POSITION
CORPS LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ANYTHING. THANK YOU COMMENT
OKAY I DO NOT HEAR HAND UP MISS
SHE DOES ON OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DESERVED COURSE OKAY. THAT
ONE THANK YOU NO. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY AND NOW WE ARE TO MOVE
ON AND I MISTER EWING THERE
DIRECTOR YOU MENTAL SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY-
COMMISSION COMPARED AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
CHANCE TO JOIN YOU TODAY TOBY
DOING WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH
COMMISSION- PRESENTING ON THE
AUGMENTED FUNDING PROPOSAL FOR
THE MEDICAL STUDENT SERVICES
ACT THE- YOU RECALL AND AS
OUTLINED AS AN AS IS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS AND THE AGENDA
FOR TODAY SENATE SUPPORTED THE
MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES
ACT COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THE
COMMISSION HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE. SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANTS TO EIGHTEEN
COUNTY SCHOOL PARTNERSHIPS TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SCHOOL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
PROGRAMS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES-
THESE WERE SMALL INVESTMENTS
RELATIVE TO THE SCALE OF NEED
BUT VERY IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS.
AND WE WERE UNABLE TO FIND
TWENTY APPLICATIONS THAT CAME
IN AT THAT TIME. WE SEE THESE
PROPOSALS AS WELL I USE THE
TERM THAT SENATOR PAN REFERRED
TO S. CLINIC READY OR PERHAPS
STUDENT READY OPPORTUNITIES TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS AT AS THEY
BEGIN TO RETURN TO SCHOOL IN
THE FALL. OUT PART OF OUR-
EMPHASIS ON THIS PROGRAM IS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
COUNTIES OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF WEEKS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH COUNTIES TO PRE
POSITION SO TO SPEAK
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET THESE
FUNDS OUT TO COUNTIES. AS SOON
AS JULY ONE- WE CAN ACCOMMODATE
THAT SCHEDULE DOES THIS REALLY
MEAN THE COUNTY'S CANADA
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
HAVING THESE CONTRACTS AND
FUNDING IN PLACE WILL ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE SERVICES AVAILABLE
WHEN SCHOOLS REOPEN IN THE FALL
BUT THAT IS OUR INTENTION. TO
BE AS A STUDENT READY AS WE CAN
BE AND AS OUR SCHOOL COUNTY
PARTNERSHIPS CAN BE. THAT THE
MAY REVISE PROPOSES TO INCREASE
THE AUGMENTATION THAT JANUARY
BUDGET INCLUDES TWENTY FIVE
MILLION AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FIVE MILLION THAT WOULD ALLOW
US TO MOVE FROM EIGHTEEN SCHOOL
COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS CURRENTLY.
TO SUPPORT AN ADDITIONAL
TWELVE. AND AB SOME FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT ASSESSMENT
AND EVALUATION OF THE PROPOSAL
AS IT MOVES FORWARD. CITED
ABOUT THIS WORK THERE'S
TREMENDOUS DEMAND ON THE PART
OF COUNTIES AND SCHOOLS AND AS
YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
PAST COUPLE OF HOURS TREMENDOUS
NEED TO SUPPORT STUDENTS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE THERE OFTEN
MOST COMFORTABLE WHERE THERE'S
OFTEN THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
TRUST OF PUBLIC AGENCIES WHICH
IS COOL. AND SO WE SEE THIS AS
AN ESSENTIAL STRATEGY TO BE
VERY RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE TODAY AND- AND
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT FEW
YEARS AS STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES RETURN TO ABOUT THE RE
OPENING OF OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT
MORE SPECIFICALLY RE OPENING OF
SCHOOLS HAVE STRATEGY TO
SUPPORT THE STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AB UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU OKAY M.
BERMAN OF FINANCE AND SEE YOUR
HAND UP ON SEARS UP EITHER MR-
JUST BROKE QUESTIONS EWING AT
HOW MANY ADDITIONALLY FUNDED
GRANT UNCONFIRMED GRANTS CAN WE
FUND WITH A- COMBINED FIFTY
MILLION. WELCOME TO. COME FULLY
FIND ALL OF THE UNFUNDED
APPLICATIONS IT'S A LITTLE OVER
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS. THAT
WOULD STILL LEAVE TWENTY
COUNTIES WHICH ARE PRIMARILY
SMALL RURAL COUNTIES THAT
DIDN'T APPLY. THEY DIDN'T APPLY
FOR A RANGE OF REASONS IN OUR
OUT REACH TO THEM IN SOME
INSTANCES THEY WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF PREPARING FOR KOBE.
AND THEY JUST DIDN'T HAVE THE
TIME TO GO TO THE GRANT
APPLICATION PROCESS- SOME OF
THEM FELT THAT THE SCALE OF
FUNDING WOULD NOT OF BEEN
SUFFICIENT. RELATIVE TO THE
WORK THAT IT WOULD TAKE- BAD
WE'VE CALCULATED THAT TO FULLY
FUND ALL OF THE APPLICANTS THAT
WE HAVE WOULD BE SLIGHTLY OVER
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS. SO WHY
NOT ASK FOR THAT. WELL WE WOULD
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FULLY FIND NOT
JUST THOSE EIGHTY. BUT ALL
COUNTIES. ALL COUNTY
PARTNERSHIPS WHICH WE COULD DO
VERY QUICKLY IF WE DIDN'T HAVE
TO DO IF YOUR COMPETITIVE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS- WE FEEL
LIKE THAT THAT THE NEED IS
THERE AND WE HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN VERY
QUICKLY- THAT'S NOT WHERE THIS
CONVERSATION WITH
ADMINISTRATION LANDED. BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION MOVING FORWARD.
OKAY IT JUST MAKES SENSE AS WE
KEEP TALKING ABOUT THE
IMMEDIACY THAT WERE ABLE TO
FIND AS MANY OF THESE AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN. ADD A BIT THREE
COUNTIES I REPRESENT THE ONE
BUT- NEITHER TWO OF THEM DID
NOT- AND THE OTHER ONE I JUST
HAVE A TEENY SLIVER OF THAT
COUNTY. AND PARTLY IT'S BECAUSE
THEY'RE- THEY'RE THE COUNTIES
WITH LESS CAPACITY SOMETIMES
WITH WHAT WAS STAFF AND
RESOURCES. AND SO I WOULD ALSO
AGREED THAT COMPETITIVE GRANT
CAN MAKE IT- PERHAPS LESS. BUT
LESS LIKELY FOR SOMEBODY TO
JUMP IN I'M WONDERING IF WE CAN
DO SOME KIND OF TIERED SYSTEM
MICHAEL WE HAVE SOME EXTRA CASH
WE CAN. FUND A BUNCH MORE
UNDERSTANDING AT SOME POINT
DOWN THE ROAD- THEY'LL HAVE TO
BE. A MATCH BUT PAN. THE LATEST
PHYSICAL IF WE WERE GOING TO
FIND ALL THE COUNTIES-
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO PRODUCE A
PROPOSAL OF SUFFICIENT QUALITY
FOR YOU- HOW MUCH SO YOU SAID
EIGHTY FOR IF WE FUNDED
EVERYTHING BUT THEN HOW MUCH
FOR. ALL THE COUNTIES. ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OKAY. AT AT THE SCALE.
THAT WE HAD OFFERED OUT. IN THE
INITIAL GRANT JUST TWO AND A
HALF MILLION FOR SMALL COUNTIES
FOR. FOR MEDIUM SIZED COUNTIES
AND SIX FOR LARGE COUNTIES THAT
RECOGNIZES THAT FOR COUNTY LIKE
LOS ANGELES SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IS INSUFFICIENT. BUT IT IS A
ESTAR WHAT WHAT WE WORK BUT
WHEN WE DESIGNED THIS PROGRAM
OF COURSE WE WERE NOT
STRUGGLING WITH KOBE. OUR
INTENT HERE WAS TO INCENTIVIZE
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF ROBUST
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN. OUR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND OUR LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES AND SO WE REALLY WERE
CREATING WHAT WE REFER TO AS
INCENTIVE GRANTS. TO BRING THEM
TO THE TABLE- THAT'S REALLY NOT
A PROBLEM ANYMORE BECAUSE
THEY'RE RECOGNIZING HOW THEY
NEED TO BE WORKING TOGETHER-
BUT IT BUT WE- STILL NEED TO
RESOURCE THEM BECAUSE THERE ARE
NOT NECESSARILY AS YOU'VE HEARD
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF TODAY.
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PRIVATE
HERE HEALTH INITIATIVE. THERE
ARE NOT ADEQUATE RESOURCES THE
STAFFING THE PROGRAMMING THE
TREE THE- THE- FUNDING TO
SUPPORT TRAINING. AND SCREENING
FOR STUDENTS AND SO- YOU KNOW
THE NEED IS IMMENSE AS
RECOGNIZE EVIDENCED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. IT JUST
REMIND ME- SO THIS- THIS IS FOR
HOW MANY YEARS THE HOW MANY%
YEARS OF FUNDING ASSISTANCE FOR
ONE YEAR OR- THESE SO. NOW
THESE GRANTS ACTUALLY AVAILABLE
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS WE WORK
WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS. TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH TIME THEY
HAVE TO SPEND THE MONEY IT'S
TYPICALLY THREE YEARS OKAY AND
REYES FOUR OR FIVE OKAY- WE
CANNOT GIVE THEM MORE MORE
DOLLARS IN LAST YOU PROVIDE
MORE DOLLARS BUT WE CAN GIVE
THEM MORE TIME. AND COUNTIES
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO REALLY
TAILOR THEIR PROPOSAL TO THEIR
NEEDS SO MANY COUNTIES ARE
REALLY HIGHLIGHTING SCREENING.
FOR STUDENTS. AND THAT ALL OF
THE CHALLENGES. BUT ALSO THE
OPPORTUNITY SAID THAT PRESENTS
THAT YOU DISCUSSED TODAY. SO
ROUGHLY ON USUALLY AROUND THREE
YEARS HE SAID. EIGHTY MILLION
IF. ALL OR SO CALLED THE YOU
KNOW. CLINIC REYES HERE STUDENT
RIGHT AND THEN UNDER TWENTY
FIVE MILLION TO FUND ALL THE
COUNTY OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. PLEASE TELL US YOUR HAND
UP. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE FUND THIRTY
EIGHTY FIVE HAS NOT BEEN
RECONCILED EFFORTS TIME AND
GIVEN THE CHALLENGE OF MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS SPENDING OUT OF IT
AS WELL AS MANY EXISTING
OBLIGATIONS ON BOTH FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES WE
BELIEVE THAT AT THIS TIME
ABSENT THE PLAN BE RECONCILED
THE CURRENT LEVEL OF RESOURCES
AND FISCALLY PRUDENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS PATEL. OKAY
LET'S MOVE ON TO- THE NEXT
ISSUE WHICH IS- CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE COVERED
CALIFORNIA. I SEE MISTER
BROTHER GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS K<c.cyan> RAVAL DIRECTOR</c>
POLICY ELIGIBILITY IN RESEARCH
COVER CALIFORNIA AND HAPPY TO
BE WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON TO
ADDRESS CURRENT CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET ISSUES- BEGIN WITH ISSUE
ONE BY PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW OF
THE ADVANCE PREMIUM ASSISTANCE
SUBSIDY PROGRAM ADOPTION. THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN INCLUDED
SEVERAL PROVISIONS TO MAKE
COVERAGE THE EXCHANGES MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR PLAN YEARS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WHICH ARE WELL SUMMARIZED
IN THE HEARING AGENDA TODAY-
SPECIFICALLY. IT INCREASED
FEDERAL PREMIUM SUBSIDIES
SUPPORT FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INCOME BELOW 4100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL INCLUDING
ELIMINATING PREMIUMS
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH INCOME BELOW 150% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. I ALSO
ELIMINATED THE CAP ON FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INCOME ABOVE 4100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. SO THAT
NO ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUAL HAS TO
PAY MORE THAN EIGHT POINT 5% OF
THEIR INCOME. IN PREMIUMS FOR
BENCHMARK PLAN. AS YOUR AGENDA
NOTES THE PREMIUM SUBSIDIES
UNDER THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ARE MORE GENEROUS THAN THE
STATE PREMIUM SUBSIDIES WHICH
EFFECTIVELY ZEROS OUT THE
CONSUMER STATE PREMIUM SUBSIDY.
COVER CALIFORNIA IMPLEMENTED
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
PREMIUM SUBSIDY ENHANCEMENTS
FOR COVERAGE BEGINNING MAY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR. AFTER NEW
AND EXISTING MEMBERS. FOR THIS
REASON THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
STATE PREMIUMS THAT SEEKS
BENCHERS WILL BE LIMITED TO THE
PERIOD JANUARY THROUGH APRIL
AND FOR COVERAGE FROM THE FIRST
OF THIS YEAR THROUGH THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO CONSUMERS WILL
RECEIVE ONLY FEDERAL PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES THROUGH THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IN AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN. THE MAY REVISION
REFLECTS A REDUCTION OF GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURES FORTY FOR
BOTH CURRENT AND BUDGET YEAR TO
REFLECT THIS YEAR OWING OUT OF
THE STATE PREMIUM SUBSIDY TO
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. THAT
CONCLUDES MY BRIEF OVERVIEW BUT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AND THEN I
WOULD TURN IT TO MY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE COLLEAGUES TO
ADDRESS A QUESTION TO. THE SIDE
OF. OKAY WHEN WE GO AHEAD AND
HAVE FINANCE ADDRESS QUESTION
TO THAT. THANK YOU IN SHEFFIELD
APARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
QUESTION TO- THE STATE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED AS A
TEMPORARY THREE YEAR PROGRAM IN
PART TO PROVIDE A BRIDGE UNTIL
POSSIBLE FEDERAL ACTION
INCREASING HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WE APPLAUD THE
BOLD ACTIONS OF THE FEDERAL AND
BY NOON MINISTRATION WHICH HAVE
HELPED EXPAND AFFORDABILITY FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS. THE
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE AREA
OF HEALTH CARE PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE DOES NOT CHANGE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY. AND
DOES NOT PRECLUDE US FROM
EXPLORING OTHER AFFORDABILITY
OPTIONS IN FUTURE BUDGETS WHICH
MAY HAVE COST GREATER THAN THEY
WERE YOUR FUNDS I'M OUT. BY
SETTING ASIDE THE PENALTY
REVENUE WE ARE MAINTAINING THE
COMMITMENT TO USE A PENALTY
REVENUE TO INCREASE
AFFORDABILITY MEASURES. WE ARE
OPEN TO IDEAS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING FUTURE
INVESTMENTS IN THIS AREA
INCLUDING USING. USE OF GENERAL
FUND BEYOND THE AMOUNT SET
ASIDE IN THE PROPOSED RESERVE
FUND. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. THAT
WOULD BE. HELLO MANY THANKS
JOHNSON OKAY NO HAND UP OKAY OF
THE FENCE. YEAH BUT THANKS VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OPENNESS TO
LOOK AT- YOU YOU- FOR
DIVISIONAL- HEALTH COVERAGE
AFFORDABILITY OPTIONS I WOULD
ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT THAT I
CERTAINLY FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE
IF I KNEW THAT THE- BUDGET THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SUBSIDIES WHICH WE'RE CERTAINLY
VERY HAPPY TO SEE AN- BUT NO
CALIFORNIA LEADING AND STARTING
THIS- AND THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NOW HELP ANNOUNCE
AND- PROVIDING THESE
ALTERNATIVE SUBSIDIES- BUT I'D-
I HOPE THAT ALSO IS WE'RE
LOOKING AT HOW YEARS THAT IN
CASE. UNFORTUNATELY IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOESN'T
SUSTAIN THIS THAT WE ARE GOING
TO PLAN TO BE ABLE TO RESUME
THESE SUBSIDIES- IF FOR SOME
REASON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
NOT ABLE TO CONTINUE THEIR
PLAN- SO THAT WE DON'T CREATE
A- SUDDEN SHIFT FOR PEOPLE
INCOME CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY AT
ISSUE NUMBER TWO ONE DOLLAR
PREMIUM SUBSIDY PROGRAM. OKAY
EXCELLENT UNDER THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT FEDERAL PREMIUM TAX
CREDITS CANNOT BE USED ON THE
PREMIUM AMOUNT FOR CERTAIN
ABORTION SERVICES THE FORMAL
CARE ACT ALSO REQUIRES A
QUALIFIED HEALTH PLANS OFFERED
THROUGH MARKETPLACES LIKE COVER
CALIFORNIA MUST SEPARATELY
ESTIMATE THE PREMIUM COST OF
THESE ABORTION SERVICES AND
THOSE COSTS COULD NOT BE LESS
THAN ONE DOLLAR PER MEMBER PER
MONTH. FOR THIS REASON MANY
COVER CALIFORNIA ENROLLEES HAD.
HAD TO PAY A ONE DOLLAR MONTHLY
PREMIUM EVEN THOUGH THE PREMIUM
TAX CREDITS AVAILABLE TO THEM I
WOULD OTHERWISE COVER THEIR
ENTIRE PREMIUM COSTS. AS I
MENTIONED IN THE LAST ISSUE THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ELIMINATES
PREMIUM CONTRIBUTIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH INCOME BELOW
110050% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. AND SO THIS MEANS THAT
MORE AT COVERED CALIFORNIA
ENROLLEES THAN EVER COULD HAVE
ACCESS TO ZERO PREMIUM PLAN BUT
FOR THE ONE DOLLAR MONTHLY.
CHARGE THAT'S REQUIRED FOR
ABORTION SERVICES. RECENT
RESEARCH ON MARKET PLACE
ENROLLMENT SUGGESTS THAT
THERE'S A SO CALLED ZERO PRICE
EFFECT WHERE ENROLLMENT SPIKES
IN MARKET PLACES ARE THAT HAVE
PREMIUMS THAT ARE FREE AS
OPPOSED TO JUST VERY LOW COST.
SO THIS PROPOSAL BUILDS ON THAT
RESEARCH AND WOULD ALLOW COVER
CALIFORNIA TO OFFER TRUE ZERO
PREMIUM PLANS. ARE SPECIFICALLY
UNDER THIS BUDGET ITEM COVER
CALIFORNIA'S REQUESTING
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH A
PERMANENT PROGRAM TO PAY THE
ONE DOLLAR PER MEMBER PER MONTH
CHARGE FOR ABORTION SERVICES
FOR WHICH FEDERAL FUNDING IS
PROHIBITED. AND WE'RE ALSO
REQUESTING EXPENDITURES STORY
OF APPROXIMATELY TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE PROGRAM FOR
BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. WE BELIEVE THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM ENHANCEMENT. TO
INCREASE COVERAGE FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM TODAY.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT WHEN
PAIRED WITH COVER CALIFORNIA'S
UPCOMING IMPLEMENTATION OF AUTO
ENROLMENT OF INDIVIDUALS LOSING
MEDICAID COVERAGE. OF THIS
POLICY COULD BE A POWERFUL TOOL
FOR MANY IN SMOOTHING THE
TRANSITION FROM MEDICAID TO
COVER CALIFORNIA. IF APPROVED
COVER CALIFORNIA WOULD PAY THE
ONE DOLLAR PER MEMBER PER MONTH
PREMIUM CHARGE BEGINNING FOR
THE COVERAGE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION ON THIS ISSUE AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THE THING
THAT I THINK YOU KNOW HELLO
NOTHING ON THIS ONE- WE JUST
QUICKLY NOTE THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL
AND TO BELIEVE IT COULD BE A
COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH TO
IMPROVE IMPROVING COVERAGE
WITHIN THE- EXCHANGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK WE
WOULD CONCUR HERE SO THANK YOU-
AND THEN. THE FINAL ISSUE IN
HERE IS HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND.
GREAT AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
INVESTMENT IN FEDERAL PREMIUM
SUPPORT. THROUGH MARKETPLACES.
AND WHILE THAT ENHANCE AND
EXPAND THE PREMIUM SUPPORT IS
TEMPORARY PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
AMERICAN FAMILIES PLAN PROPOSAL
WOULD MAKE A SUBSIDIES
PERMANENT- CALIFORNIA IS PROUD
TO PARTNER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO IMPLEMENT OUR
STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM WHICH WE
BELIEVE WAS A SUCCESSFUL PROOF
OF CONCEPT. THE EXPANSION OF
SUBSIDIES TO MIDDLE INCOME
CONSUMERS WHICH WE NOW SEE IN
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLANS. THAT
WE'RE ALSO EXCITED FOR THE
POTENTIAL COVERAGE AND
AFFORDABILITY IMPACT OF THE
ZERO PREMIUM PLAN PROPOSAL AND
AS WE SHOULDN'T PRIOR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE COVER CALIFORNIA
IS COMMITTED TO MAXIMIZING THE
BENEFITS OF THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA. WE WORKED
QUICKLY TO IMPLEMENT THE NEW
SUBSIDIES AND WE'RE OFFERING A
SPECIAL ENROLLMENT THROUGH THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ELIMINATE ANY BARRIERS
CALIFORNIANS ENROLLING IN
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THOSE
SUBSIDIES- WERE ALSO
EMPHASIZING EARLY SIGN UPS
UNDER THE ACT BY INVESTING UP
TO THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS. IN
MARKETING IN OUTREACH EFFORTS
AND WILL CONTINUE THAT THROUGH
THE REST OF THE YEAR AND DURING
OUR TRADITIONAL. OPEN
ENROLLMENT PERIOD NOVEMBER. SO
AS WE WORKS THE BALLOT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO MAXIMIZING.
AND AWAIT THE OUTCOME OF
POTENTIAL ADDITIONAL CHANGES AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WE DO BELIEVE
IT'S PRUDENT TO ESTABLISH A
RESERVE. THAT COULD BE USED
PARTIALLY BACKFILLED THE LOSS
OF THE MORE GENEROUS FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES IF THEY'RE NOT
EXTENDED. OR POTENTIALLY TO
SUPPORT OTHER STATE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY INVESTMENTS COULD
BE EXPLORED IN THE FUTURE. TO
THAT END AND AS WE DISCUSSED
BRIEFLY THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO ESTABLISH A HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY RESERVE
FUND. AND PROVIDE A STORY FOR A
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TRANSFER.
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE MILLION INTO THE
NEW FUND- THE TRANSFER AMOUNT
IS EQUAL TO THE PROJECTED
REVENUE- FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY PAYMENT
FOR TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO. LAST THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO COVER
THE PROPOSED- A ONE DOLLAR
PREMIUM SUBSIDY PROGRAM. THE
FIRM WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE- AND WOULD BE USED
TO IMPROVE AFFORDABILITY OF
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR COVER
CALIFORNIAN RELEASED. THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION ON
ISSUE THREE THE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I DO NOT SEE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAND UP I
DO NOT SEE THE ALEJO'S
DEPARTMENT WELCOME QUE. UM WELL
YOU GOT OFF THE HOOK PRETTY
EASY TODAY MISERABLE YEARS
HERE'S WHERE. TECHNICAL MOSTLY
IN NATURE AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND NOW WE ARE
GOING TO MAYBE WE SHOULD TAKE
LET'S TAKE A TWO MINUTE RECESS
TO GET EVERYBODY SET. BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PART B. OF
OUR HEARING SO WE'LL. TAKE A I
COULD THREE MINUTE RECESS.
OKAY
LET'S START. RECONVENE THIS.
COME THIS HEARING AND ON BEFORE
I TURN TO DIRECTOR. JOHNSON LET
ME SAY THERE WAS ONE TYPE- IN
OUR- AGENDA. UNDER ISSUE ONE
UNDER DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- THE BULLET FOR THE
CAL WORKS INDIAN HEALTH
CLINICS. INCORRECTLY IDENTIFIES
A PROPOSED INCREASE OF THREE
POINT NINE MILLION. IT IS ONE
POINT NINE MILLION NOT THREE
POINT NINE MILLION AND WE KNOW
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. COUNTS
EVEN WE HAVE A SURPLUS OKAY-
DIRECTOR JOHNSON A NICE TO SEE
YOU AGAIN. THEY KNOW
EVERYBODY'S NAMES NOW IT'S
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD SO WELCOME- AND A
YEAR ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE CALYX.
TRAINING THANK YOU MADAM JIM
JOHNSON DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES JUST QUICKLY GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT SEVERAL PROPOSALS
FROM THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR
DESCENDS ONE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS. CALIFORNIA COME BACK
PLAN IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO MAY REVISE PROPOSAL WHICH
PROPOSES TO MAKE INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA STATE GINEPRI BRANDS
THAT HAVE BEEN DESIGNED TO
COLLECTIVELY WORK TO DISRUPT
POVERTY. BY PROVIDING HOUSING
CASH ASSISTANCE STUDENT HEALTH
BENEFITS ACCESS TO CHILDCARE
AND EARLY LEARNING AND MORE
SHE'S A STORE CALLED MULTI
GENERATIONAL INVESTMENTS WILL
HELP PROVIDE A FOUNDATION TO
ADVANCE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
IMPROVED. SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING
THOSE WHO NEED IT MOST WHAT
SPECIFICALLY WERE PROPOSING TO
CONFRONT HOMELESSNESS AT
HISTORIC LEVELS INCLUDING
STRENGTHENING THE INTEGRATION
OF HOUSING AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
PROVIDE GREATER SUPPORTS FOR
ADULTS OUR ELDERS AND THOSE
WITH DISABILITIES AGAIN SEEKING
TO ACHIEVE FUNCTIONAL ZERO ON
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS WITHIN FIVE
YEARS. THEY'RE A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION RENTAL SUPPORT
THROUGH CAO WORKS IN NEW
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS
WE ALSO HAVE A NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS HERE AT WORKING WITH
PROVIDING ECONOMIC RELIEF. TO
THOSE MOST GREATLY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC AND THOSE
EXPERIENCING POVERTY POVERTY
INCLUDING A TWELVE BILLION
DOLLAR EXPANSION OF THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS A MAXIMUM EIGHT
PAYMENT INCREASE OF FIVE POINT
3% FOR FAMILIES PARTICIPATING
IN CAL WORKS. I WE ALSO HAVE
PROPOSED HERE IN YOUR AGENDA
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION AND
ACCESS WE TALKED ABOUT A BIT
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE EARLIER
THIS AFTERNOON HERE. I TO CHILD
CARE SUBSIDIES EARLY EDUCATION
AND TO BROADER PREVENTION
EFFORTS WE ALSO HAVE A NUMBER
OF PROPOSALS THAT WILL
STRENGTHEN OUR IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION EFFORTS AS WELL AS
SERVICES TO SUPPORT TRIBES OF
NATIVE AMERICANS. AND FINALLY
WE'RE PROPOSING NEW ECONOMIC
MOBILITY OPPORTUNITIES CAREER
PATHWAYS AND SUPPORT FOR THOSE
WORKING IN THE CARE ECONOMY.
TODAY YOU HAVE TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT LEADERSHIP ACROSS
SEVERAL DIFFERENT. PARTS OF THE
ORGANIZATION THE ORGANIZATION
OF THE MY TRULY. TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH TO ACHIEVE OUR
MISSION AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO OUR CHIEF DEPUTY TO.
CHEN CHOI UP FOR THE FIRST ITEM
ON CALPERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR JOHNSON GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. GEN SHARIA
TO DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES-
WITH RESPECTIVE ACCOUNT WORKS
PROGRAM WE HAVE EXCITING
INVESTMENTS HERE IN SUPPORTING
ECONOMIC STABILITY. AND
MOBILITY I HAVE BOTH TO CREATE
A MORE INCLUSIVE SOCIETY AND WE
BELIEVE A MORE RESILIENT
ECONOMY. THE STATE'S WELFARE TO
WORK PROGRAM IS FUNDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION AT SIX
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
TOTAL FUNDING BUT THEN
ANTICIPATED CASELOAD OF OVER
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND FAMILIES. WE WILL NOTE
THAT THIS IS LOWER THAN THE
ESTIMATED CASELOAD IN THE
JANUARY TENTH BUDGET DUE TO
UPDATES WITH ACTUAL DATA. BUT
IT IS STILL REFLECTING A
CASELOAD INCREASE BASED ON THE
ASSUMPTION THAT FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WILL
EXPIRE BEGINNING IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. RIGHT IN THE
BUDGET- I FIVE POINT 3% TO
STRICTER JOHNSON MENTIONED
EFFECTIVE OCTOBER FIRST BASED
ON THE FUNDING AVAILABLE IN THE
CHILD POVERTY AND FAMILY
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
COUNTS. THIS EQUATES TO I'M
NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR A FAMILY OF
THREE AND A HIGH COST COUNTY.
BY OUR CALCULATIONS- WHICH
INCLUDES ALL OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BEING AIDED. THAT
IS 51% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND
THOUGH TO THE QUESTION IN YOUR
AGENDA AND NOTE THAT THAT
CALCULATION IS NOT THE SAME AS
THE ONE THAT THE SENATE HAS
USED. TO TRY TO MEASURE POVERTY
BY LOOKING AT AN ASSISTANCE
UNIT PLUS ONE ADDITIONAL
PERSON- THE COMPARISON TO THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL WOULD BE
LOWER UNDER THAT METHODOLOGY.
IN ADDITION TO THE GRANT
INCREASE BAMBI REVISION
INCLUDES- ASSISTANCE TO HELP
WITH URGENT NECESSITIES FOR
FAMILIES UNDER THE PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE FUND.
EXPECT PEACE TO BE ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME FRAME NON RECURRING
SHORT TERM. BENEFITS AROUND SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLARS FOR
EACH FAMILY RECEIVING WORKS. IN
THE REVISION ALSO INCLUDES
OVERPAYMENT RELEASED OUR POLICY
CHANGES WITH RESPECT TO CAL
WORKS BE INVESTMENT THAT THE
CHAIR ALREADY MENTIONS.
RESPECTED INDIAN HEALTH CLINICS
AND INCLUDES AS WELL NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TO SUPPORT
FAMILY REUNIFICATION THIS
FUNDING IS TO ENSURE THAT.
PARENTS WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN REMOVED TO WORK HOW WORKS
RECIPIENTS ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE
RECEIVING CASH ASSISTANCE IN
ORDER TO KEEP STABILITY SO THAT
WE INCREASE THEIR CHANCES OF
BEING ABLE TO WORK TOWARD
UNIFICATION. SO I HAVE HERE
WITH ME THIS AFTERNOON DR
JENNIFER HERNANDEZ WAS OUR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OVER THE FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AND EMPOWERMENT
DIVISION AND SHE AND I BOTH
STAND READY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT WE CAN- FROM THE
CHAIR OR MEMBERS ON CALIPHATE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- LMAO.
AND CHAIR JEANNIE BELOW WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. ALLEN YOU'RE STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING THE
PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS THAT'S IN
FRONT OF YOU FOR THE MAY
REVISION FOR CAL WORK. AND WE
WILL IN THE COMING WEEK OR SO
CONTINUE TO UPDATE YOU WITH ANY
NEW FINDINGS AND ANALYSIS. AT
FIRST LOOK AS IF THAT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR VENTURA JUST MENTIONED
THE CASELOAD IS LOWER AND SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC.
OUR OFFICE HAS BEEN FORECASTING
MUCH LOWER CASE LOADS THEN THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND WHAT WE
WOULD SAY IS THE MAY REVISION
REALLY NARROWS THAT GAP WE'RE
STILL TAKING A CLOSER LOOK AT
IT. IF WE WOULD RECOMMEND ANY
REVISIONS BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS
NOTHING CLOSE TO THE
DIFFERENCES WE WERE RECOGNIZING
AT THISTIME LAST YEAR SO THAT
THE DIFFERENCE IN OUR CASE THAT
ESTIMATE. HAS REALLY NARROWED.
AFTER ALWAYS BEEN AT IN THE
RECENT YEAR HAS SPENT A LOT OF
TIME LOOKING AT THE CAL WORKS
CASELOAD. AND LOOKING AT THE
DECLINE IN THE CASE LOAD. AND
WE DO THINK THAT UPON REVIEW OF
THE MAY REVISION THERE ARE SOME
POLICIES WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THAT
HAVE. THE POTENTIAL TO INCREASE
OUR CASELOAD. IT'S MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE ARE
MORE LIKELY TO COME IN. AND
THOSE THOSE REALLY THOUGH
APPEAR TO HAVE MODEST
INCREASES. THE FIRST IS THAT
THE AS MENTIONED ABOVE FIVE
POINT 3% RATE INCREASE. AT THAT
WOULD BE PAID FOR OUT OF
REALIGNMENT REVENUE. WERE
THINKING THAT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE A MODEST
INCREASE OF THE CASELOAD OF I'M
OF MAYBE. A FEW THOUSAND CASES.
WE WERE ASPECTS I SUBCOMMITTEE
STAFF TO TALK ABOUT HOW THIS
GRANT INCREASED I'M HERE IS TO.
LEGISLATIVE INTENT- AS CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CHOI A MENTION
TO GET BACK ALL CAO WORKS
FAMILIES TO FIFTY PERCENT. OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY GUIDELINE
FOR A FAMILY THAT IS ONE PERSON
LARGER THAN A YOU UNIT THE
ASSISTANCE UNIT. I WILL SAY
THAT ACTUALLY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
ALTHOUGH IT I MEAN FOR GRANT
INCREASE FOR OUR FAMILIES SO
FAR FALLS SHORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE SCHOOL. OUT BY OUR
CALCULATIONS IT LOOKS LIKE AN
AVERAGE SIZE. OUR EX FAMILY
WOULD RECEIVE ABOUT A FIFTY
DOLLAR INCREASE UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. WERE
UNDER THE LEGISLATURE ALTERNATE
INTENT THAT. WOULD BE CLOSER TO
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS. BY
THE ADMINISTRATION ARE PER. AT
USE SOME THE FEDERAL FUNDS TO
SET TO SEND TO FIX EIGHT.
HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLAR ONE
TIME PAYMENTS ALL CAO WORKS
FAMILIES BEGINNING IN JULY. AND
THAT'S BUILDING OFF OF A
PREVIOUSLY. AT SENT HUNDRED
DOLLAR PAYMENT THAT WAS DONE IN
THE SPRING AS PART OF THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PACKAGE.
AS CONSTRUCTED ALTHOUGH THIS
WILL BE A MEANINGFUL INCREASE
FOR FAMILIES WE DON'T THINK
IT'S LIKELY TO NECESSARILY HAVE
A BIG INCREASE IN INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE FAMILIES
TO APPLY. I FOR THE PROGRAM IS
SO IF THAT IS OF INTEREST OF
THE LEGISLATURE- WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THINKING ABOUT MAYBE
GIVING YOURSELF A LITTLE BIT OF
LEAD TIME BEFORE SENDING OUT
THAT GRANTS. AND PERHAPS
PACKAGING IT WITH THEM FUNDING
FOR SOME OUTREACH MONEY. AGAIN
AS OUR INITIAL COMMENTS WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT I THINK HOW
IT WORKS BUDGET AND TRAILER
BILL AS MORE BECOMES AVAILABLE.
AND WERE AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FROM BECCA MYSTERY I
GUESS DO YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENT. YOU GUYS DID YOU ALL
THINK IT'S UP TO THE- 50% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY AND THE L.
A. O. HAS A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION. OF TIME AND A HALF.
YEAH I GUESS AND WHAT I WOULD
SAYIS IT'S NOT SO MUCH A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION I THINK
WE PROBABLY WOULD AGREE WITH
EACH OTHER ABOUT- BOTH OF THE
CALCULATIONS THAT WE'RE
SHARING. BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS
SIMPLE YET ONE OF A DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGY OR FORMULA FOR HOW
TO ACCESS THE GRANDSONS AGAINST
THE POVERTY LEVEL HISTORICALLY
IN THE PROGRAM- THE TYPICAL WAY
THAT WE HAVE DONE THAT IS TO
ACCESS IT FOR AN ASSISTANCE
UNIT OF THE EXACT SIZE- OF THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO DO RECEIVE
IT. BECAUSE THERE IS A LARGE
NUMBER OF- FAMILIES IN THE
QUEUE SLOWED WHERE THERE IS AN
ADULT WHO IS A NATIVE- I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE HAS OPTED TO
USE A DIFFERENT FORMULA TO
ACCOUNT FOR THAT BY ADDING AN
ADDITIONAL. PERSON TO THE SIZE
OF THE ASSISTANCE UNIT FOR
PURPOSES OF COMPARISON SO
THEY'RE TWO DIFFERENT WAYS OF
LOOKING AT THAT COMPARISON
THERE IS NO SORT OF ONE
OFFICIAL WAY TO DO SO. THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FORMULA
INCLUDES WHICH INCLUDES- THE
ASSISTANCE MEMBER UNITS JUST
THEMSELVES AND REFLECTS 51% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IF
YOU WERE TO ADD AN ADDITIONAL
PERSON WHO'S NOT EVEN BY THE
CALYX FROM GRAHAM- AS THE
SENATE HAS CHOSEN TO DO IN
RECENT YEARS FOR YOUR- LOOK AT
IT THEN. THE NUMBERS WOULD BE
DIFFERENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I SEE THE DEPARTMENT. THEIR
HAND REYES FUNCTION. JEAN DR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
NOT AT THIS TIME OKAY. THANK
YOU AND I SAW YOU MATTHEW AT
UNANIMOUS AT MISSPELLED YES.
YOU WOULD AGREE WITH PARCHMENT
YEAH RIGHT YES I AGREE WITH
THAT ASSESSMENT OKAY- THANK YOU
FOR AND THAT AND NOW AND
ACCURATE REMIND ME IF WE IF WE
DO. THAT IMPLEMENT THE KIND OF
ONE APPLICATION PROCESS ONE
DOOR FITS ALL DO WE THINK THIS
WILL HELP INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE ON CAL WORKS TO BE
ABLE TO REACH MORE. I AM I
ASSUME THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
THAT STATEWIDE VERIFICATION
HAVE AND WE DO ALSO HAVE BEEN
NUMBER EITHER EFFORTS UNDER WAY
AS WELL TO ENSURE THAT WE
SERVE. WITH HORIZONTAL
INTEGRATION I THINK IT'S OFTEN
THE DISTRIBUTOR OKAY WELL
CHILDHOOD FAMILY APPROACH TO
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYTHING
THAT ANYONE IS ELIGIBLE FOR IF
THEY ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE AND WE
DO CERTAINLY HOPE. THAT THOSE
APPROACHES AND THE EXISTENCE OF
THE STATE RIGHT VERIFICATION
HUB WILL MAKE THE PROCESS MORE
FRIENDLY FOR FAMILIES AND WILL
ENSURE GREATER ACCESS ACROSS
THE BOARD. THANK YOU FOR
FINDING MY WORDS WHEN I CAN'T.
OKAY I THINK THAT IS ALL AT
THIS TIME LET'S LET'S LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
HOMING HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
CORINNE BUCHANAN AND I SERVICE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. THE MAIN
REVISED PROPOSES EXTENSIONS TO
FIVE OF OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS
JUST TELL THEM TO BETTER MEET
NEED AND ONE NEW PROGRAM
PROPOSED IN JANUARY REVISED.
GRIEF WE WALK THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS. EIGHT I'LL START BY
SAYING THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING SOME ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY THE FOURTEENTH IN
THE- PROGRAM. ANNELIES IN
BOULDER SENIOR AND ADULTS THE-
ONE IMPORTANT CHANGE IS THE
REDUCTION IN THE COUNTY MATCH
FROM 1100% MATCH 25% MATCH FOR
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME HOUSING
GET DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM. EIGHT IN ORDER TO
ENSURE COUNTIES AND TRIBES ARE
ABLE TO EITHER ESTABLISH NEW
PROGRAMS OR TO GROW THEIR
EXISTING PROGRAM. IN ADDITION
TO THEIR DOCTOR IN THE LOCAL
MATCHING MINISTRATIONS TO
MAXIMIZE THE PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY YOU REALLY NEED TO
BE ANY NEED AT ALL. THROUGHOUT
OUR DIVERSE EIGHT. PLEASE
INCLUDE ASSISTANCE PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING TARGETED
ASSISTANCE HELP ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUAL ACCESS CALIFORNIA
CODE NINETEEN RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WHICH CAN AS YOU KNOW
HELP KEEP RENTING UTILITIES OR
HOUSING ABILITY. HE'S PROGRAM
EXPANSIONS WILL SUPPORT LONGER
TERM RENTAL SUBSIDIES TO BRIDGE
SUPPORTS BETWEEN RAPID RE
HOUSING INTERVENTIONS TO
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR
EVEN COMMUNITY CARE PLACEMENTS
I'M THRILLED ADULT AND SENIOR
CARE SETTINGS FOR THOSE THAT
NEED DEEPER HOUSING
INTERVENTIONS AT TO DO OUTREACH
AND ENGAGEMENT TO LANDLORDS TO
INSURE ALL INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS YOUR- TIGHTENING HER.
WORKING MAKING HOUSING LESS
CARE I'M EVEN INCLUDING THOSE
WHO HAVE INFORMAL OR
NONTRADITIONAL HOUSING
ARRANGEMENTS INCLUDING PAYMENT.
OF FIRST AND LAST MONTH'S RENT.
I AND OTHER SERVICES AND
NECESSARY FACILITATE THE
TRANSITION FROM. THE ABILITY TO
EXPAND IN REMEMBRANCE HOUSING
TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE SHELTER
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHILE THEY'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF IDENTIFYING
HOUSING. THAT'S ALL A PART OF
THAT A PART OF THAT COLLECTIVE
VISION. I'LL TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT
OUR TO PROPOSALS THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON ENDING FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS. AFTER A MULTI
AGENCY EFFORT WE SPEND ANY
ADMISSIONS GOAL TO ACHIEVE
FUNCTIONAL ZERO ONE FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS WITHIN FIVE YEARS.
YOUR INVESTMENTS AND
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION RENTAL
SUPPORT HOW IT WORKS. AND YOU
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE ARE ALMOST. WHEN YOU SEE
FUNCTIONAL ZERO MEANING THAT
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS RARE BRIEF
AND NON RECURRING. HOWEVER
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM. FOR
DSS THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE MAYBE
BY INCLUDES A FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION IN ATTITUDE AND
BOTH TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWO AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. YEAH THANK YOU TWENTY
THREE WOULD BE AN INCREASE OF
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION- AND THIS WORK AGAIN IS
TO ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE
HOUSING NEEDS OF FAMILIES
EXPERIENCE. OUR PROGRAM HELP
TEEN AND THEN. HE ACKERMAN
HOUSING. SIX ALONE IT IS FOR
JUST- BUT- THREE THIRTY. OR
THIRTY THOUSAND FAMILIES OVER A
MULTI YEAR. YEAH AND THE NEW
PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY AS I
MENTIONED WE'RE FOCUSED ON
PREVENTION TO REALLY STEM THE
IN. WE KNOW IT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ALONE THERE WERE OVER EIGHTY
ALMOST EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN. HELLO I'M- ASKING
MADE TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS. I'LL ALSO JUST
QUICKLY SAY THAT AN ESTIMATED
85% OF FAMILIES WHO TOUCH THE
HOMELESS SYSTEM ARE RECEDING OR
WERE RECENTLY RECEIVING WORK.
FIRST YELLING OUT OF THIS
PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR THE
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM IS
REALLY NOT A DIRECT EFFICIENT
AND HOLISTIC. WAY TO ADDRESS.
NEXT I'M GOING TO ONE FAMILIES
HOME. OUT WHICH IN THE TWENTY
TWO WHEN THEY INCLUDES TO
EIGHTY MILLION- IN GENERAL FUND
FOR THE PROGRAM IN BOTH FISCAL
YEARS WHEN YOU THINK WE ONE
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THE FEDERAL FOR
YEARS AND THE PROGRAM IS
INTENDED TO HELP REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF FAMILIES IN THE CHILD.
WELFARE SYSTEM EXPERIENCING
HOME. IT CREASED REUNIFICATION
AND PREVENT. CARE PLACEMENT. OF
THIS PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR IS
PROJECTED JUST BURKE- OVER
ELEVEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS. IS A QUICK GLANCE.
I NEED WITHIN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. I THOUGHT. WELL NOW THE
LINE OUR FOR CONTROL THAT
SERVES SENIORS AND ADULTS. THE
FIRST IS HM OR ARE HOUSING
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM AN
INMATE REVISION INCLUDES A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION-
OVER THE NEXT THREE FISCAL YEAR
FOR MULTI YEAR FUNDING FOR
EXPAND ON THE NOTABLE
EXACERBATE STAFF PROGRAM WHICH
HAS I'M HAPPY TO SHARE 78%
SUCCESS RATE YOU KNOW APPROVALS
PRESS OUTSIDE WELL ABOVE. THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE PAGE NOT
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO ASSIST
PEOPLE AT BOTH THE STABILIZE
AND HOUSING WHILE ADVOCATING
FOR BENEFITS MOST. NAMELY SS I
SS II I THROUGH THIS PARTICULAR
EXPANSION I'M DESCRIBING WE
PROJECT THAT WE CAN FURTHER
AROUND ELEVEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. EIGHT I JUST TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE SCALE
OF THE NEEDS ARE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABLING CONDITIONS AND OVER
FOURTEEN THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS-WERE OVER THE AGE OF FIFTY FIVE
TOUCH THE HOMELESS. TWENTY
TWENTY IF YOU'RE PRESENTS OTHER.
PROXY OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
ACTUALLY BE ELIGIBLE. FOR NINE
WORK. NEXT I'LL I JUST THE WHO
SPEAK THAT MAY INCLUDE UNDER AT
MILLION I'M OVER THE NEXT YEARS
THE COURT HOME PROGRAM. FUNDS
HERE ARTS PROVIDE HOMELESSNESS
AND PREVENTION SERVICES FOR ALL
AND IT ADULTS WHO ARE PART OF
THE ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
AND WHAT EXPANSION INDIVIDUALS.
OR ADDRESS. LAST YEAH PROPOSED
ONE TIME FUNDING WOULD ALLOW
COUNTY AND TRY TO PROVIDE THEM
BEAT THE HOUSING INTERVENTION-
THAT WE HAVE. THE MODEL THAT WE
THAT WE COME TO REALLY
APPRECIATE IT PROGRAM AND THAT
OUR PARTNERS IN HEALTH SERVICES
HI CAN YOU CAN HELP TELL US
HELP MAKE ALL THE DIFFERENCE-
IN RESOLVING THE- I PROJECT
ROOM HE- IS APATHY MANY FOLKS
ARE FAMILIAR OUR- AD CODE
RESPONSE EFFORTS FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
HOTELS AND MOTELS. PROVIDING ON
CONGREGATE SHELTER ON WORK
PROPOSING TO ME REVISED A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN
FUNDING WOULD GO TO COUNTIES IN
CHRIST WERE OPERATING. HE BOTH
TO BE ABLE TO BE HERE I THANK
YOU CAN YOU WOULD NOT
CONGREGATE SHELTERING WITH A
REAL EMPHASIS ON WE HOUSING
EFFORT I HAVE PROJECT ROOM HE
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN PEOPLE
THINK THAT BAY CAN- BE
CONNECTED TO PERMIT HOUSING.
AND NOT GO BACK TO THE STREET.
SO I LOVE RIGHT NOW- DATA FROM
TODAY WE HAVE A NINE. OCCUPIED
ROOMS THE STATE- WITH OVER TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE. HAS THESE TO
SPEAK TONIGHT- BECAUSE PROJECT
HE. RECORDED I'M AS A PANDEMIC.
AND RECORDED THE LONG TERM
STABILITY OF THOSE. ARE LASTLY
I'LL DESCRIBE THE CAN CHARACTER
PRO- WHICH A NEW A NEW PRO I
YOU PROPOSE. AS A PART OF THAT
CHANGE BUDGET AND- I'M LEVEL
WHEN THEY REACH- WHICH IS I
HAVE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR FOR THE NEXT
YEAR. MULTIPLY ACQUISITION
CONSTRUCTION AND WE HAVE ADULT
AND SENIOR CARE FACILITIES AND
INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES ARE
HOMELESS OR AT RISK ALMOST. THE
NUMBER OF I SINCE I WAS AND- IN
THESE TYPES OF SPENDING
DECREASING. EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE TO DECLINE BECAUSE OF
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF COPING
NINETEEN. THE SETTINGS WERE
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
HOUSING. FOR SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES WHEN PEOPLE
HEAR HEALTH CONDITIONS WHO
REALLY HAVE NO ALTERNATIVE
HOUSING OPTIONS TO MEET THEIR
LEVEL OF. THE LIKELY BECOME
HOME. THANK BILLABLE. QUESTIONS
ABOUT- WHAT THE OVERSIGHT AND
REPORTING THE BOOK LIKE THE
LARGEST QUICKLY SHARE THAT THE
COUNTY AND TRIBAL GRANTEES
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULAR RECORDING YES.
INCLUDING DATA ON THE
FACILITIES AND THE NUMBER OF
UNITS THAT ARE REQUIRED OR WE
HAVE. OWNERSHIP STATUS OF THE
FACILITIES NUMBER OF SSI
RECIPIENTS. THE LADIES AND-
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION. AS
WELL AS SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THAT ARE PROVIDED IN THE
LADIES. WORK HOUSING STABILITY
VERY IMPORTANTLY HEALTH
OUTCOMES THOSE. THOSE AS CLIENT.
ALSO THAT WE FUNDING WOULD BE A
TO MAKE BECAUSE TO CERTIFY
THEIR ITENDED YEAR RESIDENTS.
AND THE LENGTH OF THE COVENANTS
YES THIS YET I THE LEVEL OF
HERE AT THE FUNDING THAT HAS
BEEN AWKWARD. MORNING HERE
EXPANSION OUT WE- THAT WE BE
ABLE PRINT. ANOTHER FIVE
THOUSAND NEW BAD AND PURSES
AROUND THOUSAND THAT'S ACROSS.
YOUR SENSE OF SMELL RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE AROUND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND. YEAH IN ADULT AND
SENIOR CARE. THE NUMBER AGAIN
FIFTEEN THOUSAND MANY CORRECT
FIFTEEN TO WHAT. IRAN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS ACCESS I.
S. S. B. RECIPIENTS WHO WERE
LIVING IN LICENSE ADULT IF
YOU'RE CURRENTLY THE DATE. ALSO
SURE THAT THERE WAS A QUESTION
I IN PARTICULAR ABOUT THE
DEADLINE FOR THE AMERICAN
RESCUE FUND RESCUE ACT FUNDING
I'M AND I WILL SHARE AND THAT
THE ONLY PROPOSAL HERE THAT
I'VE JUST DESCRIBED THAT HAS.
AMERICAN RESCUE. PLAN ACTS
FUNDS IN IT YOU THINK YOU NEED
TO CARE EXPANSION WHICH I JUST
DESCRIBED- IT HAS FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THIS FISCAL
YEAR. END OF THE FUNDS WOULD
NEED TO BE SPENT BY JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
SO I KNOW I'VE TAKEN QUITE A
BIT OF TIME SO I'LL STOP THERE
AND JUST SAY THAT I RISING THAT
DEFENSE HAS A SOLID FOUNDATION
AND TRACK RECORD RESPECTIVELY
RAMPING UP. IN EVIDENCE BASED
HOUSING INTERVENTIONS AND THESE
PROPOSED EXTENSIONS WOULD
REALLY ALLOW US TO SCALE THE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ED DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. NUMBER BERMAN OPINIONS
KNOWN AS COMMENTS THIS TIME.
HELLO ANY WITH L. A. MORE IN IS
BECOMING AVAILABLE BY THE DAY
FOR THESE PROPOSAL SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE SURE WE
FULLY UNDERSTAND ALL THE
COMPONENTS AND IT'S MORE OF THE
TRAILER BILL COMES OUT WE'LL
REFINER COMMENTS OR COMMENTS
THEY WILL BE VERY HIGH LEVEL-
AND INITIAL AND THEN WILL
FOLLOW UP. ON AT AS AS YOU'VE
JUST HEARD THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION REALLY CONTINUES TO
RECOGNIZE THE STATE'S HOUSING
AND AFFORDABILITY AND
HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES AND
THIS IS REALLY BEEN A SHARED
PRIORITY OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR AND IS A
WORTHWHILE GOAL. AT THE
GOVERNOR'S OVERALL HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PLAN. AS YOU HEARD
IS MULTI DEPARTMENT- WILL BE
FOR IN SENATE SOME TOMORROW I
THOUGHT FOCUSED COMMENTS ON THE
OF SERVICES OR THAT YOU ABOUT.
I'M IT IS IMPORTANT NO THAT YOU
KNOW WHEN HE QUESTION WE ARE
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL IS REALLY
ALL THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL-
ARE MEDITATIONS REALLY FIT IN
THIS BROADER FRAMEWORK AND WHAT
CONTRIBUTION THEY HAVE TO THE
GOAL OF ELIMINATING
HOMELESSNESS FOR FAMILIES BUT
IN FIVE YEARS SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE WORKING
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE. THE
ROLE THAT THEY PLAY. HOW THEY
MAY REVISION DOES PROPOSE TO X.
THAT J. PROPOSAL FOR THE NEW
PROGRAM TO ACQUIRE. WIRE AND
RENOVATE COMMUNITY CARE
FACILITIES. MOST OF THE
AUGMENTATIONS IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES REALLY FOCUS
ON EXISTING. I HOUSING
PROGRAMS. THE PROPOSAL OF
INTENTIONS REALLY REPRESENT
VERY LARGE INCREASES TO THE
BASELINE FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS SO FOR EXAMPLE. THE
STATE TYPICALLY SPENDS ABOUT
NINETY FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY ON
THE CAL WORKS AS A SUPPORT
PROGRAM THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT.
AND THE PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION. FOR EACH
OF THE NEXT TWO TWO YEAR.
PROGRAM ONE OF OUR QUESTIONS IS
SORT OF WHAT A SECOND WAS DONE
TO DETERMINE. AT THE LEVEL OF
THE ESTIMATED NEED FOR EACH OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND THEN HOW DID
THAT ASSESSMENT TRANSLATE TO
THE FUNDING LEVEL AND HOW DOES
THAT OLD SIMPLY HOPE THE
ADMINISTRATION. I REACH THEIR
GOAL- IT IN FIVE YEARS. SO I
KEEP ALSO BE WHETHER THESE PRO
I THE CAPACITY. TO ADMITTED AND
SPEND THE NEW FUNDING WITHIN
THE TIMELINES OR WHETHER IT
WOULD BE IT WOULD MAKE MORE
SENSE TO USE US YOU HAVE A
SMALLER AMOUNT OF MONEY OVER A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME. HAVE YOU
HEARD TODAY WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION ANTICIPATES
INTRODUCING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS. WHICH ARE REALLY MAKE
MODIFICATIONS TO HOW THEY
OPERATE TODAY. SO THEY COULD BE
ONE FACTOR THERE BILL IS
RELEASED THEY COULD AND IT
COULD CONTAIN. I CHANGES THAT
WOULD ADDRESS SOME OF THE KNOWN
BARRIERS TO THE PROGRAM SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES ACCESS. FOR
EXAMPLE NEEDING TO HAVE AN
EVICTION NOTICE ON HAND AT THAT
COULD BE SOMETHING THAT FEET
THE TRAILER BILL CONTEMPLATES.
AT ANOTHER IDEA THAT WAS
MENTIONED IN IN YOUR AGENDA AND
IN PREVIOUS. MEETINGS OF THE
SUB COMMITTEE WAS EVERY
CONSIDERATION OF THAT COUNTY
MATCH REQUIREMENT- ARE ALLOWING
FOR MORE FLEXIBILITY IN THE USE
OF THE FUNDS. AT YOUR DESS
THINGS THAT MAYBE THE CURRENT
PROGRAMS DON'T ALLOW THOSE ARE
ALL THINGS THAT ARE MINE THAT
WILL BE LOOKING. AT WHEN WE
RECEIVED THAT THE TRAILER BILL
AND ARE ALL. THINGS. FOR THIS
PROPOSAL NOW FOR THIS UPDATED
PROPOSAL WHICH WE THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- LIKE I WAS
IMPORTANT BEFORE BUT IT WITH
THE ENHANCED FUNDING IT'S
PROBABLY EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
NOW THAT WE HAVE THE- RIGHT
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROGRAM'S
PARAMETERS ARE EXPECTATIONS.
OVERSIGHT MECHANISMS THAT
PASSED SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE WILL DEFINITELY BE TAKING A
CLOSE LOOK AT WHEN IT WHEN IT'S
AVAILABLE. AT EITHER TO SOME OF
OUR INITIAL THOUGHTS AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO ADVISE YOU AS
WE AS WE LEARN MORE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF MR CAN CAN YOU CAN
YOU SPEAK TO THAT THE FIRST THE
FIRST ISSUE THE L. A- RAISED
ABOUT HOW DO THESE PLANS. DO
WHAT WHAT DO YOUR METRICS WHAT
ARE YOUR PLANS TO ACTUALLY HOW
ARE THESE GOING TO REDUCE-
ELIMINATE HOMELESSNESS FOR
FAMILIES AND FIVE YEARS. YEAH I
GOT ABSOLUTELY SO I'LL JUST
START BY SAYING THAT DEBT
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS SERVED OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE- ACROSS THE
STATE IN TWENTY TWENTY ALONE
SO- OF COURSE. KEEPING A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THE ABILITY OF US TO
WORK WITH COUNTIES TO STAND UP
PROGRAM'S REALLY QUICKLY AND IN
A RESPONSIBLE WAY. WE WERE ABLE
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
SHELTER BEDS THAT EXIST ACROSS
THE WHOLE SYSTEM OF CARE. BY
OVER 50% IN A MATTER. OF MONTHS
THE INVESTMENT PROJECT. YOU CAN
BRING MANY OF THOSE LAST
LEARNED. AND ACTIVISTS WORK. I
DIDN'T GET WHY CAN CHECK READ
SHARE SOME OF THE NUMBER TO
MAKE EARLIER ABOUT. THE TOTAL
WHICH WE CAN NOW TRACK THROUGH
THE HOMELESS DATA INFORMATION.
DOES THAT- COLLECTS ALL OF THE
LOCAL HOMELESSNESS AND ROLLED
UP INTO. ONE EIGHT FOR FOUND.
WE HAVE PROVIDED SOME INSIGHTS
TERMS OF THAT MEASURE THAT-
WORK YEAH HE'S IN- WE AT IN
TWENTY- THERE WERE ALMOST
THIRTY THOUSAND FAMILIES THAT
TOUCHED THE HOMELESS SYSTEM.
WORKER HOUSING ANNEX YEAH AN
EXPANSION OF PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT BUT
KEEP IN MIND THAT'S IN ONE YEAR
ALONE. BUT BIG PART OF OUR
ABILITY TO BRING FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS TO FUNCTIONAL ZERO
IS ALSO. THREE CONVENTION AFTER
WHICH IS. KIND OF A PART OF THE
PROJECT I HAD EXPECTED
RESOLUTION ON WE NEED STOP THE-
YEAH AND ASTOR. THAT ARE
CURRENTLY HOMELESS BY PROVIDING
THEM THAT. BUT LET ME JUST
DESCRIBE QUICKLY THAT THE
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES. EMERGENCY TEMPORARY
SHELTER IT PROVIDES RAPID RE
HOUSING WHICH IS AN EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICE WE GET PEOPLE
IMMEDIATELY AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE INTO THEIR OWN UNITS
I'M SURPRISED THAT UNIT AND
WRAPAROUND. MANY OTHER OF OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
THAT'S A BIG ADVANTAGE OF THE
WORK THAT WE DO I. DS AFTER
THAT WE- WERE NOTHING. THE
WHOLE FAMILY- THROUGH OUR SUITE
OF. SOCIAL. SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
OUT OF OUR DEPARTMENT- AND THEN
OF. I WILL. PARTNERING BECAUSE-
WITH- ARE OUR SISTER AGENCIES
AGE AND PARTICULAR CD I THROUGH
THEIR HOME HE INVESTMENT WHICH
WILL HELP US TO ACTUALLY CREATE
NEW HOUSING UNITS. THAT WILL
ALIGN REALLY WELL WITH THE WORK
THEY WERE TRAINED TO DEAL WITH
HOUSING HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN- PURCHASE. WE KNOW STONE I
LIKE TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO
BUILD NEW HOUSING BUT ALSO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF EXISTING HOUSING
ON THE MARKET. VIEWS USE RENTAL
SUBSIDIES TO QUICKLY GT
FAMILIES. INTO HOUSING AND
HOUSING THAT MEETS THEIR NEEDS
AND ALLOW. OKAY OKAY- CAN YOU
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PROGRAM- AND I KNOW WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT SS I SS P. LATER
BECAUSE IT JUST SEEMS. I MEAN
WE CAN WE CAN HELP STABILIZE
SOME OF THESE BUT IF WE DON'T
RAISE A REIMBURSEMENT LEVEL
THEN. THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO STAY
IN BUSINESS RIGHT I MEAN SO
THAT THIS IS A TWO PRONGED
ISSUE SO TELL ME HOW SO TELL ME
HOW THIS PROBLEM IS GOING TO
INCREASE CAPACITY AND I WAS
TRYING TO SAY. RIGHT NOW THERE
ARE FIFTEEN THOUSAND. PEOPLE
HOW MANY MORE D WE HOPE TO GET
WITH THIS THAT WITH THIS
INFUSION. THANK YOU GREAT
QUESTION SO THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION IS ALL ABOUT
EXPANSION AND PRESERVATION WE
WANT TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF-
THE PHILLIES BUT CANNOT
CONSERVE PEOPLE WHO RUN SS I SS
II. AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS RIGHT.
THANK YOU. SO I'M WE DO THAT BY.
ACTORS AND RE. AND THEN USING.
USE RESTRICTIONS JUST THAT AT
THESE UNITS MUST. POPULATE ON
THE PRESERVATION SIDE IT CAN BE
THINGS LIKE I GOT IT THE SILLY-
WHAT I NEED IF I'M GONNA GO OUT
OF BUSINESS BUT WHAT I NEED IS
A NEW ROOF SO HOW CAN BE FUNDS
THE RE HAVE TO SHORE UP THE
DEFERRED MEET. ANY KIND
SETTINGS THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO OPERATE AS PART OF OUR
HOUSING KIANA WE ALSO- HAVE
DESIGNED A PROGRAM IN A WAY
THAT- ALIGNS WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE WHO WERE LIVING.
IN ADULT AND SENIOR CARE
FACILITIES MANY COUNTIES ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THESE
TYPES OF FACILITIES EITHER WORK
ON PROVIDE FUNDING DIRECTLY TO
THE FACILITY FOR AUXILIARY
SERVICES OR IN SOME CASES IN
KIND SUPPORT THEY MAY LATER ON-
ON SITE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
HELP. HELP ACTUALLY MEET THE
WHOLE NEEDS OF FOLKS WHO WORK
WHO ARE HOUSED IN THE SETTINGS-
DON'T YOU KNOW THAT. BRINGING
NEW YOU KNOW HOW BY. ACCORDING
COST OF THE ACTORS AND READ. OR
THAT FOR ME. IS A PART OF
PLANNED MAKE SURE THAT WE AND
HER THIS BILL IN. AND WE IMPART
HOME MANY MANY BEDS QUALITY HOW
MANY BEDS DO WE THINK WE CAN
EXPAND HERE WE HAVE A GOAL.
YEAH WE ARE PROJECTED TO BE
ABLE TO BRING ON FIVE THOUSAND
YOU BET. AND PRESERVE. ABOUT
FOUR THOUSAND. THANK OKAY OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE WILL WE WILL
ALL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON THIS-
GOING FORWARD I THINK IT'S IT
IS A- AGAIN- WE ALL AGREE WITH
THAT WE ALL AGREE WITH THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM. BUT
JUST HAVING THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES AND TO ACTUALLY.
ADDRESS IT WITHOUT WITHOUT
CREATING POCKETS OF FRAUD AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED TO BE HELPED ARE REALLY
HELPED. AND TO MAKE IT I THINK
THAT. THE SOME CONFIRM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ALWAYS AS EASY AS WE
CAN FOR OUR LOCALS TO BE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT AND SO IF THERE'S-
IF THAT THE COUNTY MATCHES IT
CAN SOMETIMES BE DIFFICULT I
MEAN WILL LET LET'S LET'S
ALWAYS LOOK AT WAYS. TO ADD TO
GET RID OF THOSE AND- AND THE
OTHER THING THAT. I THINK STAFF
AND I AND WE ALL JUST WANT TO
KEEP RAISING THIS IDEA OF THEM
SOMETIMES WE DON'T LIKE IT AND
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE TO
HOUSING STABILIZATION. SO THAT
PEOPLE DON'T FALL OUT AND THEN
HAVE TO BECOME HOMELESS BEFORE
WE CAN HELP THEM- IN THOSE
KINDS OF- NINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE CREATE
SOMETIMES. CAN BE INCREDIBLY.
M. A- THE DEVASTATING- AND LET
ME JUST SAY WHAT WITH WITH THE-
THE H. STEP PROGRAM I TO GET
MORE PEOPLE ON SSI IS GREAT.
BUT IT BUT AGAIN IF WE DON'T
EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF BAD
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS ON THE
STREETS RIGHT NOW- WITH SSI AND
THEY CANNOT FIND A GOOD
PLACEMENT. YOU KNOW WE TALKED
EARLIER ABOUT CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. I CAN ASSURE
YOU THAT THERE ARE ADULTS ON
THE STREET RIGHT NOW WHOSE
FAMILIES HAVE TRIED TO HELP
THEM SINCE THEY WERE CHILDREN.
AND ARE NOW STILL TRYING TO
HELP THEM AND STILL CANNOT FIND
STABLE HOUSING. FOR OUR
SERIOUSLY AND PERSISTENTLY
MENTALLY ILL POPULATION SO.
THE- THE I AM THE APPS THAT THE
HOUSING TO STEP DOWN ALL OF
THAT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT WE
FIGURE OUT A WAY. TO MAKE IT
WORK. AND YOU ARE. ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT THAT IF WE CAN AND YOU
SAID THE BEGINNING PREVENT HIM
FROM GETTING HOMELESS OR
RAPIDLY RE HOUSING PEOPLE. IS
LIKE TRYING TO AVOID THAT
FIRST. PSYCHOTIC BREAK IF WE
CAN PREVENT THAT OR OR MINIMIZE
IT QUICKLY THEN WE HAVE. WAY
BETTER CHANCES FOR LATER- OKAY
ALL RIGHT AND THEN THE ISSUE OF
WE'LL TALK ABOUT LOCAL ENTITIES
PERHAPS NOT HAVING A MATCH AND
BEING ABLE TO THINK ABOUT- SOME
OF THOSE THINGS TO. OKAY ALL
RIGHT THEN LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE AUTOMATION
PROGRAMS. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
SELENA CHAU CHIEFOPERATING
OFFICER AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND I'LL BE
GOING OVER THE KEY CHANGES IN
THE MAYOR VISION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT'S AUTOMATION
PROGRAMS THAT ARE LAID OUT IN
THE ENGINE. THE FIRST TWO ITEMS
ARE RELATED TO THE STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED WATER SYSTEM WHICH IS
USEDFOR THE ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION AT HOWARD'S
RESTAURANTS. AND SO THE FIRST
ITEM OF ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS- SIX AND A FIFTY
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND. IS
NEEDED TO UPDATE THE NOTICE OF
DENIAL OR PENDING STATUS FORM
THIS IS A FORM USED BY COUNTIES
JUNE THIRD BY HOUSEHOLDS OF
THEIR APPLICATION STATUS AT THE
NATIONAL APPLICATION AND
RECERTIFICATION. AND IT NEEDS
TO BE UPDATED TO INCLUDE HE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION REGARDING
THE REASON FOR DENIAL OR THE
PENDING STATUS OF THE CASE IN
ORDER TO COMPLY. WITH THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. THE I IN-
RELATED TO THE CONSOLIDATED
PORTAL AND SMALL FUNCTIONALITY
WITHIN THE COUNCIL'S MIGRATION
TO A SINGLE SYSTEM. AND THE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FRIENDS
IS TO INCORPORATE TRANSLATIONS
INTO TWENTY ACTUAL LANGUAGES
THIS SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT'S
MISSION AND GOAL TO PROVIDE
QUALITY SERVICES WITH A FOCUS
ON EQUITY INCLUSION AND STATE
OR CITY AND- RESEARCH. AND THEN
THE ENTERPRISE DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS IS A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
REQUESTS CHIU IMPROVE OUR
DEPARTMENT'S DATA ACQUISITION
AND PROCESSING OPERATIONS. THIS
WOULD ALLOW US TO PROCURE NEW
INTEGRATION AND DATA WAREHOUSE
PLATFORMS EXPAND THE
DEPARTMENT'S CURRENT CAPACITY
AROUND YOU TO CAPTURE STORAGE
AND PROCESSING AND ALLOW US TO
HAVE MORE ROBUST DATA ANALYTICS
AND INTERSECTIONS ACROSS
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS WITH PARTIDA.
THREE ARE RELATED TO THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES DATA SYSTEMS.
FIRST ONE IS THE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OR FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND GENERAL
PLANS FOR COUNTIES TO SUPPORT
THE CBS DATA CLEAN UP
ACTIVITIES. CURRENT SYSTEM
INCLUDES A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN'T
DETER THAT'S INHERENT IN THE
HISTORIC ARCHITECTURE OF THE
SYSTEM AND SO THIS DATA CLEANUP
IS NEEDED TO INSURE THAT CLEAN
DATA IS CONVERTED TO THE NEW
CARE SYSTEM THAT'S UNDER
DEVELOPMENT. AND THEN THE-
ESTIMATES MIGRATION SO THIS IS
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONE POINT TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND. TO MIGRATE
EXISTING PLATFORMS SO THAT IT
CAN BE SUPPORTED BY MICROSOFT
AND IBM THE CURRENT PLATFORM IS
ANTIQUATED AND WILL NO LONGER
BE SUPPORTED. SERVICE
MIGRATIONS THE UPDATED PLATFORM
WILL HELP ALLEVIATE ANY
POTENTIAL RISKS OF DESTRUCTION
OR STOPPAGE WHICH COULD OCCUR
WITH MICROSOFT HALF PATCHES IN
OUR- OPERATING SYSTEM UPGRADES.
NO NO I ITEM IS. REVISED FOR.
OUR CARE PROJECT REQUESTING
THIRTY POINT FOUR MILLION
GENERAL FUND. RESPONDING THIRTY
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR ALL
BILL WITH THAT- AND NOT REPLACE
IT COSTS YOU. HARMON'S A
SERVICE. DISSIPATION ACTIVITIES
FOR OUR USER CENTERED DESIGN
FUNCTIONS AND IT ALSO INCLUDES
AN UPDATED SCHEDULE REFLECTS
THE LATEST DELIVERY APPROACH
WHICH WE MET DR ED- THAT WOULD
DEPLOY PRODUCTION INCREMENTALLY
AND MODULES AND THEN THAT WOULD
LATER BE FOLLOWED BY A FULL
FUNCTIONALITY WHEN IT REPLACES
A SENIOR US CMS. SIR THAT'S
SEEING. THE OVERVIEW OF THE
AUTOMATION CHANGES ON HOW. THE
ANSWERING QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ANYTHING. THE SERVICE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NOTHING TO
ADD AT THIS TIME. LMAO HELLO
WITH THE L. A. WE'RE KICKING
OFF A CLOSE LOOK AT ALL OF
THESE REQUESTS I WOULD JUST
STAY ON THE LAST ONE THE CWS
CARE IS REQUEST WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT OF THE
PROJECT AS IT MOVES THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH I
WOULD I WOULD CONCUR AT. ALL
ALL ALL ALWAYS ALL THINGS WITH
THE I. T. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE- GOOD OVERSIGHT ON
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
IDENTIFY ISSUES EARLIER THAN
LATER- AS WE TEND TO HEAR ABOUT
HIM OUT. OUT IN THE PUBLIC-
VERY QUICKLY SO- WILL BE EAGER
TO SEE THAT BUDGET TRAILER
LANGUAGE WHEN IT COMES UP WITH
THE- F. PLAN THE EVALUATION AND
THE- FEEDBACK LOOPS ALL BUILT
INTO. OKAY ISSUE NUMBER. FOUR
JENNIFER TRY AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT- ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
RELATES TO SS I SS P. WHICH IS
ALREADY BEEN THE SUBJECT OF-
QUITE A BIT OF DISCUSSION. HERE
TO DAVE THIS PARTICULAR ITEM IS
MORE ABOUT THE GRANT IN THE
PROGRAM SO AS YOU KNOW THE
PROGRAM SERVES. OUR ELDERS IN
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
WHO ARE LOW INCOME AND PROVIDES
CASH ASSISTANCE. THE INCREASE
PROVIDED IN THE MAY REVISION IS
TWO FOLD ONE IS REFLECTING AND
SSI COLOGNE COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND THE
SECOND IS REFLECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR AN
INCREASE TO THE S. S. P.
PORTION OR THE STATE
SUPPLEMENTAL PORTION. OF THE
PAYMENT- THE RESULTS OF THAT
AND INCREASES IN. FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE GRANTS WOULD
GO FROM- NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH IN
202-129-0090 DOLLARS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND THE CONNECTION
AND THE REASON FOR THE FOCUS ON
THE GRANTS FOR INDIVIDUALS
RATHER THAN COUPLES IS RELATED
TO A REDUCTION THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUALS. A SEVERAL YEARS
AGO DURING THE GREAT RECESSION
THE RESULTS OF THE GRANT
INCREASE AT PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION WOULD
BE A GROUND LEVEL THAT IS
EQUIVALENT TO WHAT WAS PROVIDED
IN TWENTY ELEVEN- AS YOUR
AGENDA NOTES THIS IS NOT A FULL
RESTORATION OF ALL. REDUCTIONS
THAT OCCURRED OVER THE COURSE
OF SEVERAL DECADES OR ALL FOUR
GRAND. YOU SEE YOURS. IS
NONETHELESS A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S MEAN REVERSION-
I HAVE AT OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
DEBBIE THOMPSON HERE WITH ME
AND WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THE PARTNER FINANCE.
BRITISH ASSUME CONTINUE TO
FINANCE FURTHER COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME HELLO. THANK YOU
PROCEED WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE AND WE WERE
ASKED BY STAFF TO HIGHLIGHT
AREAS WHERE ME REVISION
PROPOSALS MAY NOT FULLY ALIGNED
WITH LEGISLATIVE OR SENATE
PRIORITIES I'M SO FOR AND AGAIN
OUR COMMENTS TODAY REFLECT OUR
CURRENT UNDERSTANDING OF THESE
PROPOSALS AND WILL PROVIDE
UPDATES AS WE LEARN MORE IF
NEEDED- BUT BEFORE WE DIG INTO
THE EXERCISES PETE GRANT
INCREASE PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY.
A BROADER POINT OUR OFFICE HAS
MADE ABOUT THE BUDGET AND ITS
TOTALITY IS THAT WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DIRECTING
RESOURCES I'M TO PROP UP NEW
SOCIAL SERVICE INTERVENTIONS WE
DO NOT NECESSARILY SEE THE SAME
AUGMENTATION LEVELS AND MAJOR
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS LIKE A
SCIENCE S. P. I'M- NOW
SPECIFICALLY REGARDING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S S. S. P.
GRANT. INCREASE WHICH BASED OFF
OF OUR ROUGH CALCULATIONS WOULD
ESSENTIALLY INCREASE GRANTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS BY TEN DOLLARS-
WELL THAT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION RELATIVE TO
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES IT STILL
ISN'T IN FULL ALIGNMENT
SPECIFICALLY- AS A PART OF THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NIGHT ARE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT OF THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
INTENT LANGUAGE- TO BEGIN TO
PROVIDE ONGOING. COLAS OR COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS TO THE S.
S. B. PORTION OF THE GRANT
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AM AT OUR TWO TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND I'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
BEYOND THIS I'M GREAT INCREASE
DOESN'T PROVIDE ANY FUTURE COAL
ONCE. I'M ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD
JUST LIKE TO FLAG THAT AS A
PART OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING- IT WAS INCLUDED. WITHIN
THEIR STRATEGY THEIR BROADER
STRATEGY ON ANTI POVERTY- THE
OVERALL GOAL OF INCREASING
EXERCISES PEAK GRANTS TO THE
ELDER ECONOMIC INDEX OR THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL TO THE
EXTENT THAT FUNDS WERE
PROVIDED- I ALSO JUST LIKE TO
FLAG BASED OFF OF A ROUGH
CALCULATION IN TERMS OF WHAT
WHERE DOES THIS GET. RECIPIENTS
THAT BASED OFF OF THAT F. P. L.
RUSH HOLD BUT WAS ALSO RAISED
IN LAST WEEK SENATE BUDGET
HEARING- IT'S BASED OF OUR
ROUGH CALCULATIONS WE FIND THAT
RECIPIENTS ARE STILL- FURTHER
AWAY FROM THE F. P. L. THAN
THEY WERE RELATIVES- TWO TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN LEVELS. SO WITH
THAT SAID THE LEGISLATURE COULD
VIEW THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL AGAIN AS PERHAPS A
STARTING POINT- AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTERESTED IN PICKING A
DIFFERENT GRANT THRESHOLD THAT
PERHAPS- RESTORES A GREATER
SHARE OF THE PAST S. S. P.
REDUCTIONS. THAT'S AN OPTION
THAT WE'D BE HAPPY TO ASSIST
THE LEGISLATURE AND- BUT THEN
ALSO ANY OTHER OPTIONS AT THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERING HAPPY
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- YEAH I GUESS. I
GUESS THAT THAT IS THE QUESTION
AND IN THE BILLIONS. AND
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE GONNA.
INITIALLY INVEST IN NEW. AND IN
TRYING TO DO AS MUCH OUTRAGE AS
WE CAN TO GET MORE PEOPLE. INTO
CAL WORKS IN DIFFERENT KINDS OF
PROGRAMS- WE ALREADY HAVE THIS
PROGRAM. AT THAT IS THAT WOULD
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE A AT. A
SITTING DEMOGRAPHIC THERE WHO
WE KNOW ARE VERY POOR PEOPLE
OFTENTIMES WITH DISABILITIES
WHY NOT INVEST MORE IN THEIR-
TO GET PEOPLE AGAIN WITH THE
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. POVERTY
RATES ARE YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S A DECADE AGO ITEM AND
TO. EVERYBODY'S COST OF LIVING
HAS GONE UP TREMENDOUSLY- I
HAVE I HAVE CLOSE FRIENDS. WHO
ARE ON SS I SS PETER I HAVE I
HELP EVERY MONTH BECAUSE IT IS
JUST NOT ENOUGH. TO MAKE IT
THROUGH. AN WELL COMMUNITY
SUPPORT IS IMPORTANT- WE DON'T
WANT TO JUST DEPEND UPON THE
KINDNESS OF OUR FRIENDS. AND
NEIGHBORS- TO MAKE THREE POSTER
WE HAVE ENOUGH TO EAT EVERY
MONTH SO CAN YOU SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT TOO. THE RATIONALE TOWARDS
NOT INCREASING- THE GRANT
ADDITIONALLY A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN TEN DOLLARS- TO THIS
EXISTING POOL OF PEOPLE THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE THAT WE KNOW- NEED
HELP. I'M NOT SURE IF THAT WAS
ADDRESS TESTER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THINK
FOR OUR PART I THINK WE- MIGHT
BE HELPFUL TO- EMPHASIZE WITH
RESPECT TO EXERCISES THE
RECIPIENTS BUT WE- CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THEIR VULNERABILITY
AND THIS INVESTMENT IS
IMPORTANT TO US- AS A AS A
MEANS OF INCREASING INCOME- FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. AND AS WE
JUST DISCUSSED IN THAT PRIOR
ITEMS- B. E. INVESTMENTS ON
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS SIDE
WILL ALSO BENEFIT MANY OF THESE
RECIPIENTS. IN ADDITION IN
RECENT YEARS WE HAVE EXPANDED
CALFRESH TWO SS I SS P.
RECIPIENTS TO ENSURE THAT%
THERE'S GREATER ACCESS TO
NUTRITION BENEFITS. SO THERE IS
SORT OF MORE THAN ONE THING
THAT IS A BENEFIT TO THIS
POPULATION AND THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO US- BUT WE
CERTAINLY. HEAR YOU AND
APPRECIATE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT INCOME LEVEL OVER ALL AND
THE CHALLENGES. THAT THESE
RECIPIENTS SPACE. THANK YOU AND
I THINK IMPORTANT. THAT THAT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION I THINK
HAS DONE A- HAS IS MADE HAS
MADE REDUCING POVERTY A REAL
FOCUS AND WE DO AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT. AND WE JUST
KNOW THAT THE NEED IS GREAT AND
SO- YEAH. WE WANT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE PUT TO HELP-
WHERE IT IS IT IS IT IS. MOST
LIKELY TO DO GOOD. OKAY SO WE
WILL TALK MORE AND THEN WILL OF
COURSE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE WHEN IT
WHEN IT COMES SO WE CAN WE CAN
BETTER ANALYZE. WHAT'S GOING
ON. OKAY ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. BUT
IF I CAN JUST SAY AGAIN EVERY
SINGLE TIME FOR THE RECORD.
RAISING THESE RATES ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE IN OUT OF HOME
PLACEMENTS SO THOSE BUSINESSES
CAN STAY OPEN- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT HOW HOW WE CAN CREATE A DA
VIDA SYSTEM. NOT NOT THAT I
WANT EVERYTHING TO GO FOR
PROFIT BUT IT IS JUST WHEN WE-
WHEN WE ATTACH DOLLARS TO
SOMETHING. WE SEE THE
PROLIFERATION WHEN WE DON'T
ATTACH DOLLARS TO SOMETHING. WE
SEE DECIMATION SO. WE GET TO
MAKE WE GET TO MAKE CHOICES.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. THANK
YOU- EGGMAN THAT ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE IS WITH RESPECT TO BE. IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM SO CRITICAL PERSONAL
CARE SERVICES. AND ALLOW OUR
ELDERS AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES TO REMAIN SAFELY
AT HOME- V. AT CRITICAL
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE H. EFFECT
PROGRAM IN THE NAY REVISION
INCLUDE. AND ELIMINATION OF THE
7% REDUCTION IN THE HOURS OF
SERVICES THAT- RECIPIENTS. ARE
AUTHORIZED TO RECEIVE THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REPEALING
THAT REDUCTION AND SUSPENSION-
WAS POSTED ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE'S WEBSITE TODAY. AND
THEN THE REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES- TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO MAINTAIN THE TRADITIONAL
STATE AND COUNTY SHARING RATIOS
WITH RESPECT TO. NON FEDERAL.
COSTS RELATED TO BARGAINING. IT
MAY RIVER INCLUDES AS WELL AND
INVESTMENT IN A PERMANENT AN ON
GOING BACK UP PROVIDER SYSTEM
TO ENSURE THAT WHEN THERE IS AN
IMMEDIATE HEALTH AND SAFETY
RISK RECIPIENTS RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE AND THERE IS A
GREATER SAFETY NET OF. UTILITY
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO MEET
THEIR NEEDS- THERE IS TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IN THE MAY
REVISION AS WELL TO- GOVERN OUR
COLLABORATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
IN AN EFFORT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH REQUIREMENTS
FROM CMS. RELATED TO ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION AND THE
VERIFICATION OF A PROVIDER'S
LOCATION WHEN THEY PROVIDE
SERVICES OUR INTENTION IS
CERTAINLY TO DO THAT IN THE
LEAST INTRUSIVE MANNER
POSSIBLE- BUT THERE ARE THINGS
THAT WE DO NEED TO- I UNDER
CURRENT GUIDANCE FROM. THE
ADVANCE- IT WOULD ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE NAY REVISION
INCLUDES AN INVESTMENT IN LONG
TERM CARE CAREER PATHWAYS- AND
ENSURING THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
SUPPORT PROVIDERS- AS THE- AS
THEY BOTH BECOME AYE AGES
THAT'S PROVIDERS AND CONTINUE
WITHIN THE PROFESSION AND
PERHAPS AND MOVE INTO HIGHER
LEVEL- POSITIONS WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY- AND WITH
THAT I WILL TURN IT OVER TO OUR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR DEBBIE THOMPSON
WHO CAN ANSWER SOME OF THE MORE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT ARE IN
YOUR AGENDA AS WELL. THANK YOU
HI GOOD AFTERNOON DEBBIE
THOMPSON ADULT PROGRAMS DEPUTY-
AT I WAS JUST GOING TO ASK
FOLLOW UP ON THE REMAINDER OF
THE QUESTIONS FOR YOU AND CHEN
DID ADDRESS QUESTION TO WHICH
IS THAT THE TRAILER BILL HAS
BEEN RELEASED REPEALING- THE
SEVEN PERCENT. AND THE SECOND
QUESTION AROUND THE SIXTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT- FINDING OF
THE NON FEDERAL SHARE THE AND
THAT CONTINUING. THE QUESTION
WAS WHETHER OR NOT THAT WAS AN
ONGOING PROPOSAL AND YES IT IS
AN ONGOING PROPOSAL- D. CAREER
PATHWAYS. THAT JANET WAS JUST.
MENTIONING IN TALKING ABOUT TO
SUPPORT R. I. HSS PROVIDERS.
WITH BOTH- ENHANCING IN GAINING
ADDITIONAL SKILLS TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE BEST SERVICES
POSSIBLE TO OUR I JUST LAST-
PROVIDERS AND ALSO. I'M GIVING
THEM ADDITIONAL SKILLS IF THEY-
SO CHOOSE TO MOVE INTO OTHER-
HEALTH CARE RELATED TYPE FEELS.
THE FUNDING IS GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING A NUMBER OF THINGS
IT WILL SUPPORT AB CONTRACTING
WITH A VENDOR TO PROVIDE- BACK
TRAINING. IT WILL INCLUDE STATE
BINS FOR- PROVIDERS AS THEY
COMPLETE OUR STEPS WITHIN THOSE
KINDS OF TRAINING ACTIVITIES.
IT WILL INCLUDE- IT TEER
DEVELOPMENT AND NAVIGATION THE
SUPPORT FOR THE PROVIDERS AS
THEY- ENHANCE THEIR SKILLS AND
LOOK AT OUR NEXT STEPS TO.
INCREASE THEIR THEIR THEIR
SKILLS AND TRAINING. IT WILL
ALSO INCLUDE OUTREACH. AND
COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE. COSTS TO
OUR HAVE THE CAL PROVIDE
NECESSARY- IT THROUGH THIS
PROCESS- TO OUR PROVIDERS AS
WELL THERE ALSO WILL BE SOME-
AUTOMATION COSTS TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE SYSTEM
SYSTEM NECESSARY TO TRACK-
FOLKS PROGRESS AS THEY DO
TRAININGS AS WELL AS ISSUES
STIPENDS- AS THE COMPLETE THOSE
ACTIVITIES. SO HOPEFULLY THAT
PROVIDES YOU A LITTLE MORE
INSIGHT INTO INTO THAT AREA.
AND THEN THE FINAL QUESTION WAS
IN REGARDS TO THE BACKUP
PROVIDER SYSTEM AND THE AND
WHETHER AND TO USE LIMITING IT
TO SEVERELY IMPAIRED
RECIPIENTS- I APOLOGIZE FOR ANY
CONFUSION IT IT IS NOT INTENDED
TO ONLY SERVES SERVICE SEVERELY
IMPAIRED CERTAINLY SEVERELY ARE
IMPAIRED ARE REFERENCED BECAUSE
WE ANTICIPATE. THAT THOSE WILL
BE THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL
MOST LIKELY BE IN A SITUATION
THAT WILL REQUIRE- THIS TYPE OF
BACKUP CARE BUT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS SITUATIONS WHERE
A PROVIDER NEEDS IMMEDIATE
SERVICES THEIR PROVIDER ISN'T
AVAILABLE AND WITHOUT THOSE
SERVICES THEY WOULD BE PUT IN A
SITUATION OF HAVING A HEALTH OR
SAFETY RISK. AND SO IT THAT IS
REALLY THAT CRITERIA FOR BEING
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THOSE
SERVICES HOPEFULLY THAT PROVIDE
SOME CLARIFICATION AND HOPE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ON ANY OF THESE AREAS.
AND JUST FOR THE RECORD I WILL
TELL I WILL SAY FOR DOCTOR PAN
WHO JUST REJOINED US ONE OF THE
ISSUES WAS THE 7% WERE THEY
GONNA VOTE REPEAL THAT AND THEY
JUST RELEASED TODAY THAT THAT
THAT IS ON THE LIST OF THINGS
TO BE REPEALED. OKAY DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. NONCONFORMITY
FINANCING FROM A GROUP OF THIS
TIME. AT THE PAR VALUE. THANK
YOU PROCEED WITH THE LIST OF
ANALYST OFFICE AGAIN- PER
DIRECTION FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE
OF JUST IDENTIFYING AREAS IN
WHICH THERE IS OR IS NOT
ALIGNMENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES- ONE AREA WHERE
THERE IS A LINE MEANT WITH UP
AND- AND ACTION THAT'S THE
SENATE TOOK LAST WEEK WAS NOT
ONLY TO ELIMINATES THE I JUST
CITED BY THE SUSPENSION AROUND
THE RESTORATION OF I. JUST A
SERVICE HOURS BUT THEN ALSO TO
REMOVE. AND STATUTORY LANGUAGE
THAT REFERENCES THE ORIGINAL
REDUCTION TO BEGIN WITH AND
AGAIN THE TRAILER BILL WAS JUST
POSTED TODAY AND WILL MAKE SURE
TO REVIEW IT THOROUGHLY BUT
JUST AN INITIAL WALK IT DOES
SEEM TO REPEAL THOSE KEY
SECTIONS I WILL PROVIDE MORE
UPDATES AS WE DO A MORE
THOROUGH REVIEW- ON THAT POINT-
BUT ONE ISSUE THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO RAISE TWO IN TERMS OF-
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION-
REVOLVES AROUND THE LONG TERM
CARE OF CAREER PATHWAYS
PROPOSAL. AND JUST FOR
ADDITIONAL CONTACTS AND THE
CONCEPT OF PROVIDING TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR I JUST AS
PROVIDERS AND STRENGTHENING
PROP POSSIBLE LINKS BETWEEN THE
I JUST WORK FORCE AND THE
BROADER HOME HEALTH WORKFORCE-
WAS RAISED- DURING THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS BUT THEN ALSO IS
BROADLY MENTIONED WITHIN THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING GET-
ITSELF. SO DEEPLY WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL MAY TRY
TO GET A BROADER CONCEPT I
THINK AT THIS TIME- WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE
INFORMATION TO REALLY ASSESS
THE MERITS OF THE PROPOSALS
ALONG THOSE LINES I'M
SPECIFICALLY WE DON'T KNOW- HOW
THE ADMINISTRATION CAME UP WITH
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DLLARS
BAKER HOW MANY I JUST AS
PROVIDERS WILL BE SERVED- WHAT
WHAT TO THE MIX OF TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND WHAT AND WHETHER
IT THAT'S GONNA- IS REALLY
ADDRESSING. THE PROBLEM OR
UNMET NEED WITHIN THE SYSTEM
AND AGAIN MORE BROADLY WHAT IS
THE PROBLEM MORE UNMET. NEED
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS TRYING TO
A DR AND HOW WHAT'S IT WILL IT.
BE MEASURED. AND AGAIN WE'RE
STILL IN THE EARLY STAGE OF
MAIN. SO WE WILL CAN TO WORK
WITH THE- AND I'M TO GET THESE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS I'M HOWEVER
IF THE NECESSARY LEVEL OF
DETAIL CANNOT BE PROVIDED
WITHIN THE SHORT BUDGET TIME
FRAME TO THE LEGISLATURE. WE
CAN ALSO HELP THE LEGISLATURE
THINK THROUGH POSSIBLE
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES IF IT
WERE INTERESTED IN DOING
SOMETHING IN THIS SPACE-
POSSIBLY COMING UP WITH A MORE
DEFINED. AND ACTIONABLE SHORT
TERM APPROACH- WHICH MAY NOT
REQUIRE AS MUCH FUNDING TO
BEGIN WITH BUT CAN AT LEAST BE
BUILT UPON PERHAPS NEXT YEAR OR
IN THE FUTURE YEARS AT THE
ADMINISTRATION SOLIDIFIES AND
COMPLETES. THAT MORE LONGER
TERM STRATEGY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AT IN MS JOHNSON CAN YOU
CAN SOMEBODY SPEAK TO THE
CAREER PATHWAYS AND WHAT WHAT
IS THE GOAL WHAT DO YOU HOPE TO
ACHIEVE IN AND WHERE. WILL
WHERE WILL FOLKS BE GOING IS
THE DEPARTMENT CAN OFFER SOME
TRAINING ARE THEYGONNA HAVE TO
OBTAIN IT. AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OR OR SOMEWHERE ELSE-
AND THEN I GUESS. THEN THE
PEOPLE'S THE PAY CORRESPOND
WITH THEIR THEIR NAME THE NEW
LEVEL OF TRAINING BUT BUT I
THINK THE OVERALL QUESTION IS.
HOW DOES THIS FIT INTO THE-
MASTER PLAN ON AGING AND WHAT
DO YOU HOPE TO ACHIEVE WITH
THAT. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WHAT WILL. THIS
ABSOLUTELY IS COMING OUT OF.
THOSE DISCUSSIONS IN THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AND THE OVERALL
CONCERN THAT AS WE ALL ARE VERY
AWARE THAT. POPULATION IS AGING
MORE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO NEED.
OUR DIRECT KINDS OF CARE- AS
WE- MOVE THROUGH THE NEXT
DECADE THAT WAS COULD THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO INCREASE AND SO
THERE IS. GOING TO BE A
TREMENDOUS DEMANDED THAT WE
ALREADY ARE STRUGGLING TO MEET.
BOTH WITHIN I'D JUST ASK AND
THE HEALTHCARE FIELD AND CARE-
FIELD. GENERALLY SO IT IS
INTENDED TO- YOU START
ADDRESSING THOSE NEEDS BY
STARTING TO. PROVIDE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ALREADY- IN THAT IT DOING
THAT AS- PART OF THEIR INCOME
WHETHER IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY DO FOR FAMILY MEMBERS OR
WHETHER IT'S SOMETHING THEY DO
AS THEIR PRIMARY OCCUPATION.
THEY ARE DOING THAT CARE GIVING
AND- AND THAT IS A GOOD PLACE
TO START IN DOING OUTREACH TO
TRY AND OFFER OPPORTUNITIES. TO
GROW SKILLS AND TO MOVE INTO
THAT FIELD ONE THING THAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THE ICE THOSE
PROGRAMS IS THAT MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE WITH MORE- BUT
CHALLENGING DISABILITIES ARE
ABLE NOW TO BE IN THEIR HOMES
AND BE SERVED IN THAT WAY BUT
IN ORDER TO DO THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE SKILL
LEVELS. TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT TYPE OF CARE AND SO GIVING
OPPORTUNITIES TO. GET PEOPLE
TRAINING AND EXPAND THEIR
SKILLS IS CRITICAL TO MEETING
THAT WORK FORCE DEMAND AND
THAT'S THE INTENT HERE WE WOULD
INTEND TO HAVE A VENDOR THAT
WOULD PROVIDE TO CONTRACT WITH
THE VENDORS TO PROVIDE- THE
TYPE OF THE TRAINING WHAT THAT
EXACTLY IS GOING TO LOOK BACK.
LOOK LIKE IS STILL IN
DEVELOPMENT BUT CERTAINLY- THAT
WOULD BE OFFERING BOTH- VIRTUAL
AS WELL AS IN PERSON TRAINING
WE KNOW FROM- PAST. THE AROUND
PROVIDING TRAINING THAT MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING IN HOME
CARE IT'S DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
GET OUT BECAUSE THERE THAN
LEAVING THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
THEY CARE FOR. AND SO BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT RIGHT THAT KIND
OF TRAINING REMOTELY IS
CERTAINLY AN AREA THAT WE'RE
EXPLORING AND INTEND TO PURSUE
WITH HOW WE HOW WE WILL
APPROACH THIS. WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING WITH OUR HOW IT WORKS-
FOLKS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT AND-
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN OFFERING TO THOSE
FOLKS THAT THEY SERVE. AND
APPROACHES THAT WE FEEL LIKE
COULD ALSO BENEFIT- ARE
PROVIDERS IN IN. IN TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT SOME OF
THAT DIRECTION AND WHEN IT'S
COMING OUT OF. OKAY M. THE VERY
VERY NEEDED ALL OF IT OF
COURSE- THANK I THINK IT JUST
ALWAYS BEARS MENTIONING THAT
OUR CHILD CARE WORKERS IN OUR
SENIOR CARE WORKERS ARE SOME OF
THE LOWEST PAID IN OUR WORK
FORCE WHICH DOESN'T SAY GOOD
THINGS ABOUT US. BLACK PANTS.
THANK YOU- AND- AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION-
FINALLY ADDRESSING THE
SUSPENSION- AND- IT IS A SAID.
HAVING BEEN THROUGH SOME TOUGH
BUDGET TIMES RECOGNIZE THAT
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO MAKE HARD
DECISIONS BUT WE SHOULD PUT
AUTOMATIC CUTS AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- THE
MINISTRATION THE GOVERNOR'S.
RECOGNITION THAT IN THIS
PROPOSAL AND ALSO THE SIXTY
FIVE. THIRTY FIVE COUNTY
SHARING RATIO- BECAUSE NOT ONLY
IS THAT- PLATE NOT REVERSING
THAT CHANGING THAT RATIO- THAT
NOT ONLY DOES THAT. THE
DECREASE DEPRESSION HSS. THOSE
FUNDS BECAUSE NINE ONE
REALIGNMENT ALSO FLOW DOWN TO
BOTH MENTAL HEALTH AND- PUBLIC
HEALTH TWO MAJOR PRIORITIES I
KNOW AS WELL FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS JUST
EARLIER THIS HEARING AS WELL.
SO AGAIN REALLY IMPORTANT AND
VITIATE THE ACTION BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. AT THE WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT- CERTAINLY
HOPING THAT WE CAN FIND SOME
SOLUTIONS TO ENSURE THAT THERE
ARE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS WITH EVERY COUNTY
AND THAT- DATE THAT THOSE DON'T
GET DRAGGED OUT- SO BUT- AGAIN
HOPE LOOK LOOKING AT LOOKING TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN. RESOLVE THAT ISSUE AS WELL
BUT- YEAH AND FREESHEET- THESE
VERY IMPORTANT STEPS THAT I
KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR A VERY LONG TIME. IN
THE SUB COMMITTEE- AND- YEP WE
SHOULD. THE GOVERNOR PUTTING
THIS FOR THANKS. THANK YOU MUCH
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE SIX.
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES.
DID YOU FELT AGAIN CENTURY I
WITH THE DEPARTMENT- THAT THERE
ARE NUMBER OF THE BEST THINGS
THAT I WILL M. HIGHLIGHT HERE
FOR YOU AND THEN I AM I WILL
INVITE OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR INTO
SPORTS TO SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
MORE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT
WERE IN YOUR AGENDA. SO FOR THE
ITEMS I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT IN
THE MAY REVISION THAT ARE KEY
INVESTMENTS IN THE SAFETY AND
WELL BEING OF CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE AND THOSE
WERE AT RISK OF ABUSE OR
NEGLECT- I'D LIKE TO BEGIN WITH
A HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS THE
THREE YEAR BLOCK GRANTS. TO
SUPPORT COUNTIES IN THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION OF PREVENTION-
UNDER THAT FAMILIES FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT WHICH
USUALLY ALLOWS OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FEDERAL. FUNDING FOR
PREVENTION PURPOSES. YOU NEED
TO THERE ARE FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
FOSTER YOUTH WITH A CUTE AND
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS. INCLUDING
YOUR TO RETURN FROM OUT OF
STATE GROUP HOME PLACEMENTS- IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THERE
IS ALSO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH SUPPORTS THE ON GOING
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT NEEDS
ASSESSMENT TOOL OR WHAT WE
OFTEN REFER TO AS CANS. AND
ALONG WITH SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS RELATED TO THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM AND
RECONCILIATION RELATED TO X.
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENDITURES AND
THE COST SHARING BETWEEN THE
STATE AND COUNTIES-
ADDITIONALLY I WOULD VIOLATE
THAT WE HAVE INCLUDING FUNDING
TO CONTINUE ALLOWING FOR
PLACEMENT PRIOR TO APPROVAL. TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAD IN SUPPORT
AND URGENCY SUPPORT FOR CARE
GIVERS. AND FINALLY I WOULD
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE HAVE
INVESTED- OR PROPOSED TO INVEST
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING AVAILABLE OVER
THREE YEARS. TO PROVIDE
STIPENDS AND SCHOLARSHIPS TO.
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS WHO
ARE PURSUING THEIR MASTERS IN
SOCIAL WORK DEGREES YOU'RE
PRACTICING PUBLIC CHILD
WELFARE. WITH THAT I WILL HAND
IT TO OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
INTEREST. WELCOME A SHORT SAID
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR UP THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON- YOU SHORT
BE DIRECTOR OF THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES DIVISION AFTER
THE FLUTE. QUESTION FROM THE
AGENDA THERE WERE A COUPLE
RELATED TO THE PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS THE COMPLEX NEEDS AND
YOU TO ENABLE THEM TO BE
SUPPORTED. BUT IN CALIFORNIA
THE QUESTION FOR WHETHER THE
FUNDING IS INTENDED TO BE ONE
TIME OUR ON GOING AND WHETHER
WE ARE PLANNING TO REVIEW THE
CASE. THANK YOU THAT WERE
PLACED OUT OF STATE CONFORM.
HOW THAT PROPOSED SPENDING IS
UTILIZED. TOTAL INCLUDED A
COMPANY OF ONE TIME YEAH I'M
GOING FUND AND ARE INVOLVED. IN
THE IN THE YEAH PROPER THING.
I'M INCOME THE INITIAL INTERNAL
ANALYSIS THAT WE DID REGARDING
THE CIRCUMSTANCES. OF THE YEARS
THAT WERE RETURNED TO
CALIFORNIA. HAVE ANY FORM THE
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS BOTH THAT
DEVELOPMENT EXPANSION AND
SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS WHICH WILL
BE ACCOMPLISHED IN THE ONE TIME
FUNDING. AS WELL AS THE NEED
FOR THE ON GOING FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE INTENT THAT NEED.
TO ADD YOUR CALL COMPLEXITY. IT
WOULD ALSO. ABOUT THE- RELATED
TO FUNDING TO SUPPORT PLACEMENT
PRIOR TO A FAMILY APPROVAL AT
THE RESORT THE ONLY. THE
QUESTION POSED WAS WHETHER THE
FUNDING ONLY FOR BUDGET YEAR
AND THAT IS CORRECT. THE
PROPOSAL IS TO ALLOW THE
FUNDING TO CONTINUE FOR A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS FOR
GOOD CAUSE TO EXPAND UP TO
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
DAYS FOR BUDGET YEAR AND THEN
BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
EMERGENCY CARE GIVER FUNDING
WOULD BE LIMITED TO NINETY
DAYS. I BELIEVE THOSE ARE THE
ONLY QUESTION POSED IN THE
AGENDA HAPPY TO ANSWER
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. OR
PROVIDE FURTHER CLARIFICATION.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF.
ANYTHING STRATIS DOESN'T FOR
HIS PART FINANCE ADDED YET
AGAIN NOTICED A COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME BUT OPENED- RESPONDED
ANY QUESTIONS SHORT EARLIER.
THANK YOU ANGELES SHORT WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- BUT THE START AUSTIN
MILLER TO WHAT MY- LA-
COLLEAGUES HAVE NOTED WITH
PREVIOUS ITEMS WERE CONTINUING
TO REVIEW- THE DETAIL PROPOSAL
INFORMATION- FOR THE VARIOUS
MAYOR VISION PROPOSALS. AND WE
WELL- REFINER COMMENTS AND
PROVIDE ANY ADDITONAL GUIDANCE
THE LEGISLATURE OVER THE COMING
DAYS AND WEEKS BUT FOR TODAY
THERE ARE- A FEW POINTS WE
WANTED TO JUST FLAG FOR THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S ATTENTION- IN
PARTICULAR GIVEN LINKAGES TO
ISSUES THAT THE SUB COMMITTEE
HAS DISCUSSED DURING PREVIOUS
HEARINGS. ALSO FOR THE MAYOR
VISON PROPOSES- A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO ASSIST TOWN TO THE
DEVELOPING PREVENTION SERVICES
IN LINE WITH AFFECT YES- CHIEF
DEPUTY. DIRECTOR TRANSPORT TO
THIS PROPOSAL. AND AT THE TIME
OF THE GENERATOR BY KNOWS LEVEL
AND- WOULD PROPOSE FOR THE- IN
OUR OFFICE HAD FLAG THIS IS AN
AREA FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER PROVIDING FUNDING FOR
COUNTIES TO HELP INSURE- BUT
ALL ELIGIBLE YOUTH AND
FAMILIES. ACROSS THE STATE
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS
PREVENTION SERVICES. AND WHILE
WE HAVE NOT YET BEEN ABLE TO
REVIEW ALL THE DETAILS OF THIS
PROPOSAL IT DOES SEEM TO MAKE
PROGRESS WITH THIS
RECOMMENDATION- AND THIS IS
ALSO AN ISSUE THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE DISCUSSED AT LAST
WEEK'S HEARING. SECOND MAYOR
VISION CONTINUES SOME
SIGNIFICANT AUGMENTATION.
RELATED TO PANDEMIC RESPONSE
WITHIN CHILD WELFARE. INCLUDING
FUNDING FOR THINGS SUCH AS
FLEXIBILITY AS AN EXPANSION FOR
NON MINOR DEPENDENTS AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH- AS WELL AS
SUPPORT FOR FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS TECHNOLOGY HOTLINE FOR
YOUTH AND FAMILIES AND MORE.
BUT ONE NOTE WE WOULD MAKE IS
THAT- EIGHT GAP DOES REMAIN- IN
TERMS OF FINDING IT- FOR.
RESOURCE FAMILIES S. T. R. T.
P. AND- LANCASTER TERRORISTS IN
GENERAL. WE RESERVE THE TIME OF
THE JANUARY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THAT OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC THESE CAREGIVERS AND
FAMILIES. HAVE BEEN FACING
INCREASED COST PRESSURES SUCH
AS FOR FOOD AND HAVE BEEN
NAVIGATING THE VARIOUS
CHALLENGES A STAY AT HOME
ORDERS- FOR EXAMPLE CHALLENGES
AROUND VIRTUAL LEARNING. AND
POTENTIALLY LACK OF ACCESS TO
CHILD CARE. AND THEREFORE WE
CONTINUE TO FLAG THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE FOR- OR OTHER DIRECT
ASSISTANCE. TO ALL FOSTER CARE
PROVIDERS AS PART OF THE
STATE'S OVERALL COOK AT
NINETEEN FISCAL RELIEF. EFFORTS
WITHIN CHILD WELFARE- THE THIRD
REGARDING THE PROPOSED- TO
ASSIST COUNTIES OF DEVELOPING
AND IMPLEMENTING SPECIALIZED
PLACEMENT OPTIONS AND SERVICES
FOR USE WITH COMPLEX CARE NEEDS-
THAT WILL BE TAKING A LOOK A
CLOSER LOOK AT THIS PROPOSAL IN
THE COMING DAYS. WE JUST WANT
TO FLY GET GIVEN UNDER SUB
COMMITTEE HAS DISCUSSED IN THE
PAST THE POTENTIAL NEED FOR
ONGOING SUPPORT FOR YOUTH
RETURNING FROM OUT OF STATE-
AND BROADER QUESTIONS AROUND
THE USE OF OUT OF STATE
CONGREGATE CARE PLACEMENTS-
MORE BROADLY GOING FORWARD. AT
THE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF AS WE LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE PROPOSAL. AND
LASTLY- JUST WANTED TO FLAG
THAT- THE MAYOR VISION AND THAT
DOES- REMOVE SUSPENSION
LANGUAGE FOR CHILD WELFARE
PROGRAMS THAT HAD BEEN INCLUDED
AT THE TIME OF THE- JANUARY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND OTHER
SUB COMMITTEE TOOK ACTION LAST
WEEK VOTING TO ELIMINATE ALL
PROGRAM SUSPENSION SO MAYOR
VISION IS IN ALIGNMENT- WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON THAT POINT-
THAT'S ALL I HAVE AT THE MOMENT
BUT HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I WOULD I WOULD AGREE WITH
THE ISSUE OF- FUNDING FOLLOWING
THAT THE CHILD AND IF FIVE OUT
OF ONE PLACEMENTS NEED
SOMETHING EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT A
FAMILY PROVIDER. IT SEEMS TO
MAKE SENSE TO BE ABLE TO.
PROVIDE FOR THAT THAT CHILD IN
THAT HOME AS WELL AS- AS
ANOTHER MEANS OF STABILIZING
THAT PLACEMENT. BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THE MORE PLACEMENTS THE
HIGHER RISK THAT KIDS ARE UNDER
WHEN THEY'RE IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM- SO THAT THAT SEEMS TO
MAKE THEM GOOD SENSE- AND- ARE
WE ARE WE GOING TO BE SURE THAT
WHEN WE START ACCEPTING OUR
KIDS BACK. OF THIS TO THE
DEPARTMENT THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BE PREPARED- TO HAVE ALL OF
THEIR NEEDS MET- AND
ADDITIONALLY AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THERE'S NOTHING THAT WOULD
PREVENT US FROM SENDING KIDS
OUT OF STATE AGAIN. DO WE NEED
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
PROHIBIT US. FROM SENDING KIDS
OUT OF STATE- AND THEREBY
REALLY ENSURING THAT THE STATE
BE ABLE TO STEP UP. OR NOT
THAT'S THE MYSTERY AMISSAH
SHORTS. TRANSACTION IN TERMS OF
ARE WE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE THEM WHEAT RETURNING
FUNDED IN THIRTY THREE YEARS
THAT WILL REQUIRE MORE PLACE
OUT OF STATE TO CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE- WHAT WE RETURNED OF HIS
TO MANY TO. PLACEMENT RELATIVES
TEST YOUR TO KEEP PEACE AND THE
FOSTER FAMILY HOMES- WE PROVIDE
A VERY INTENSIVE. TA IN ORDER
TO DEVELOP AN INNOVATIVE MODELS
AND FELL AGAIN THAT PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE BEFORE YOU IT SORT
OF BASED ON ON WHAT WAS
SUCCESSFUL AND WHAT'S NEEDED TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND- IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE TO THIRTEEN I THE
NEEDS OF YOUR CURFEW COMPLEX
GAME BUT IN CALIFORNIA. AND ARE
PROPOSAL DOES NOTINCLUDE A
MORATORIUM ON PLACES BUT PLATE
OUT OF STATE- BUT WE DO THINK
THAT THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN TO
ALLOW THEM TO BE FAIR.
SUCCESSFULLY WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
OKAY SO THEY HAVE BEEN THERE
THE KIDS ARE SUCCESS AND WE
HAVE A VALUE. AT OUR LOW AT AT
ALL OF THIS HOW HOW WE'RE
MEASURING SUCCESS IT IS STABLE
PLACEMENT. WHAT CONTINUING TO
MONITOR THIS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS FOR LOOKING AT IT- ON A
WEEKLY BASIS TO CONTINUE TO
POST INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE
THE PLACEMENT BAR OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND
THE TECHNICAL. I'M WITH THE
COUNTY YOU CAN TROUBLESHOOT
ISSUES AS THEY ARISE HELLO. AND
EVEN THOUGH THE YOU'D HAVE
RETURNED TO CALIFORNIA WE
CONTINUE TO BE VERY INTENSELY
INVOLVED WITH MAKING SURE- THAT
WE KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE DRAFTING
NEEDS IF THEY ARE. OKAY THANK
YOU AND THEN MY FINAL QUESTION
IS. AROUND THE EXTENSION. OR
FOR BEING ABLE TO DO FAMILY
PAYMENTS FOR CARE GIVERS- BUT
WE'RE STILL NOT HITTING THAT
NINETY DAY AND IT'S BEEN A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS DO WE NEED
TO CHANGE THE CRITERIA OR WE'RE
GONNA HIRE MORE STAFF OR HOW WE
CAN MAKE. MAKE SURE THAT WE
MEET THAT. AT NINETY DAY ED.
THE DEADLINE. ASSEMBLY FOR THE
PANDEMIC- THE TIME ONE HAD COME
DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY FROM THE
BEGINNING EVERY FIRST DALY
APPROVAL AND QUARTER FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN AVERAGES WERE DOWN TO
A HUNDRED AND EIGHT DAYS BUT
THEN THEY FOUND OUT THAT THE
RESULT OF THAT HAND THAT MIGHT
AND THEN QUARTER FOR TWENTY
TWENTY WITHOUT A HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE DAYS BUT WE DO THINK THAT
WE WERE IN A VERY POSITIVE
TRAJECTORY TO GET TO THAT
NINETY DAY TIMELINE WE JUST
HADN'T HAD. A BIT OF A PICK UP
WITH THAT AND I'M MAKING A LOT
OF THE BACKLOG THAT RESULTED AT
THEIR FEET DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
SAID WE DO THINK THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO GET THE TIMELINE BACK
DOWN- BUT OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT. YEAR AS WE RETURN-
AND A STEP ISSUE HER. HEAVY
REQUESTED MORE SO. AND THAT THE
PART TO BE ABLE TO MEET THAT
BACKLOG. THEY'RE ALREADY GOING
DOWN AND IT'S REALLY AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL IN TERMS THAT THAT
REFER FAMILY APPROVAL BY DONE-
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL BUT- YOU
KNOW I THINK THE BACKLOG THAT
RESULTED WAS MORE IN TERMS OF.
YOU KNOW DELAYS BECAUSE
EVERYTHING WAS MOVED INTO A
VIRTUAL WORLD AND THERE WERE
SOME DELAYS IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT I'M INSPECTION.
THANKS TO HELP- BUT BUT THE
BACKLOG THAT TIME LINES ARE
ALREADY COMING BACK DOWN- I
DON'T HAVE THE CURRENT DATA
RIGHT. IN FRONT OF ME BUT I CAN
GET THAT FOR YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
IMMIGRANT AND INTEGRATION
SERVICES. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR- MY NAME IS
MARCELLO RUIZ AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
EQUITY- WITH CDSS WHICH
INCLUDES THE IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION BRANCH- A PROVIDE A
VERY BRIEF AT THE OF THE
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS AND THEN
OF COURSE LEAVE TIME FOR. FOR
QUESTIONS- SO THE PROPOSED
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION
INVESTMENT BUILT ON THE STATE'S
SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS OF
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIANS THROUGH
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES AND
ALSO INTEGRATION SERVICES THAT
INCLUDE NAVIGATION KEYS
MANAGEMENT- FOR IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES- THE PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES FUNDING TO SUPPORT
MIGRANT ARRIVALS AT THE BORDER
AS WELL AS CRITICAL SERVICES
FOR IMMIGRANTS DURING TIMES. OF
NEED BY AUGMENTING THE RAPID
RESPONSE FUNDS AS YOU KNOW THAT
DEPARTMENT ADMINISTERS FUNDING
FOR IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES
AND SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN WE
HAVE FUNDED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE THOSE
LEGAL SERVICES THROUGHOUT.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO
INDIVIDUALS CAN REGULARIZE
THEIR STATUS WHICH WE ALL KNOW
IS REALLY CRITICAL TO ECONOMIC
MOBILITY AND OVERALL WELL BEING
OF INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
FAMILIES- THE FIRST PROPOSAL
SPEAK TO IS THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR
DACA AND NATURALIZATION FILING
FEES. A COMPONENT OF THE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAM HAS BEEN TO SUPPORT
FILING FEES FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE APPLYING FOR DACA AS THERE
IS NO- AVAILABILITY TO WAIVE
THOSE FEES THE USCIS IS NOT
PROVIDE THAT PROCESS SINCE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT HUSBANDS PROVIDING
THAT SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE
SERVED OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH THOSE FILING
FEES THIS PROPOSAL WILL SEEK TO
EXPAND THAT SERVICE TO ALSO
INCLUDE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
SEEKING TO NATURALIZE THEIR
STATUS. THE SECOND PROPOSAL IS
IN HOGG. OF THE- FOR I COME
MINORS AS WE ALL KNOW WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A SURGE IN
ARRIVALS OF UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS AND MANY OF THOSE ABOUT
IT ABOUT 90% OF THE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS WHO COME
INTO THE UNITED STATES ARE
ULTIMATELY PLACED IN. IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
SERVICES FOR UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS WERE SEEKING TO AUGMENT
THE LEGAL SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. AS WELL AS SERVICES
THROUGH A PROGRAM NAMED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR USE THAT
INCLUDES CASE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM NAVIGATION USE
MENTORING AND COACHING AND
FAMILY SUPPORT- FAMILY SUPPORTS
WITH THE GOALS OF SUPPORTING
HEALTHY AND RESPONSIVE
RELATIONSHIPS FOR THE YOUTH AND
THEIR FAMILIES. HELP BUILD USE
CORE SKILLS AS WELL AS
CONNECTING THE USE AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO COMMUNITY
RESOURCES- THE LAST TWO
COMPONENTS OF THE PROPOSAL ARE
IN EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION- TO PROVIDE
SHELTERING SERVICES TO THE
ARRIVING. MIGRANTS AS AS AS YOU
WELL KNOW WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN MIGRANT ARRIVALS AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER ACROSS
THREE COUNTIES IMPERIAL
RIVERSIDE AND SAN DIEGO AND
THERE HAS BEEN AN EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR- ALLOCATION THREE TRIO
FUNDS. TO THE SUPPORT- RESPITE
SHELTERS FOR MIGRANTS WHO ARE
MAINLY MOVING ON AND TO INSURE
THAT WE ARE RESPONDING IN AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO- INSURE THE
SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF THE
ARRIVING MIGRANTS BUT ALSO THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY
PARTICULARLY WITH ALL OF THE
CONCERNS SURROUNDING CO BID.
AND THEN FINALLY- THAT BUDGET
ALSO PROPOSES A ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION FOR
THE RAPID RESPONSE FUND THIS.
FUND IS USED TO PER RIDE AS-
CRITIC SERVICE DURING TIMES OF
NEED AND IN THE PAST HAS BEEN
USED TO PROVIDE SUPPORT DURING
AND AFTER WILDFIRES- THE
DISASTER RELIEF ASSISTANCE FOR
IMMIGRANTS WAS SUPPORTED IN
PART WITH THIS FUND- AS
ECONOMIC RELIEF FOR- FOR COVE
IT AND HAS ALSO BEEN USED TO
SUPPORT THE BORDER RESPONSE
IT'S REALLY A FUND THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT.
IMMIGRANTS AND RECOGNITION THAT
MANY ARE EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL
SERVICES THAT ARE NECESSARY
DURING THOSE CRITICAL TIMES OF
NEED- SO WITH THAT I WILL- A
CLATTER I'M GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NANKANA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME
MISSPELLED. HELLO WITH L. A. L.
NOTING THAT WILL BE WOKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
UNDERSTAND REALLY THAT THE
NETWORK AND THE AND THE
CAPACITY TO GET THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS OUT AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE UNDERSTAND THE ESTIMATE-
THAT IS ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR-
ALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THEN- AND I WOULD CONCUR THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
THAT I THINK IS VERY TIMELY IN
ITS AND RIGHT IN FRONT OF US
RIGHT NOW AND- WE NEED TO DEAL
WITH IT BUT WE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THE- RESOURCES ARE-
ARE WELL SPENT. WITH GOOD WITH
GOOD CHECKS AND BALANCES SO
WE'LL BE TALKING A LOT MORE
ABOUT THIS MOVING FORWARD AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK-
OKAY NOW WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT SECTION WHICH-
IS. CHILD CARE. THANK YOU SIR-
AND I WILL KEEP A STOCK FOR THE
CHILD CARE ITEM GENTRAN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ONE MORE TIME
AND- WITH RESPECT TO CHILD CARE
AND WE HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
FUNDING WITHIN THE MAY REVISION
IN INVESTMENT. IN RELIEF FOR
THE WORK FORCE WHICH WILL TALK
ABOUT IN THE NEXT AGENDA ITEM.
AS WELL AS THOSE INVESTMENTS TO
IMPROVE ACCESS AND TO
STRENGTHEN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
MAKE SOME SYSTEMS IMPROVEMENTS-
FEDERAL FUNDING IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE INSTRUMENTAL IN
PROVIDING FOR THE RECOVERY AND
STABILITY OF. THE WORK FORCE
AND THE FAMILIES. AND THE
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE THEM- THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE
THROUGH THESE PROPOSALS AND IN
OUR IN OUR WORK I HAD AND TO
BUILD A KEY RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE MASTER. I DON'T CARE
SYSTEM. AND AS WE DISCUSSED IN
PRIOR HEARINGS WE ARE FULLY
COMMITTED TO A SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION OF CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS FROM CD ETS EDS ASKED.
WHICH WILL BE EFFECTIVE JULY
ONE IS AROUND THE CORNER BEFORE
WE KNOW IT- SO WITH RESPECT TO
THE MAY REVISION ONE OF THE-MOST SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
IT'S REALLY HISTORIC. IN
PROPOSING TO ADD MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILD CARE
SLOTS. TO THE SUBSIDIZED CHILD
CARE SYSTEM- THOSE SLOTS AT
QUITE A FEW OF THEM ARE IN THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
WITH ABOUT YOUR PROGRAM AND
SOME ARE ALSO PROVIDEDIN THE
GENERAL CHILD CARE PROGRAM.
WHICH ALLOWS US TO DO A LITTLE
BIT MORE TARGETING AND IN
PARTICULAR TO INVEST SOME IN-
ACCESS FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS
WHICH IS DEEPLY NEEDED IN THE
FIELD. IN ADDITION TO THE SLOTS-
DO FOR IN. IN- IN. AND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS. WE ALSO PROPOSED
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDS TO INVEST IN LOCAL
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL AGENCIES.
SIX MILLION DOLLARS WHICH WILL
MODERNIZE OUR PAYMENT SYSTEM
AND ENSURE THAT WE CAN UTILIZE
DIRECT DEPOSIT PAYMENTS FOR
CONTRACTORS. FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO- SUPPORT BE- IN
PLANNING AND INITIAL
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE DESIGN
OF A CHILD CARE DATA SYSTEM TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF FAMILIES AND
THE WORK FORCE. TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH WILL PRESERVE
FLEXIBILITY BACK CONTRACTORS
CURRENTLY HAVE TO TRANSFER
FUNDS BETWEEN GENERAL CHILD
CARE IN STATE SCHOOL PROGRAM AS
A LOAN. AND TO ALLOW FOR THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO BE RECONCILED ON
THE BACK AND BY THE STATE. AND
DIDN'T TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
A MULTI YEAR EFFORT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO EXAMINE AND STRNGTH AND OUR
QUALITY SUPPORT AND SYSTEM-
YOUR AGENDA ASKS ABOUT THE MIX
THE FUNDING FOR CHILD CARE
SLOTS. AND THE CHILD CARE SLOTS
THAT ARE FUNDED WITH FEDERAL
FUNDING FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDING
UNDER ARAFAT. AND THAT IS AB
THE LARGEST AMOUNTS AND THEN
THERE IS ADDITIONALLY- SOME
GENERAL FUND AND SOME
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR FUNDING.
THE NTENTION IS FOR THE SLOT
TO BE I'M GOING WITHOUT YOUR-
SOURCES STILL TO BE DETERMINED-
AND I THINK WITH THAT I WILL-
ALLOW MY COLLEAGUES JUMP INTO
SELINA CHOW WILL ANSWER- SO
ADDITIONAL. THAT WERE IN THE
AND BACK. THANK YOU VERY.
MISTER AGAINST OUR CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE ENGENDERING A
QUESTION REGARDING THE DIRECT
DEPOSIT AND WHEN THAT WOULD
START WE ARE INTERESTED. OUR
STAR TO TURN AND RIGHT TWENTY
TWO AND THE SORT OF OUR TIME
THE DEPARTMENT TO CONTACT WITH
THE VENDOR I. HE DIDN'T RESPOND.
FROM AND OTHER REQUIRE. AS WELL
COURTNEY WITH SCO TO OPERATE.
ANOTHER POSITS. ARE WE ARE
CLEANING TO- IN REBEKAH.
COMMUNITY TO. THE TERM WHAT
KIND- ONE OPTED THE DIRECT
ABOUT WOULD ALLOW TIME TO DO
THAT. GEISHAS WELL. AND IN THE
CHUNKIER DID SYSTEM I SEE THAT
YOU HAVE A ON. HOW THE SYSTEM
WILL LINE THE SHOW CARE DATE
EFFORTS SEEK. WOULD BE THE
FOLKS. THAT WOULD. PROVIDE A
FUTURE. FOR INTERFACING WITH
THE OTHER SYSTEM SUCH AS HE
SAID CRADLED CAREER. ON SO THIS
WAY IT GIVE US NOW TO.
EVENTUALLY IN DATA OTHER
SYSTEMS FOR CALM. DATING AND
ANALYSIS. THIS IS CURRENTLY THE
GROUNDWORK. FUTURE UP. AND YOUR
ENGAGING WITH C. YEAR PROCESS
WHILE. RIGHT TERMS OF THE
FUNCTION. THIS IS A DAY SYSTEM
VISION BACK. WE PROPOSING THAT
OF BECOME TWO THINGS FOR ONE
AND CENTRAL ALL THE ACROSS THE
PROGRAMS- INTO A UNITS.
MANAGEMENT WOULD STAY OVER. FOR
A TOOL THAT WOULD HELP MANAGE
SCHEDULING CAPACITY IN WOMAN'S
ATTENDANCE SHEETS INVOICES ALL
OF THOSE THINGS THAT NOT ALL
PROVIDERS CURRENTLY HAVE BEEN
AUTOMATED TOOL TO MANAGE SO
IT'S REALLY TO FALL AND- HAVING
THE FUNCTIONALITY TO ALLOW FOR
DATA COLLECTION OF WHAT ITS
CURRENT REQUIRE CURRENTLY
REQUIRED AS WELL AS THIS TYPE
OF EXTENSION WE ALSO ENVISION
THAT THIS OUR SYSTEM WOULD
ALLOW FOR. MANAGING AS WELL.
AND THEN. REGARDING COSTS THE
STUDENT VISION- WILL BE
INFORMED BY AN EXTENSIVE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
AS WELL AS PLANNING SO IT IS
SUBJECT. STATES I. T. PROJECT
APPROVAL PROCESS AND THAT'S
REQUIREMENTS- AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE THINKING IT IS GOING TO
BE. AN EIGHTEEN MONTH PROCESS
TO GET THROUGH. ALL THAT
PLANNING AND PROCUREMENT- IT IS
EIGHT A DOCTOR WILL SCALABLE
SOLUTIONS SO THAT DIFFERENCE IN
COST WITH HER NEARLY DRIVEN BY
THE VOLUME OF USER LICENSES
THAT WE WOULD NEED FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTION. THERE IS-
I REQUEST THAT AS WE GET
THROUGH THE APPROVAL PROCESS
WOULD HAVE PROVISIONAL
AUTHORITY FOR ANOTHER FOUR
MILLION TO EXPAND. THE USER
LICENSES. AND SO WE DON'T A
COMPLETE ESTIMATE OF COSTS OF
THIS TIME BUT IT IS- IN THE
MAIL OF. THE TENDS NOT AS
OPPOSED TO HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
THAT WE WOULD SEE WITH
TRADITIONAL MORE COMPLEX.
SYSTEMS THAT REQUIRE A LOT OF
CUSTOMISATION AND HERE WE HAVE-
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS MORE OF
A OFF THE SHELVES AT THE
SOLUTION. IS A MUCH LOWER COST.
AND THEN WHAT AND BELIEVE WE'RE
NOT QUITE URE ON. YEAH HOW
ABOUT TIMELINE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION I HEARD EIGHTEEN
MONTHS FOR. THE PROCESS TO GET
A VENDOR AND POTENTIALLY THAT
DESIGN. HOW ABOUT FOR
IMPLEMENTATION TO HAVE A TIME
LINE FOR THAT. RIGHT SO- ONCE
WE GET THROUGH THE PROCUREMENT
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD BE
RELATIVELY QUICK AND IT'S
REALLY JUST A MATTER OF. HOW
WHY DO WE WANT TO. EXTEND THAT
FOR THAT THE- DIFFERENT
LICENSES AND USERS ONCE IT. USE
THE SYSTEM. SO WE CAN FIND OUT
A LITTLE MORE BUT IT WILL BE
VERY MUCH INFORMED BY. THE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS.
OKAY GOD DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
AFTERNOON CARLOS A LETTER AT
THE PERMANENT FINANCE THING
FURTHER TO ADD- LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE DISCUSSIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CORTES.
AFTERNOON SERVER TED WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
WE DO HAVE A FEW COMMENTS AS
FAR UNDERSTANDING- OF THE
CHANNEL CARE ME REVISION
PACKAGE- AND WE KNOW THAT OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS PACKAGE
MAY OF ALL AS BUDGET DOCUMENTS
CONTINUE TO BECOME AVAILABLE
FOR OUR REVIEW. FOR FIRST
COMMENT IS WITH ABOUT THE ARC
OF FUNDED SLOTS THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN FUNDED SPOT SO MOST
OF THE ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SLOTS ABOUT SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
OF THOSE ARE FUNDED. WITH A ONE
TIME. AND WHICH WE ESTIMATE ON
THE NUMBER OF SLOTS THAT THESE
ARE THE FUNDS LASSEN. TWENTY
JUNE THREE. ONLY RECOMMEND ALL
TO APPROACH STAFFERS STEPHENS
THE WORST TEMPORARY SLOTS BUT
OVER A LONGER PERIOD. SO FIRST
WE RECOMMEND EXTENDING THE
TEMPORARY SLOTS THAT WERE
FUNDED OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PANDEMIC- THESE ARE CURRENTLY
SET TO EXPIRE JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE RECOMMEND
EXTENDING THE SLOTS UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. WE ESTIMATE THIS ACTION
WOULD COST TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY FOUR MILLION. WITH THE
REMAINDER OF THE FUNDS THE
STATE COULD PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL DOCTOR SLOTS- UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. WE RECOMMEND VOUCHER
SOCKS INSTEAD OF GENERAL CHILD
CARE SLOTS BECAUSE OF THE
TEMPORARY NATURE OF THE FUNDS
FIRST. AND ULTRA PROVIDERS ARE
ABLE TO BEGIN USING SOCKS MUCH
QUICKER THAN GENERAL CHILD
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS- BECAUSE
OF THE STATE CONTRACTING.
PROCESS WHEN WE ASKED THE STATE
WOULD BE ABLE TO ABOUT FOURTH.
SLOTS IMAGE LOWER THAN THE
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND- FROM OCT.
TO TWENTY AND TO REJECT OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. OUR
RECOMMENDED APPROACH AVOIDS
DESTROYING FAMILIES FROM CHILD
CARE INVOLVED JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND JUNE IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- WHEN THE
TEMPORARY SLOTS ARE SET TO
EXPIRE. ON AVAILABILITY OF
FUNDS-
BUT IT DOES PUSH TO. YOU
KNOW A HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
MILLION OF AN ONGOING RESOURCE
BY JULY TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
WITH REGARD TO THE GENERAL FUND
IN PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
HUNDRED SLOTS THE LEGISLATURE
MADE WANT TO CONSIDER A TOLD BY
MY- THE MIX OF. EXPANSION OF
GOING TO EACH OF PER. THE
GOVERNOR'S- PROVIDE ROUGHLY
SIXTY OF THE SLOT EXPANDING DR
PROGRAM WITH THE REMAINING 4%
ON THE GENERAL CHILD CARE KERR.
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER ALL MAKES SLAPSTICK- I
WHICH FROM BEST ME YOUR- FOR
THE- IF LEGISLATURE TO CREATE
MORE TIME- IMMEDIATELY
INCREASING ACT TO TRY. THE
MOTORCYCLE BE THE SOCKS THEY
WANT. TO BECAUSE IT JUST HE
TYPICALLY TO NINE TO RE UP CHEN
CHILD SLOTS YOU TO THE STATE
CONTRACT PROCESS ONLY A FEW
MONTHS TO UP THE SAW. THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS. IN MY LAST
COMMENT IS ABOUT THE PROPOSED-
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT ON THE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
AMERICA FUND PROPOSED FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT- SO WE
KNOW THAT OUR BUDGET HEALTHCARE
FUNDS CANNOT BE USED FOR.
CONSTRUCTION MAJOR INNOVATION
LAND PURCHASE FOR LEAD TO
IMPROVEMENT MINOR RENOVATIONS
SUCH AS INSTALLING THEN YOU'RE
A NEW H. BACK OR SMOKE
DETECTORS IN ALLOW POLICE
DEPARTMENT FUNDS. GIVEN THESE
RESTRICTIONS- EITHER THE SCHOOL
THE PROPOSAL WILL NEED TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFIED TO
EXCLUDE ACQUISITION
CONSTRUCTION AND DEVELOPMENT.
OR THE PROPOSAL WE NEED TO BE
FUNDED WITH JAVA THIS CONCLUDES
MY REMARKS BUT I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF A TRADE YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE TO STRETCHING THAT OUT
TO TWENTY TWENTY FOUR VERSUS
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WELCOME HI
SORRY I SWITCHING DEVICES HERE
AT THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY
TYPICALLY YOU CAN DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS. AND WITH RESPECT
TO THE SLOTS ARE PROPOSAL IS AM
60% OF THEM IF YOU WERE TO BE
ALTERNATIVE CLASS AND 40% OF
THEM TO BE- GENERAL CHILD CARE
WITH A FEW SMALLER AT PROGRAM
INVESTMENTS AS WELL. WE BELIEVE
THAT THESE FLIGHTS COULD BE
TAKEN UP IN IN IN THE TIME
FRAMES THAT WE HAVE PROPOSED A
FREEZE THEM IN AND ARE ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE FULL
INVESTMENT AND COMMITTED FULLY
TO ALL ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SECTION ONE HUNDRED SIX
THOUSAND SLOTS. AND THAT IS THE
APPROACH SAID THAT WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO PROPOSE OKAY. OKAY
AND THEN THEN CAN YOU KNOW THAT
THE ARE BILL BACK PROBABLY PLAN
HAS TWO HUNDRED FLIGHTS AS DOES
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS-
HAS TWO HUNDRED SLOT SAID THAT
THAT WE THINK ARE NEEDED- AND
ALSO AND TELL ME ABOUT THE
DECISION NOT TO DO ANYTHING
WITH RATE REFORM WE'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT RATE REFORM IN OUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. YOU TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT. SURE
AND HAPPY TO WE SIMILARLY HAVE
HEARD FROM QUITE A FEW. FOLKS
WITH RESPECT TO RATES AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THE IMPORTANCE
EVERY. WITHIN THE CHILD CARE
SYSTEM I'M BAD THE MASTER PLAN
CONVERSATIONS ON RATE- AND MANY
STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND WE HAVE
RECEIVED AS WELL. AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO TAKE A VERY CLOSE
MARK- AT THE RATE SYSTEM AT THE
STRUCTURE AND THAT THE RATES
THEMSELVES. AND AS YOU ADD
CRAP. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THEIR STATUTORY FRAMEWORK WITH
RESPECT TO- BARGAINING WITH THE
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS UNITED.
UNITED UNION AND INCLUDES RATE
SETTING WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
BARGAINING SO AS WE- CONTINUE
TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT RATES-
AND TO IMPLEMENT THAT STATUTES
AND WE CERTAINLY DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
FURTHER. ON THOSE ISSUES. OKAY
THANK YOU I'M SOME ITEMS WILL
HAVE A LOT MORE CONVERSATIONS
I'M SURE ABOUT- TELL KAREN T.
K. AND THE PROPOSALS BEFORE US
MOVING FORWARD OKAY AND YOU'VE
LOST ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BUT ME SO WE WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE-
CHILDCARE PANDEMIC RELIEF.
GREAT WITH RESPECT TO FOCUSING
ON ACADEMIC RELEASED- THE BEST
IN THE MAY REVISION- THERE'S A
TOTAL OF MORE THAN FOUR POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT'S BEING
PROVIDED TO CALIFORNIA BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WE HAVE
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO OR
TWENTY TWENTY THREE DEPENDING
ON THE FUNDS SOURCE TO OBLIGATE
THOSE FUNDS AND THEN ONE
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO YEAR EXPAND
BAM- THERE WAS ALREADY SOME
ACTION TAKEN- IN IN PRIOR
BUDGET ACTIONS TO PROVIDE
RELIEF TO THE FIELD IN AN
EFFORT TO STABILIZE WHAT WE
KNOW HAS BEEN A DEVASTATING AND
DIFFICULT TIME. FOR PROVIDERS
AND FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
ACROSS THE STATE. AND THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES ADDITIONAL
RELIEF EFFORTS- AND THESE ARE-
INVESTMENTS THAT THAT WERE- AN
AGREEMENT THAT WAS REACHED WITH
THE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS UNITED
UNION THROUGH A WORK GROUP
PROCESS FOR PANDEMIC RELIEF. SO
I WILL HIGHLIGHT BED BEES
INCLUDE INVESTMENTS IN ONE TIME
STIPENDS FOR ALL LICENSED.
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME
PROVIDERS HAVE THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN ADDITION TO
TIERED STIPENDS FOR LICENSE
CENTERS THAT RANGE FROM. THREE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED TO SIX
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
BASED ON LICENSED. CHILD
CAPACITY- TWO HUNDRED SIX NO
DOLLARS FOR ONE TIME PROVIDER
STIPENDS OF SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR SUBSIDIZED CHILD. IT ALSO
INCLUDES THE WAIVER OF FAMILY
FEES FOR ALL FAMILIES THROUGH
THE END OF JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. ANY REVISION INCLUDES AS
WELL AND INVESTMENT IN THE
CHILD CARE INITIATIVE PROJECTS
TO BUILD CAPACITY BEFORE IN THE
TIGER AND OTHER SLOTS AND- TO
ASSIST US IN LICENSING AND
PROVIDERS WITHIN CHILD CARE
DESERT. THE MAY REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES AN INVESTMENT IN BE
CALIFORNIA INCLUSION AND
BEHAVIOR CONSULTATION SERVICES
TO INCLUDE SUPPORT FOR THE
CHILD CARE WORKFORCE IN MEETING
THE NEEDS OF CHILDREN- AND
TAKING CARE OF THEMSELVES. IT
INCLUDES AS WELL SIXTEEN
ADDITIONAL PAID NON OPERATIONAL
DAYS FOR KOBE NINETEEN RELATED
CLOSURES AND THE CONTINUATION
OF A HOLD HARMLESS POLICY THAT
PAYS CONTRACTED PROVIDERS BASED
ON THE MAXIMUM LEVEL AND NEED-
YOUR AGENDA ASKS A QUESTION
WITH RESPECT TO THE AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL SPENDING THAT REMAINS-
I'M ALLOCATED. SINCE AS I
INDICATED NOT ALL FEDERAL FUNDS
NEED TO BE- OBLIGATED AND
LIQUIDATED IMMEDIATELY- IT- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE IS
ONE POINT ONE EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS NOT YET
ALLOCATED IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
QUESTION- IN THE PROPOSALS THAT
YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU. THE ANSWER
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISS CORTES. HELLO AGAIN
CORTES AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- SO AGAIN WE
JUST LIKE TICK ME OUT MY
COMMENTS WITH RESPECT- WORST
ARE UNDERSTANDING OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSALS ARE EVOLVING AS WE
CONTINUE TO PREVIEW MORE
DOCUMENTS BASED ON OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE REVISION
FAILED TO INCLUDE A PROPOSAL TO
FULLY EXPANDED TWO POINT THREE
BILLION OF CHILD CARE
STABILIZATION OF FUNDING. SO
THAT WITH THIS HEALTHCARE
STABILISATION FUNDING PROVIDED
THROUGH THE STATE IS TO PROVIDE
GRANTS TO CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
TO KEEP COSTS SUCH AS PAYROLL
RENT AND CLEANING SUPPLIES SO
CHILDCARE STABILIZATION FUNDS
TOTALING TWO POINT THREE
BILLION MUST BE FULLY EXPENDED
BY SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE HOWEVER THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT STRONGLY
ENCOURAGES STATES TO EXPAND AT
LEAST HALF OF THE FUNDS BY
DECEMBER ELEVENTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS CONGRESSIONAL
INTENT IS THAT THESE RESOURCES
BE USED FOR BUYING MEDIA FISCAL
RELIEF TO THE CHILD CARE
SECTOR. AND THIS INCLUDES
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
NOT PARTICIPATING IN THE
SUBSIDIZED TO STOP THE STATE IS
TO DEVELOP AN APPLICATION AND
AWARDS OF GRANTS WHICH
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS BASED ON
THEIR OPERATING EXPENSES. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU. MISTER YOU WANT TO
SPEAK TO THE ABOUT WHAT PLAN IS
ALL THOSE MY OUT. I'M YES I CAN
CERTAINLY CONFIRM FOR YOU THAT
WE ARE. I DON'T KNOW IF YOUR
INTERNET MOVE WORK FOR YOU.
THIS IS GET OUT ON THE
DEPARTMENT I IT LOOKS LIKE WE
LOST STRATEGIES DEPUTY THERE SO
I THINK SHE WAS JUST GOING TO
SAY THAT WE CAN CONFIRM THAT WE
ARE ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT THE WORKAROUND.
MORE HELP. BACK OKAY CAN YOU
FOR- SO JUST JUMPING IN FOR YOU
OKAY. THE SAME HE CAME IN FOR
THE SAME QUICKLY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU DIRECTOR JOHNSON M.
IF YOU CAN HEAR ME OUT I'LL GO
AHEAD AND CONTINUE AND MY TRAIN
OF THOUGHT WHICH WAS JUST TODAY
BUT WE ARE COMPLYING WITH THE
INTENT TO GET IT TO GET FUNDS
OUT AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN AT THE
SAME TIME WE ARE HAVING SOME
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT GIVEN.
THAT THERE IS TIME FOR THE
STATE TO- EXPANDED OBLIGATE THE
FUNDS OVER MULTIPLE YEARS. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT- A LOT TO DO IN THIS
SPACE AND DID YOU DID YOU
ANSWER THE QUESTION ABOUT ABOUT
JUST. REGULAR PARENTS WHO HAVE
KIDS WHO ARE GENERALLY IN CHILD
CARE- WOULD COULD THEY BE WERE
THE RECIPIENTS OF SOME OF THOSE
FUNDS THAT NEEDS TO GET OUT THE
DOOR AS THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SEND THEIR KIDS BACK IN. BUT
I'VE HAD SOME OF THE SAME NEEDS
OF SOME OF OUR PROVIDERS. I'M
pPROVIDE. PROPOSING HERE IS
REALLY MORE ABOUT- IT IS REALLY
MORE ABOUT RELIEF TO THE FIELD
IN A STABILIZATION OF THE FIELD
WHICH ULTIMATELY OF COURSE
BENEFITS PARENTS- THERE ARE
OBVIOUSLY A NUMBER OF OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT ARE ARE MORE
ABOUT WOODS AND BENEFITING
PARENTS IN TERMS OF THEIR OWN
ECONOMIC STABILITY SOME OF THEM
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
TODAY. AS WELL AS THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS AND GOLDEN STATE
GRAHAM'S- IN ADDITION BE SLOT
THAT BET WE ARE PROPOSING AND I
KNOW YOU- AS YOU AS YOU
REFERENCED HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR
EVEN MORE FOR OBVIOUSLY ARE ARE
CERTAINLY INTENDED TO BENEFIT
THE FAMILIES AND CHILDREN HERE
RELY UPON THE SYSTEM. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT-
AND WILL BE WILL BE IT WILL BE
SEE MORE THE PROPOSALS AS THEY
COME INTO WERE WERE- WE'RE
EXCITED THAT THAT THERE IS
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR CHILDCARE
RATHER THAN CUTTING IT- AND NOW
WHICH HOPEFULLY SPENDING IT AS
EFFECTIVELY AS WE POSSIBLY CAN-
TO BE ABLE TO STABILIZE. THE
INDUSTRY AND BE ABLE TO HAVE A
SAFE PLACE FOR PARENTS TO SEND
THEIR KIDS SO THEY CAN GET BACK
TO WORK. OKAY I'M MOVING ON TO
THE FINAL ISSUE. NOW I WAS
GONNA SAY TO SHE'S GOT ONE MORE
YEAR NO NUTS THAT'S DONE I
DON'T HAVE ANYMORE HERE OKAY-
DID DEPARTMENTS I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK
AND I KNOW AS BUSY AS WE'VE
BEEN ON THE LEGISLATIVE SIDE
AND OUR- OUR BUDGET STAFFERS
BEEN ANALYZING EVERYTHING I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY WHILE STILL
DELIVERING PROGRAMS AND TAKING
CARE OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND
THEN MAKING PLANS FOR THE
FUTURE I KNOW THAT IS- I KNOW
THAT YOU ALL WHERE A LOT OF
HATS. I NEVER KNOW IF I LOOK
HERE LOOK THERE- BUT WE
APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT YOU DO AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO PARTNERING IN YEARS GOING
FORWARD AS WE AS WE FINALLY
HAVE SOME MONEY TO HOPEFULLY BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF SOME OF
THESE PRESSING ISSUES THAT
WE'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO BE ABLE
TO DO MORE ABOUT. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY WITH THAT
WITHOUT THESE. ONE THING THAT I
THOUGHT I MIGHT HAVE BUT I
DON'T. WE WILL ASK- WOULD THEN
GO TO THE PHONE LINES- FIRST I
GUESS WE SHOULD LOOK INTO ROOM
AB ONE TWELVE FOR ANYBODY
THERE- I'M GOING TO ASK. THE
MODERATOR HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
ON THE PHONE LINE. AND THEN
WE'LL PROBABLY TAKE A- THREE
MINUTE RECESS- IN BETWEEN WE
START TAKING CALLS SOMEBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE MISTER. MISTER
MISTER MODERATOR PERSON. RIGHT
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
TWENTY SIX PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO LET'S TAKE A
THREE MINUTE RESOURCE AT RECESS
AND THEN WILL BE BACK- ED TO
HEAR FROM OUR OUR CALLERS. AND
I WOULDN'T OF REMINDER COLORS
THAT WE'VE BEEN HERE FOR MANY
HOURS NOW AND IF- WHEN YOU
START HEARING PEOPLE SAYING THE
SAME THING THAT YOU WERE GONNA
SAY. AND THEN IT MIGHT JUST BE
GOOD IF YOU GIVE YOUR NAME AND
POSITION- AN ORGANIZATION
VERSUS- GOING THROUGH THE SAME
TALKING POINTS- WE APPRECIATE
IT AND I WILL WILL RETURN IN
THREE MINUTES.
AND WE'RE BACK
IN SESSION MODERATOR. FIRST
CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU WE WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE. ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE. RIGHT THE WHOLE
FARM PRINCESS I AM WITH RIGHT
NOW I JUST WANTED TO
CONGRATULATE THE
ADMINISTRATION. BREAKING BACK
MITCHELL GOING TO HEAR HOW. AND
REALLY ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
THE IMPACT WILL NEED FOR THE
SHORT TERM AND FOR THE LONG
TERM FANNING. BUDGET NOW HAS
THE SPENDING A LOT OF FUN THIS
YEAR REITERATING THE FACT THAT
WE ARE ACTUALLY STILL IN THE
MIDDLE FOR EXAMPLE. COMPUTERS
BUT ALL I'LL- CERTAINLY MOST OF
THE GOVERNOR IMPACT MANY OF.
OUR REALLY. IT BUT WHEN A YEAR
TWO FROM. WE RECKON ALLEGE.
REALLY ENCOURAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO THINK ABOUT
BOTH AND WE CAN DO BOTH. GIVEN
THE STATE'S FINANCIAL FUTURE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE- BLIND. TWO HUNDRED.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS JEREMY DAY TANK
BUT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES CALLING
REGARDING PART ANY OF THE
AGENDA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL
WELL SOME DETAILS STILL NEED TO
BE WORKED OUT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INTERNET THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED EIGHT.
BETTER HEARING MEMBERS
ENTERTAIN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS-
THING THE LATE HOUR I'LL BE
BRIEF BUT I JUST WANTED TO
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT- SSI AND SSDI
INCLUDING I DID NOT KNOW THAT
YOU'RE CURRENTLY SUPPORTING ONE
OF YOUR WELL ONE OF YOUR
FRIENDS I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT- AND CREATE THAT THE
PROPOSAL TO APPLE RESTORATION
INCLUDING PER BLOCK INFLATION
ARE QUICK AND I'LL DO THAT- A
NOMINAL INCREASE IS STILL.
ABOUT 24% SURE GIVEN THE-
INFLATION SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN
ON CAL WORKS- REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS QUESTION AROUND THE- AS
YOU PLUS ONE MAKING SURE THAT
WE TRULY LEFT ALL OF OUR
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY- AND
LAST BUT NOT LEAST ALSO THE
FAMILY REUNIFICATION HOUSING
BOARD REALLY APPRECIATE
MINISTRATION IT IS DOING THERE
AS WELL AS H. STAFF WITHIN AT
THE SITE- AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST- WE ARE STILL TO THE
POINT THAT THERE ARE. NO
INVESTMENT IN FOOD- AND WE KNOW
THAT YOU'VE AND YOUR CALL HAVE
BEEN VERY. IN THE AGAIN BUT I
FOR THE SO I'M LOOKING FOR THE
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND YOUR NASCO PLEASE. TO
SEVEN. THANK MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MEGAN ON OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATE
REPRESENTING THIRTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER SITES
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE PART A I
JUST FIRST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
TO THE TREMENDOUS INVESTMENT IN
CHILD AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR GETTING INTO THE
DETAILS OF SOME OF THIS
PROPOSAL ACTIVITIES PROPOSAL
OPENERS CONTINUE TO FOSTER
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS TO ENSURE PATIENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO THE FULL
SPECTRUM OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. WE STAND READY TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND ARE COUNTY PARTNERS TO
IMPROVE THE FRAGMENTED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DELIVERY
SYSTEM WE MUST ENSURE THAT
THESE NEW REPORTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE ALL ARE AVAILABLE TO
ALL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
INCLUDING MILD TO MODERATE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS AND
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS ALSO EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR THE WORK FORCE
ADJUSTMENT UNDER OCCUPIED AND
PARTICULARLY ITEM ONE UNDER
AUSPICES FONG BROWN HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE MAGNIFICATION. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
THESE SOME OF THESE DOLLARS ARE
AVAILABLE TO HEALTH CENTERS
AFFILIATED RESIDENCY PROGRAM
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED
ELI. KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA URBAN COUNTIES ARE
GENERALLY PLEASED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISION
INVESTMENTS AND HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICE PROGRAMS A
HIGHLIGHT A FEW ISSUES FIRST
REGARDING HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS ARE
COUNTY OTHER SUPPORT ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR HUMAN SERVICES
RELATED PROGRAMS WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE 25% SHARE
OF COST BECAUSE IT MAY HINDER
COUNTY PARTICIPATION
ADDITIONALLY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
TRAILER BILL TO KEEP ATTACHED
TORY FLEXIBILITIES THEY'RE
PROPOSING. SECOND BERMAN
COUNTIES ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION BY HFS PROPOSAL
TO KEEP THE STATE CALTRAIN
RATIO AT 65% THINK 35% COUNTY
AND TO CONTINUE THE 10% OVER
THREE YEARS TOOL YOU SEE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE THAT TRAILER BILL
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE CAP ON
YOUR LIFE IN THE 10% OVER A
THREE YEAR TO ONLY TWICE. THIRD
URBAN COUNTY FOR SUPPORT OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BEYOND THE
MAY REVISION FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE FAMILIES FIRST
PRESERVATION SERVICES ACT WE
SUPPORT INVESTING IVESTING TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARS ADDITIONALLY
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PRIORITIZING
INVESTMENTS AND CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT ARE
CRITICAL TO BRING TO CAPACITY
AND THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM INVESTMENT IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR WORKFORCE FOR ESPECIALLY
CRITICAL FINALLY AT THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SUPPORT MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR THE RAPID RESPONSE PROGRAM
UNDER THE IMMIGRATION AYE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED
SIX. ONE SHARE MEMBERS THAT
WILL YOU WANT YOU I'M PART
ISSUE FIVE WE SUPPORT
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE OVER THE YEARS ON
THE PERMANENT RESTORATION THE
7% WE SUPPORT MAINTAINED I KEEP
A COST SHARING RATIO ON THE
BACK OF THE SEN A CAREER
PATHWAY WE KNOW THAT MANY AYE
TO THE PROVIDER THINK YOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO MAY NOT BE
LOOKING TO MOVE INTO ANOTHER
CAREER OR SOMETHING FINING EACH
DEFINED TRAINING THING FOR
QUALITY OF CARE AND IDEALLY A
WAGE INCREASE. AND I TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TRACK I JUST THE
CLIENTS WE OPPOSE THE STRIKE
WITH THE GPS PROHIBITION
OPPOSED THE IDEA THAT THE
RESIDUAL OF TERMINATION
REACHING DOCTOR CAN'T COMMENT
TO RECHARGE THE CONTRACT AND
WOULD URGE THAT OPTION THE
FISCAL COUNTY PROPOSAL MOVING
QUICKLY TO CHILD CARE FOR ISSUE
EIGHT NEED AT THE EDGE OF THE
BOX MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND IT WOULD URGE THAT
RATE THAN MINIMUM ARE BASED OFF
OF. FEDERALLY LET SB TWO FORTY
SIX AND LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
DISCUSSION COUNTY K. AND
FINALLY FOR ISSUE NINE YEAR
IMPORT BOTH SUPPORT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO REACHING A FULL.
UNION CONTRACT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU NICE COLOR
PLEASE. TO TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD
EVENING DIANA DUGGAR WHAT HELL
ACCESS HELLO. CALIFORNIA
SPEAKING ON CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFIT EXCHANGE ISSUE
CALIFORNIA MERGES A NATIONWIDE
LEADER IN OFFERING
AFFORDABILITY ASSESSMENT IN
COVERED CALIFORNIA THE MOST
PEOPLE IN COVERED CALIFORNIA
PLANS DON'T HAVE DEDUCTIBLES
THE FOR EVEN SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THEY MIGHT HAVE TO
SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR A
REGULAR DOCTORS THAT THAT.
PEOPLE MAKING FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YER DON'T HAVE THE
SAVINGS NECESSARY TO COVER
THESE RISING DEDUCTIBLES WE
MUST PRESERVE THE OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ALREADY
ALLOCATED FOR AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE PENALTY SHOULD GO
TOWARDS GREATER AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE THE RESERVES SHOULD
NOT BE FUNDED FROM THIS REVENUE
ALLOW. IT THE FEDERAL SUBSIDIES
DO EXPIRE IN TWO YEARS THE
PENALTY REVENUE IS NOT ENOUGH
TO KEEP GIVING CALIFORNIANS THE
STATE THAT'S THE DAY THAT COME
TO RELY UPON WE ASK THAT
ALREADY ALLOCATED STATE BUT THE
PEOPLE IN THE RESEARCH AND I
COVER CALIFORNIA BE DIRECTED TO
RECONFIGURE AND IMPLEMENT
REDUCED DEDUCTIBLES AND COST
SHARING FOR TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. PEOPLE NEED CALIFORNIANS
BELIEVE THE WAY AGAIN WITH
LOWER PREMIUM LOWER COPAYS. AND
DEDUCTIBLES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK CALLER
PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BUT I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT KEEP
YOU PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
YOUR CLIENT NIGHT ON PART EIGHT
ISSUE ONE PDF HE IS REPORT
ACOSTA FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION CONGRONG RESIDENCY
TRAINING PROGRAM CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING A SHORTAGE OF
PRIMARY CARE FAMILY PRACTICE
PHYSICIANS IN THE EXTENT OF THE
SCHOOL FUNDING NEW POSITION
RESIDENCY PROGRAM THIS IS AN
EXCITING PROPOSAL FOR FAMILY
MEDICINE. BOB BROWN IS THE ONLY
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
FUNDING PROGRAM CALIFORNIA'S
EXCLUSIVELY FUND PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCIES THE TIMING IS
CRITICAL IN ASSURING THAT
PATIENTS IN MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS HAVE ACTED TO
THE FIHERMEN WHO UNDERSTAND
THAT LOOK LIKE THEM AND SPEAK
THEIR LANGUAGES CFU STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS ALLOCATION BECAUSE
SUPPORTING PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE AND
CONTROLS CREATING A MORE
EFFICIENT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
THEN ON THE HALF MARATHON A
PARTNERSHIP IN REGARDS TO PART
B. ISSUE ONE WE APPLAUD THE
AFFECTED CAL WORK AUGMENTATION
GOING TRYING TO THE PATHWAY TO
EQUITY FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
BUT WE'VE BEEN VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT HOME VISITING
HOME VISITING EVIDENCE BASED
HOME VISITING HAS NOT BEEN
REFUNDED WE TOOK A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR CUT IN THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE CAL WORK HOMEBUILDING
REFUNDED TO THE PREVIOUS
AMOUNT. THEN ON BEHALF OF AND A
P. AS WELL WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE FACT MANY QUESTIONS ON THE
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES ACT AND ENCOURAGE THE
INCLUSION OF MORE EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS IN PHASE ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COLOR PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE. I GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS DANNY COLDER C. E. OF
THE K. ALTERNATE PAYMENT
PROGRAM. OUR COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS SUPPORT ESSENTIAL AND
OUR LOW INCOME FAMILIES WITH
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE AND OTHER
NEEDED FAMILY SUPPORT MY INPUT
IS IN REGARDS TO PARTY AGENDA
ISSUE EIGHT. ON THE PROPOSED
NAY REVISED FAILURE TO INCREASE
RATE WILL COLLAPSE THE
CHILDCARE FEEL- THERE ANY FLOP
PROVIDED ARE ANTICIPATED TO
ONLY BE ACCEPTED BY LICENSE
EXAM PROVIDERS. AND WILL
FURTHER DISCONNECT OUR LOWEST
INCOME MAINLY BLACK AND BROWN
WOMEN WHO ARE ALSO HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD FROM HIGHER QUALITY
LIFE FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES
AND CENTRES. NOT INCREASING
RATES WILL KEEP PROVIDERS
IMPOVERISHED MAKING HOURLY
RATES OF BETWEEN THREE DOLLARS
AND TWENTY CENTS TO NINE FIFTY
PER HOUR. REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SLOT WITHOUT A RATE
INCREASE MANY HIGHER QUALITY
PROVIDERS WILL NOT ACCEPT OUT
YOUR STRENGTH UP BUT I
FAMILIES. CREATING A GREATER
RACIAL INEQUITY DIVIDE IF THE
INCREASE AND PLOTTED SECURED
WITH A RATE INCREASE THERE MUST
BE CONSIDERATION OF ONE TIME
GRANT MONEY FOR AGENCIES TO
IMMEDIATELY BEGIN TO RAMP UP
FOR FAMILY INVOLVEMENT. WE
BELIEVE THAT IF YOU INCREASE
THE RATE FROM PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR CONTRACTORS TO RAMP UP THEN
WE WILL BE ABLE TO ENROLL ANY
NUMBER OF SLOTS THAT YOU MAKE
AVAILABLE. ONE NOTE ON WHAT. I
THE DAY PROP SIXTY DEFINED IN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
NEW SLOT. PLEASE BE AWARE THAT
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET. THEY'RE ALSO
INCLUDED CROP SIXTY FOURTH
FUNDING FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
SIX HUNDRED BLOCK ENGINES THAT-
INTO THE STATE. BOTH LOTS HAVE
NOT BEEN RELEASED. IN REGARDS
TO THE T. K. PROPOSAL I SIMPLY
ASKED THAT THERE BE PURSUED A
PROTECTION OF PARENTAL CHOICE
FOR THOSE FAMILIES WITH THE T.
K. PROGRAM DOES NOT MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE FAMILY. THAT THERE
BE VALUED A TRUE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP COMING TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT CHILD AND FAMILY NEEDS.
FINALLY I ASKED THAT THERE BE
CONSIDERATION TO PROTECT
CHOICES THE FAMILY BY ALLOWING
REIMBURSEMENT A SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE DURING SCHOOL HOURS.
FINALLY IF YOU LOOK AT ISSUE TO
COME BACK HOME WITH THEIR CHILD
CARE FOR A VERY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
A CRITICAL COMPONENT THAT MAKE
THAT DIFFERENCE ASIDE FROM THE
B. THE ABOUT THE WOULD LIKE TO
LINE OUR SUPPORT OF THOSE WITH
THE ECB COALITION AND LEFT THAT
THE REIMBURSEMENT OF OUR VALUED
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
AND INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU.
THE YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SIX. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
COURTNEY JENSEN ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION REPRESENTING OVER
FORTY ORGANISATIONS BROWN
REFERENCE APART AND YOU END UP
PART BE ISSUE EIGHT AND OUR
COALITION IS IN SUPPORT OF
FUNDING FOR CHILD CARE
FACILITIES WE APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT AFTER AROUND FIFTY
MILLION AND THE REVISED BUT
MORE INVESTMENT IS NEEDED WE
ARE REQUESTING AT LEAST THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION THE
SUPPORT HOME BASED AND CENTER
BASED. CHILD CARE FACILITIES WE
ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE
ADMINISTRATION AND L. A. R. TO
DISCUSS THE USE OF FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION WE MUST INVEST IN
FACILITIES TO ENSURE WE HAVE
THE PHYSICAL SPACE NECESSARY
FOR THE NEWS BOB DISCUSSED
TODAY THANK YOUNG THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
TWO HUNDRED. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND MAN AND G. B. S. ON BEHALF
OF SEIU CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
THE PUBLIC SECTOR COUNTY
WORKERS FROM ACROSS ALL COUNTY
DEPARTMENT COMMENTING ON QUITE
A WITH REGARD TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FIRST WE APPRECIATE THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IMPROVE
YOU ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND THE LONGER TERM
THINKING AND HOW TO BUILD UP
THE ACTUAL WORKFORCE BOTH IN
THE DATA PLATFORM BUT ALSO AN
ACTUAL WORKFORCE PROGRAMS BUT
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. AND ALSO THE WORK
FORCE PROGRAM EXPANSION AND
BOTH INITIATIVES WE ARE
DISMAYED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL DID NOT
INCLUDE ANY EXPLICIT
RECOGNITION OR INVESTMENT IN
OUR EXISTING PUBLIC SECTOR
COUNTY WORKERS WHO HAD BEEN
RESOURCE CHALLENGE TIME AND
TIME AND AGAIN THE WORK FORCE
PROPOSAL PRESENTATION SOME
PROMISING BUT THEY ARE AGAIN
FUTURE LOOKING AND ALSO FALL
SHORT AND ACTUALLY OF KNOWLEDGE
AND EXISTING PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKFORCE THAT NEED TO BE
FUNDED NOW IN ORDER TO BE
MAINTAINED AND THEN ACTUALLY
GROWING IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
TO MEET THE PENT UP DEMAND.
OTHER STATE AND SCHOOLS FULLY
REOPENED ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
ALARMED BY HOW MUCH OF THE
PROPOSED FUNDING IS
CONTEMPLATED TO BE USED OUTSIDE
OF EXISTING PUBLIC SECTOR
PROGRAM AND POTENTIALLY
CONTRACTED OUT OUR PUBLIC
SECTOR IS A STATEWIDE NETWORK
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
EXPERTISE TO OPERATE THESE
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS ARE
NEEDED NOW AND STA YOU BELIEVE
THIS FINDING SHOULD ALSO BE
TARGETED. TO FIND SUCCESSFUL
COUNTY CARRILLO LADDERS AND
MENTORSHIP MODEL WE JUST DON'T
WANT TO BUILD UP THE WORK FORCE
WE WANT TO BUILD UP HIGH
QUALITY WORKFORCE WHO WILL HAVE.
HIGH QUALITY JOBS THANK YOU.
THANK VERY MUCH THANK COLOR
PLAY. TWO HUNDRED ONE. IT A LOT
I'M SURE IN MEMBERS KAREN
LAYING ON TOP OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
I. HSS PROPOSAL THAT MAINTAINS
THE SIXTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE
SPLIT THAT'S A REALLY BIG DEAL
TO THE COUNTY AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CONTINUING NOT ON ASK
FOR EITHER A GREAT TIME THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THREE. GOOD EVENING WENT
AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY RELATED TO HEALTH
ISSUES WE SUPPORT THEY'RE
ALWAYS OUT A ONE DOLLAR PREMIUM
DEPUTY AT THE SCHOOL EXPAND
COVERAGE FOR LOW INCOME NON
MEDICARE ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS
WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO AUTO
ENROLL IN COVERAGE I THINK THAT
THE SHOW THAT EVEN A ONE DOLLAR
PREMIUM CAN BE IN THE MOMENT
BEAR. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF THE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND TO
ALLOW FOR FUTURE INVESTMENT
COVERED CALIFORNIA SUBSIDIES
THE RECOMMENDED RATHER THAN
REPORT AND THANKS STATE
SUBSIDIES THE GENERAL FUND IF
THEY CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
HEALTH COVERAGE AFFORDABILITY
SHOULD THE FEDERAL SUBSIDIES
EXPIRE THANK. YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NICE COLOR PLEASE.
TWO HUNDRED FOUR. HI WENDY
HILLARY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WELL WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
FIFTY MILLION IN FUNDING TO
START UP NEW PRESIDENT THE
PROGRAM WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
APPROPRIATING ALL THE FUNDS FOR
PRIMARY CARE UNNECESSARILY
IMPEDE THE EFFECTIVENESS
FUNDING THERE ARE MANY SPECIAL
PIECE THAT COULDN'T HAPPEN CARE
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA LIMITING THE
ALLOCATION OF THE NEW RESIDENCY
PROGRAM ON ONLY TO THE
STRUCTURE PROVIDED YOUR SONG
BROWN WHAT UNNECESSARILY
CONSTRAIN THE IMPACT OF. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IN FINDING THE
RIGHT BALANCE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT WORK OR SOMETHING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU MADAM%
CHAIR MEMBERS CABINETS UNDER
LIMITS ON WHAT THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WE APPRECIATE TODAY'S
DISCUSSION ON THE ISSUES THAT
RELATE TO THE PROGRAMS ARE
MEMBERS DELIVER. ON THE STATE'S
BEHALF. THE PROPOSAL
SIGNIFICANT AND IN MANY AREAS
OF CRAFTED IN THAT. WE DO HAVE
A NUMBER OF CRITICAL PENDING
REQUESTS FOR YOU THAT WERE NOT
FULLY ADDRESSED INCLUDING THE
STANDING AT ALL PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. CASE MANAGEMENT
DELIVERING FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION STATEWIDE TO REDUCE
DISPARITIES INCREASE RACIAL DR.
WE HAVE SUFFICIENT AND STATE
FOR APPROPRIATE THE MOST
COMPLEX NEEDS. PROVIDING
FLEXIBLE HOUSING SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WE
FAIR AND FULLY FUNDING A
CONFERENCE STUDENT ELIGIBILITY
EXPANSION EMPOWER THE
MINISTRATION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF THE ADMINISTRATION THANK
YOU FOR HOLDING THESE AND OTHER
AREAS FOR PROPER BEFORE RETAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT. HI EIGHT ELEMENTARY
ARTICLE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION COMMENTING ON
AGENDA EIGHT AND THE
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENT IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THAT I'M
BEING PUT FORWARD BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF MANY OF THESE
INITIATIVES INCLUDING THE CHILD
AND YOUTH INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL WE'RE GENERALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENTS WE'RE INTERESTED IN
SEEING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO GET MORE DETAIL ON
IT WE WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT
THAT WE GET ALTHOUGH WE DO
SUPPORT HERE FUNDING WE BELIEVE
THAT THE MOST IMPACTFUL FUNDING
SHOULD FOCUS ON LIFTING UP.
CALIFORNIANS PEER SUPPORT
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM THAT'S
CURRENTLY BEING DEVELOPED UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BECAUSE THE HOSPITAL
DIDN'T TRAIN PEERS CANNOT DRAW
DOWN FEDERAL MATCH UNTIL
CALIFORNIA FULLY IMPLEMENTED
THIS PROGRAM WE DO HAVE BEEN
ASKING IT. TO THE CONCERN OF
THE COPS AROUND THIS PROGRAM
THAT WE'RE HOPING THE FUNDS CAN
BE USED FOR THAT PURPOSE
FINALLY UNDER THE MHS. AWASTHI
ISSUE ONE. THE A SUPPORT. THE
MEN HEALTH DIDN'T SERVE THAT
BINDING TO REACH THAT EMAIL
DOLLAR AMOUNT ORDER TO FIND ALL
APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO. MADAM
CHAIR MIKE CARROLL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY THANK YOU FOR THIS-
CORD HEARING THIS EVENING- I
HAVE SEVERAL COMMENTS ABOUT
YOUR GET YOU VERY QUICKLY- BUT
I DO WANT TO JUST START OUT BY
SOMETHING THAT WAS SAID BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S- EARLIER
IN THE DISCUSSION WHICH IS BAD.
YOU KNOW WHEN THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY GOING INTO A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS NEW PROGRAMS HOME OPEN
HOUSING PROGRAM ALL OF THIS
VERY WELL INTENDED IMPACT THEIR
MANY PROPOSALS MINUTES BUDGET
THAT ARE REALLY GREAT FOR- LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS BUT AT THE
BOTTOM OF THIS YOU KNOW OUR
UNDER FUNDING OF BASIC GRANT
ASSISTANCE FOR APPLE PIE AND
CAL WORKS FAMILY LEADS TO US
HAVING TO SPEND MONEY IN
PROGRAMS. THAT WE MIGHT NOT
OTHERWISE HAVE TO DO IF WE
WOULD JUST SIMPLY PROVIDE
GRAVEL ADEQUATE TO WARD HOUSING
AND THE BASIC NECESSITIES OF
LIFE SO FROM AS YOU CONSIDER
ALL OF THIS I THINK AT THE TOP
OF THE PILE WE MUST MAKE SURE
THAT WE RESTRUCTURE GRANT IN A
WAY THAT PEOPLE CAN LIVE ON SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO RELY ON
FRIENDS NEIGHBORS AND YOURSELF
MADAM CHAIR. TO HELP THEM OUT.
HAVING SAID THAT W- THE
MINISTER CAME PUBLIC HOURS FOR
CREEK THIS YEAR WE HOPE
LEGISLATURE WILL FOLLOW THROUGH
ON TE COMMITMENT FROM THREE
YEARS AGO THAT SENATOR MITCHELL
STARTED. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET THE GRANT UP TO A POINT
WHERE NO CHILD IN CALIFORNIA IS
LIVING IN DEEP POVERTY EVER
AGAIN- WE OBVIOUSLY WANT TO SEE
ANOTHER INCREASE IN THE UPPER
BY GRANTS WE- I'M SHARING WITH
SO SANDERS ALSO COMPETENT.
MISTER JAMES FROM APPROVED
BANKING COMMENTED EARLIER- WE
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE
HOUSING DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR. AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT IN IN THE
SPIRIT OF THAT THAT WE CAN
EXPAND OUT THE USE OF THAT AND
MAKE SURE THAT WERE ALSO IN A
WHIRLWIND AFTER BY RECIPIENT.
WHO ARE NOT CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS BUT WHO ALSO WOULD BE
A DON'T HAVE ABSOLUTE BY YEAH
THAT COULD GET IT SIMPLY WOULD
PROVIDE THE RIGHT APPLICANT THE
OPPORTUNITY. WE THINK THE
FUNDING IS GREAT NOW WE JUST
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROGRAM REGION ALL OF THE-
FOLKS THAT IT NEEDS TO REACH.
WE ARE HAPPY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PUT FORWARD A
PROPOSAL IN POWER OVERPAYMENT.
THIS IS A GOOD THING- WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IT GO FURTHER AND
HOPE THAT WE CAN JUST SIMPLY
WAIT MANY BEES OVER PAYMENTS.
THAT WERE DUE TO PANDEMIC
CONDITIONS. THAT WERE NOT
APPALLED WITH THE CLIENT- THE
LAST WEEK WE'D LIKE TO JOIN THE
COMMON. OF A MISSILE K. KNOWS.
EARLY ABOUT THE K. WORSE
BUILDING. AND THE NEED TO
RESTORE THE THIRTY NINE DOLLARS.
IN THAT WOULD CUT FROM LAST
YEAR. THAT IS A CRITICAL
PROGRAM INFRASTRUCTURE WE'RE
TRYING TO BUILD OUT OVER TIME.
AND WE THINK WE CAN CLEARLY
AFFORD AT THIS YEAR AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO INCLUDE IT IN
THE FINAL BUDGET PRODUCT- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR. YOUR TIME
TONIGHT. THANK YOU HOUSE
QUICKNESS COLOR PLEASE. TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY. S. JUSTIN
GARRETT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES THAT
SPEAKING THE PART B. WHEN I
THINK ADMINISTRATION FOR A
NUMBER OF KEY INVESTMENTS TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF FAMILIES
AND AFFORDABLE CALIFORNIANS IN
PARTICULAR WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THE INCLUSION OF THE PROPOSAL
THAT SIX PACK AND PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SPONSORING TO
PROVIDE CONTINUITY CRISIS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING FUNDING
MECHANISMS ALSO WANTED
KNOWLEDGE YOU THINK
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THEIR SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL. I WE WOULD
KNOW THERE IS ONE DIFFERENCE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE RELATED TO HOW
MANY TIMES THE COUNTY CAN USE
THE 10% OVER THREE YEARS TOOL
WE CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE THE
COUNTY SHOULD NOT BE LIMITED TO
USE OF THIS TOOL I WE ALSO
APPRECIATIVE OPPOSING VESTMENTS
FOR COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS AND
PREVENTION SERVICES FOR CHILD
WELFARE LOOK FOR FORWARD TO
LEARNING MORE DETAILS OF THE
PACKAGE PROPOSALS AND
COLLABORATING. ON THE
CONTINUING NEED IN THESE
PROGRAMS. I MUCH THANK YOU NICE
COLOR PLAY. ONE HUNDRED NINETY.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF
TRIPLE P. AMERICA SHOULD BE
COMMENDED GOVERNORS CONTINUED
WORK IN SUPPORTING CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND IN
PARTICULAR HIS PROPOSED
CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INITIATIVE BUT WE STILL WITH
MORE DETAILS IN THE BILL BILL
TRIPLE P. DOES HOPE THAT
CONSIDERATION IS GIVEN TO THE
ROLE THAT PARENTS PLAY IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THEIR CHILDREN
IT WILL BE WOULD ASK THAT THEY
MISSED INCLUDE OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARENTS TO RECEIVE EVIDENCE
BASED UPON THE PLANNING
PROGRAMMING. STRENGTH IN THE
PARENTS SKILLS DEMANDS ARE
CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME PREVENT PROBLEMS
DEVELOPING IN THE FUTURE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
NICE COLOR PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE. HI GOOD EVENING
CARRYING CASE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IHS STAFF
SPEAKING ABOUT PART B. ISSUE
FIVE AND I'M NOT I 7% REDUCTION
I WANT TO KNOW THAT YOU AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WERE THE FIRST TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION- TO THE 7%
CUT CALLING FOR REPEAL-
PERMANENTLY AND WE APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH THAT YOUR LEADERSHIP
HAS LED TO THE GOVERNOR
INCLUDING IN THE MAY REVISE
PERMANENT REPEAL OF THE 7% CUT-
WE ALSO APPRECIATE- MOVEMENT OF
YOUR COMMITTEE ON THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE STATE
COUNTY SHARING RATIO AND
ALIGNED. WITH THE COMMENTS FROM
BOTH THE BDA AND FEEDBACK ABOUT
THE NEED TO LIFT THE CAP IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT ONLY WOULD ALLOW
COUNTY VIEWS- THAT CALIBER
THREE WILL TWICE I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE EMERGENCY BACK UP-
PROGRAM THAT BEEN PROPOSED. WE
THINK THAT THE AMOUNT OF
SPENDING WOULD BE SUFFICIENT
FOR THE PERMANENT BACK UP
PROVIDER SERVICES BY ADMIN
ABSOLUTELY NOT THAT MAY REVISED
ONLY PROVIDE A HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WITH THEIR PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES HERE BRINGING UP
THIS NEW PERMANENT BACKUP
SYSTEM AND BACK REALLY I'M
UNBELIEVABLY LOW AMOUNTS- WE
WOULD JOIN WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PUT IN
LETTERS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD. BREAK THE PROHIBITION ON
USE OF GPS AND BELIEVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE BY NED
MINISTRATION APPEAR TO BE
ONGOING AND THAT THAT'S NOT
CLOSED AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
LIKEWISE PROPOSED THAT-
LANGUAGE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON AUTO
TERMINATION OF THE AGENT THAT'S
REDUCE RESIDUAL PROGRAM AND
THEN FINALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON
IMPLEMENTING THE IT JUST THAT
CAREER PATHWAYS- SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I ALSO WANT TO SAY
MADAM CHAIR THAT YOU CAN A
FANTASTIC JOB RUNNING THREE.
SENATE YOUR VOICE OF REALLY AND
I LISTENING TO- ALL THE YOU'RE
DOING THE HEARING. WELL THANK
YOU NICE COLOR. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE. YES I THANK YOU
AND GOOD EVENING I'M LORRAINE
AS THE TAGLIERE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL INDIAN HEALTH
BOARD. AND- AND I'M I JUST LOST
MY NOTES- THEY CAME BACK SORRY-
AND I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
AN INCREASES FUNDING FOR THE
CAL WORKS INDIAN HEALTH CLINICS
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK PREVIOUSLY SUPPORTING THE
BUDGET INCREASE FOR THE
PROPOSED RESTORATION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. OH NINE BUDGET
CUTS AND TODAY I WISH TO
EMPHASIZE A FEW SPECIFICS-
ABOUT THE PROGRAM THE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH THE SS REQUIRES THAT A
VEHICLE TRANSPORTATION COSTS
AND SIGNIFICANT LIABILITY A
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE SIX
INSURANCE BE PART OF EACH OF
THE THIRTY SIX SITES PROGRAMS
IN ORDER TO. ACCOMPANY CLIENTS
FOR SERVICES. IT REQUIREMENTS
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO ENSURE
THE CAL WORKS BY THE PROGRAM
CAN PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
AMERICAN INDIAN COMMUNITIES.
THIRTY SIX I AGENCIES WERE
AWARDED FUNDING TO PURCHASE ONE
VEHICLE PEAKS NEAR THE
INCEPTION OF THE PROGRAM IT IS
LIKELY THAT THESE VEHICLES ARE
NO LONGER USED TO PULL. CLINIC
STAFF SERVING PEOPLE OF RURAL
AREAS CAN FACE WINTER ROAD
CONDITIONS THAT ARE DANGEROUS
TO TROOPERS. SO RELIABLE
VEHICLE IS ESSENTIAL ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WOULD ALLOW FOR THE FOR
THE LEASING A CAR. ALSO THE
LIMITED AMMO USED FUNDS DO NOT
ALLOW FOR THE CLINIC TO TAKE IN
ANY INDIRECT COSTS OR BENEFITS
FOR THE POSITION. THEY CAN ONLY
COVER THE SALARY UNDER THE
EXISTING IN MY VIEW. THE LACK
OF ANY COST OF LIVING INCREASES
IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS HAS
RESULTED IN CAL WORKSITE THE
STAFF NEEDING TO. MOVE ON AND
ALSO RESULTS IN THE DIFFICULTY
OF REPLACING THEM AT THE
CLINIC. ONE EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WAS THE
PROGRAM COORDINATOR. POSITION
COULD NOT BE FILLED FOR ABOUT
FIVE MONTHS PARTLY DUE TO
LIMITED FUNDING. DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS STATED THE PRIOR
MANAGER ADDING MORE FUNDING
WOULD ALLOW FOR SUFFICIENT TIME
TO BE ALLOCATED. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THESE FACTS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK AT THIS HEARING. RIGHT
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD
REMIND CALLERS THE YOU CAN
ALWAYS SEND IN AN EMAIL YOU CAN
ALWAYS WRITE IN AND YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR OF REMARKS
WILL ALSO. BE TAKEN THEM WITH
CONSIDERATION. AND I'D ASK
CALLERS TO PLEASE TRY TO
SHORTEN YOUR COMMENTS IF YOU
COULD NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU
TERM MEMBER THOROUGHBRED ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
BEGIN THE PART A OF THE AGENDA
AND SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION TO
THE FONG BROWN HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED
FORTY NINE. HI MEDICARE KATHY
BEN AUSTIN REPRESENTING OUR
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR USE
AND THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA I
AM- ACTUALLY JEWISH USED TO
CHAT ABOUT TONIGHT- FIRST AND
FOREMOST- THERE IS A MEMBERS
REQUESTING AND IT'S NOT IN THE
MAIN REVISED JOB FOR SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO EXTEND THE
INSTANT SUPPLEMENTARY FOSTER
YOUTH AND NON MINOR DEPENDENT.
TO INCLUDE IN THE THREE MONTHS
PRIOR TO BIRTH- WE BILL
DEDUCTIONS HAPPILY ASCENTIAL-
IT WILL WORK FOR DALTON BETTER
BIRTH OUTCOMES AND HELP THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE PREPARED TO
BRING THEIR CHILL THEIR CHILD
HOME- ON BEHALF OF- IF YOU W.
CALIFORNIA- ON PART B. ISSUE
NINE REGARDING FAMILY FEES MAY
REVISED. WITH EXTENDED FAMILY
PLEASE SCREW- JUNE OF- TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- WE WOULD SUPPORT- A
WAITING FAMILY SHE'S FOR THOSE
WITH THAT- INCOME AT SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT- OR LAST STATE
MEDIAN INCOME THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR FEDERAL FIGHTER
COMING AND WOULD ALLOW FOR
BEST. AND JOB WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE MOST
IMMEDIATE- RELEASED THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE TO THESE FAMILIES-
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME WORKING
TO PROVIDES THE FAMILIES TO
SCHEDULE- YOU SAID THAT IT'S
MUCH MORE REALISTIC FOR
FAMILIES THAT DO HAVE LOW
INCOMES THAT RELY ON SUBSIDIES
ARE SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALL. AT
YEAH LINE TWO HUNDRED FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME IS FIFTEEN BRAIN
I AM REFER THE K. COUNCIL TE
BLIND ONE OF THE OLDEST
ORGANISED AB FOR PEOPLE ARE
BLIND OR HAVE LOW VISION.
SUPPORTING THE SS I SS P.
RESTORATION LET CAL- A-
COMMENTED PEOPLE OF ALREADY
MADE. AS WELL AS DISABILITY
HOUSING HE JUST WANTED
CAUTIONED TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
ONLY 3% OF BLIND AND LOW VISION
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVED THE
RELIABILITY HAITIAN- SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED AND THESE
PROGRAMS CAN BE EXPANDED TO
KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES AND
LIVING INDEPENDENTLY AND SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED. WHEN INTEGRATING
THEM INTO THE PROGRAMS I'VE
MENTIONED THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY THREE OKAY
GOOD EVENING THERE ARE FLOCKS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK AND ON
THE PART EIGHT THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF SERVICES FOR
YOUTH AGES TWENTY FIVE AND
UNDER BUT WOULD LIKE MORE
INVESTMENT SERVICES FOR ADULTS
OF COLOR EACH TWENTY FIVE AND
OVER THE STORE HAS SUPPORT
REDUCTIONS IN DISPARITIES WE
ALSO HAVE SOME RECOMMENDED
CHANGES ON THE PROPOSAL DEVELOP
AND SCALE AT. AGE APPROPRIATE
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IDEALLY WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPAND THE
PARAMETERS OF GRANT YOU SEE
MORE INCLUSIVE OF COMMUNITY TO
FIND EVIDENCE PRACTICES PROVIDE
MORE DETAILS ON HOW THE STATE
PLANS TO SCALE UP EVIDENCE
ABOUT THE PRACTICES THAT
DEMONSTRATE AN IMPACT ON RACIAL
EQUITY- AND ALSO ENSURE STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY OF GRANTEES FROM
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS AND
COMMERCIAL PLANS. IN PROVIDING
MENTAL HEALTH CARE TO THE KIDS
AND ADULTS FROM DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AND THEN ON THE
COVER CALIFORNIA AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE FUNDING- IS DOUGLAS
FROM HELP ACCESS THAT IT BETTER
THAN I EVER COULD AND THAT WE
JUST WON A SECOND TERM. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED
SEVEN. I HELLO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WITH THE TARGET BY
EVENING REPRESENTING THE BANK
BURKE AND COULD YOU I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
TWO ISSUES ON TODAY'S AGENDA
BIRTH TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVES
WERE HEARTENED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
BROADENING AND DEEPENING OUR
CARE FOR CHILDREN YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS WE PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND OUR WORKFORCE. AND
CREATE VIRTUAL PLATFORM. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION PROGRAM WE WOULD ALSO
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE
FUNDS TO NOT ONLY BE USED FOR
ACQUISITION AND REHABILITATION.
BUT ALSO TO INCREASE MONTHLY
PAYMENTS GOING CARE OPERATORS
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LED SANTOS ON BEHALF OF
AT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA WE
ARE SO PLEASED WITH SO MUCH OF
A BUDGET AUGMENTATION THAT
WE'RE SEEING IN THE MAY REVISED
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO-
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS AND OF
PROPOSAL RELATED TO ENSURING
THAT OUR PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
SAFETY ENACTED ADEQUATELY
FUNDED WE WERE EQUALLY PLEASED
TO SEE THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR RAPID
RESPONSE FOR A RIDE THESE AT
THE BORDER. AND THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED FOR
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS AT THE
BORDER THIS IS AN ISSUE NEAR
AND DEAR TO THE HEART OF OUR
MEMBERS AND OUR LOCALS WHO ARE
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
LEND A HAND- TO THOSE ARRIVING-
WE DID NOTICE SEVERAL THINGS
THAT WERE LEFT OUT OF THE
BUDGET THOSE ARE ALL INCLUDED
IN OUR LETTER SO I WON'T GOING
TO GETGREAT DETAIL BUT I DID
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE-
FAILURE TO- RESPOND THE NURSE
FAMILY- VISITING PROGRAM UNDER
HOW WORK- FAILURE TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE PROFITABILITY.
COUNTIES IN THE IMPORTANT
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS THAT THEY
PROVIDE TO THOSE WHO ARE OPEN
AT THE END OF PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES BENEFITS PARTICULARLY
AS IT RELATES TO THE 25%
MATCHING AMOUNT WHICH IS GOING
TO DISENFRANCHISE COUNTIES THAT
ARE ILL ABLE TO AFFORD IT AND
LACK OF FLEXIBILITY AS IT
RELATES IT'LL COUNTY
PROGRAMMING FOR THOSE AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS IT'S ONLY
ALLOWED FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY HOMELESS AND WE HAVE
SO MANY AT RISK THAT WE WANT TO
CAPTURE BEFORE THEY FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS. THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN. SHE
THE NAME OF THIS REBECCA OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE
AGREED WITH MY CARROLLTON THE
WESTERN CENTER ABOUT FULLY
FUNDING FOR EXISTING PROGRAMS
SUCH AS HOW WORKS A NASA
SCIENCE THAT HE PRACTICED BY IT
THAT HE WE URGE FULL
RESTORATION OF THE GRANT TO TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT LEVEL AND
THE FINAL BUDGET. IN PART AB
ONE ALIGN WITH THE COMMENTS BY
LINDA WAY REGARDING THE
PRESERVATION OF OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION ALREADY
ALLOCATED FOR AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE AND COVER CALIFORNIA
TO HELP REDUCE COST SHARING AND
THAT IS NOT FEASIBLE THAT THESE
HAVE THESE PLEASE PUT IN A
REPAIR TO BE INTRICATE
DEDUCTIBLES AND COST SHARING IN
THE FUTURE- THAT LASTLY IN PART
A AND OR HONEST PATH WE WANT TO
SUPPORT THE- EXPANDED TRAINING
CAPACITY FOR PSYCHIATRY AND
SOCIAL WORKERS AND LSO
INVESTMENTS IN THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. WORKFORCE PIPELINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NICE COLOR
PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED THREE.
THANK YOU- MARTINA MOTO FAMILY
MEMBER CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SENIOR TO ME ACTION NETWORK
ALSO MEMBER THE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES TASK FORCE AND THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
SUBCOMMITTEE IS ONE ONE MY UP
COMMENTS AND- TO THAT OF THE
WESTERN CENTER LAMPARD READ THE
BANK'S DECISION AND GUARANTEED
FULLER THE STATION THE ISSUE
THE BY A PROCESS THAT SAYS P.
AND ALSO HOUSING IS ONE OF AND
FINALLY JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TREMENDOUS
EFFORTS. BY THE DEPARTMENT WHO
THAT MEDIA ON ON THEIR EARLIER
EFFORTS ON WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE MOVIE PAGE
ONE BUT DO NOT SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED DVD TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAN REMOVING THE
PROHIBITION OF GPS AND URGING
ADMINISTRATION WORK WITH CMS
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND
ANOTHER OPTION NOT ONLY FOR
PAGE ONE BUT PAGE TWO AND
LASTLY JUST WANT TO DO A
SHADOW- TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
STAFF- SKAGEN RUDY- WE'RE DOING.
A TREMENDOUS JOB THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALL
PLEASE. TO SIXTY FOUR. GOOD
EVENING KELLY REYNOLDS ON
BEHALF OF EARLY EDGE CALL
CALIFORNIA CALLING REGARDING
PARTY ISSUE EIGHT. EARLY AT
GREATLY APPRECIATE AND THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS INITIAL
PROPOSAL OF ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND NEW CHILD CARE BUT WE
ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR ADOPT EASY COALITION'S
REQUEST WHICH WOULD STRENGTHEN
OUR MAKES DELIVERY SYSTEM BY
FUNDING SUBSTANTIALLY MORE
CHILD CARE SLOTS. INCREASING
REIMBURSEMENT RATE THAT
PROVIDERS CAN JUSTLY COMPENSATE
THE WORKFORCE THAT HAVE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES THE PANDEMIC WE
ALSO ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER POLICY ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS TO
STABILIZE AND STRENGTHEN THE
EASY THEM AS PROPOSED IN SB
FIFTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NICE COLOR PLEASE. TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE. THE
INTERNET THAN WHAT CHILDREN NOW
WE WERE THANKFUL TO SEE THE
ELIMINATION OF CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES THE TENSION AND ALL
COMPETE TO SEE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDED SOME
FUNDING FOR PREVENTION SERVICES
RELATED ASSETS YES THEY
ALTHOUGH WE DO THINK THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IS INFORMATION
AND HOPE TO SEE AN INCREASE.
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO STRONGLY
ECHO THE L. A. L. A. L. CONCERN
ABOUT THE GAP IN PANDEMIC AT
THE CONCERT CHILDREN YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE LIVING WITH
RELATIVES REPORT BADLY THAN
GUARDIANS OCCURRED PRICING THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
DENY THE FAMILY PANDEMIC
REGARDLESS TO THE POINT THE
CHILDREN YOUTH AND THEIR CARE
WE CAN GENERALLY HELP THE
LEGISLATURE WILL ENSURE THAT
BETWEEN THE DRIVE IN THE FINAL
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY. GOOD
EVENING SIR MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH CLUES AND I AM A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH CALLING
FROM VENTURA CALIFORNIA TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND HEALTHY FUTURES FOR
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE
INSURANCE SETTLEMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED SIXTY SIX.
DANIELLE MORE LABOR TO
CALIFORNIA LIGHT JOHN KELLY
SERVICES THE FIRST ITEM LIKE TO
COMMENT ON IT ONE I AND SHE
LATER CALIFORNIA WITH SERVICE
AGENCY OTHER AND YOU FOR YOUR
HELP INITIATIVES WE APPLAUD
GOVERNOR FROM FOR THIS
INVESTMENT INSURANCE HE WILL
HELP WANT TO REITERATE THE
URGENT NEED THAT CAN RIGHT NOW
OUR MEMBER AGENCIES ARE
COMMUNITY PROVIDER SERVING
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS THAT
YOU. I INVENTED CAL AND ARE ALL
FORTY INCREASED DEMAND FOR
SERVICES INVOLVED HIGHER LEVELS
OF NEED ANY HUGE WE MIGHT BEST
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
ADDRESS THE ISSUES WORK RELATED
TO WORKFORCE AND IN GREAT DAY
WE ARE PROVIDER SHORTAGE ACROSS
ALL THAT BOTH WHITE AND LYFT
UNLIKE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU
MINISTRATION ON THE WORK FORCE
COMPONENT WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTING THE WORK OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION WHAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING WITH THE STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE WHICH IS
UNDER ITEM NUMBER ONE UNDER A
MAJOR SO HE DEFINITELY THEY'RE
NOT WE ARE PART OF THE
COALITION INCREASE WILL BE
GRANTED A VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE PROPOSAL. IN YOU ISSUE. WE
SUPPORT BY THE COMP. AND
PROVIDES SERVICE IN BACK. I
REMEMBER ORDER. ARE MANY.
COMPLEX NEEDS ONLY LOOK FORWARD
TO PARTNERING WITH RECOUNTED ON
THE- THAT. WE OFFER- TWO ONE.
TO YOUR. TO THERE ARE 1100% OF
ALL YOU CAN IN THE SEARCH BOXES
HERE. HERE I THINK YOU KNOW AND
HELP YOU KEEP BERMAN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
ELENA TEMPORARY WITH NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA
HAS TAKEN GREAT STRIDES TO
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ACA
UNFORTUNATELY FAMILIES ENROLLED
IN COVERED CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
HAVE DEDUCTIBLES BETWEEN FORTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS IS
NOT SUSTAINABLE WE ASK FOR THE
PRESERVATION OF OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION ALREADY
ALLOCATED FOR AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE TO CONTINUE-
CALIFORNIA. BY REDUCING COST
SHARING AND IF SUCH CHANGES
AREN'T FEASIBLE FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THEN WE ASK THAT THE
ALREADY ALLOCATED STATE
SUBSIDIES WOULD BE PUT IN THE
RECORD THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. NICE COLOR PLEASE. TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN. EVERYONE
MY NAME IS ALEXIS OPINA AND
I'M- CALIFORNIA WELL FROM LOS
ANGELES AND I'M A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
A COALITION OF MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND FORTY ORGANIZATIONS.
AT THE POINT HERE THAT SEVEN.
THE HIGH GET PAID SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND HEALTHY
FUTURES FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PROPOSAL TO ATTEND THE INTENT
SACRAMENTO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER HE'S. TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY NINE HI THERE I
BEYOND THE BOMB THREAT WITH
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY WERE
NONPROFIT ADVOCATE FOR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY MANY
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS LOG
ACTUALLY- THE SELF EMPLOYED AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES ARE PAYING
DEDUCTIBLES OF FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR COVER CALIFORNIA ONE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER I SPOKE TO THE
OTHER DAY MADE TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND TWENTY
TWENTY AND- HAPMAP THEIR
HEALTHCARE- SO I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE CONTINUE TO HELP OUR
SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY BANK
CREASING COST SHARING REDUCTION
OR PRESERVE THE SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
ALLOCATED FOR AFFORDABILITY AT
THAT THEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO HUNDRED FORTY SIX. HI THIS
IS STEVE WEISS FROM BAY AREA
LEGAL AID. THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE INVESTMENTS IN THE REVISED
BUDGET- I AM JUST CALLING TO
COMMENT ON A FEW THINGS- I
SECOND THE COMMENTS OF MY
CARROLLTON WESTERN CENTER-
ENCOURAGE YOU TO INCREASE YOUR
SUPPORT. FOR THE PROGRAMS FOR
PEOPLE MOST IN NEED INCLUDING A
FULL RESTORATION OF THE AS A
SCIENTIST BE CRAMPED. AND
INCREASED POWER CRAMPS AS WELL
AS A WAIVER OF CAL WORKS OF
PANDEMIC RELATED OVERPAYMENTS-
AND LASTLY- ATTY- THANK YOU FOR
THE SUPPORT FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR THE HR PROGRAM.
HOUSING DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM I TO- ENCOURAGE OF. YOU
TO ADD MORE COUNTY FLEXIBILITY
TO THE PROGRAM- INCLUDING
ALLOWING ARE MAKING CLEAR THAT
DIRECT PAYMENTS TO INDIVIDUALS
ARE ALLOWED- CREATION OF A
REVOLVING LOAN FUND SUBJECT
INTERMENT ASSISTANCE
REIMBURSEMENT WOULD. OF GET
MORE RETURN ON THIS INVESTMENT-
MAKING CLEAR AS A CALLER
PRIVATE CALLER NOTED THAT THESE
FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS
AND NOT PEOPLE WHO ARE
LITERALLY HOMELESS AT THE
MOMENT- ASKING AROUND WELL
YOU'RE ONLY I'M GONNA ASK YOU
TO WRAP YOUR COMMENTS ANYTHING.
ELSE GO AHEAD AND SUBMIT IN
WRITING OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY. GOOD EVENING- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS THE MON CARE ACT LEAD
HERE WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOUTH MY COMMENTS PERTAIN
TO PART B. OF THE AGENDA
ENTERED YET THAT I'D LIKE TO
FIRST EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THE REMOVAL OF THE PENSIONS TO
CRITICAL SOCIAL SERVICES
PROGRAM AND EXPRESSED THE
CORPORATE TO PROPOSED
INVESTMENT MADE BY THE GOVERNOR
FROM THE PREVENTING EVERYTHING.
BUDGET HOME OF THE PROPOSAL
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
AND FIVE MILLION DOLLAR HOUSING
NAVIGATORS PROGRAMS BOTH
ADMINISTERED BY H. T. T. AND
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT
INVESTMENT ALSO BE MADE THROUGH
DSS ON TWO OTHER ITEMS WITHIN
THE EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS PREVENTING REDUCING
COST YOU COME UP WITH PROPOSAL.
WRITING TO BE ADDING HOW TO
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE THE LIST OF TRAINING
TOPICS FOR SOCIAL WORK WITH THE
PROBATION OFFICER IN THE FATAL
SHOOTING FUNDING FOR COUNTIES
OF HIGH HOUSING COSTS TO
SUPPLEMENT THE FUNDING FOR THE
HUGE PEOPLE UP PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO FOLLOW
UP AFTER YOU. IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE REGIONAL INEQUITIES
THAT EXIST WE REALLY NEED THAT
HELPING SACRAMENTO FUNDING TO
ENSURE THAT COUNTY HAVE THE
FUNDING THEY NEED TO ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAM WE ARE ENSURING
COLLISION OF THE INVESTMENT IN
OUR STATE AFTER YOU THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH YOU'RE VERY MUCH TAX
COLOR PLEASE. TO FIFTY FIVE.
GOOD EVENING LET REPRESENTING
OUR A THREE I WANTED LOOK AT A
LINE MY COMIC BOOK ANYMORE ON
ISSUE THANK- AND THEN I ALSO
WANT TO RAISE THE ISSUE THAT
ARE NOT MINOR DEPENDENT YOU ARE
I'M TWENTY ONE AND OLDER
GRILLOT STATE AND NEED TO TALK
TO CARE PROGRAM WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S NOT A CLICK
THE FACT WE'RE A BUNCH OF THEM
ALL HE DIED IN ONE DATE BECAUSE
THERE'S ON THE PROGRAM. AND
THEN SWITCHING HATS FOR
CHILDREN NOW IN A COALITION
THAT FORTY NINE OTHER ADVOCATE
YOU ARE ASKING FOR AN INCREASE
IN INVESTMENT AND NUMBER AND
YOUR CHILD CARE BREAKS TO BRING
THAT AND INCREASED INVESTMENT
ADDING ANOTHER THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION BUT WE CAN REALLY DO
THAT TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING
ADDED CAPACITY AND COMPORT
NAVIGATIONAL SERVICES WHICH ARE
SO CRITICAL GIVEN THAT-
COMPLEXION OR JUST A CHILD CARE
FACILITY THING RIGHT NOW THANK.
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED
SEVEN TWO. I WANT HI MICHELLE
SOBRE HE WITH OUT A CHILD CARE
AND WILL PROVIDE IN THE BAY-
WE'RE GLAD TO SEE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL CHILD CARE
SLOTS MISTER FAMILIES IN THE
BUDGET- BUT WE WOULD URGE. URGE
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO INVEST MORE
BOLDLY- FOR MORE CHILD CARE
SLOTS INCREASING CHILD CARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE- THIS IS
CRITICAL TO RAISE WAGES FOR
CHILD CARE TEACHERS AND
PROVIDERS- BROWN ALIGNMENT WITH
THE EASY COALITION ON THAT ASK-
AND ALSO AS IT RELATES TO THE
TRACK CHILDREN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE- WE WOULD
URGE. THAT SOME OF THE
RESOURCES BE SPECIFICALLY
DEDICATED TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH FOR CHILDREN AGES
ZERO TO FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE. GOOD EVENING CARE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEXIS AND
I'M A FORMER PROSECUTOR NOW
ADVOCATE I'M HERE TO ECHO THE
NEED EXPRESSED SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF A COLLECTION OF MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND FORTY
ORGANIZATIONS FOR THE SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
HEALTHY FUTURES FOR FOX YOU
PROPOSAL TO ATTEND AND
PRINCIPALEMENT I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT IN APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. RIGHT
WELL I THINK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR- AND ANYBODY WHO DID
NOT GET THE CALL AND PLEASE
KNOW THAT YOUR- COMMENTS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US YOUR IDEAS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US HE COMPLETES.
ALWAYS EMAIL- THAT COMMITTEE
STAFF AND OR THE BUDGET STAFF.
AND WE APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
SUPPORT AND INPUT TODAY. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR NEXT
HEARING LATER ON THIS WEEK
THURSDAY I BELIEVE- AND WITH
THAT- THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.